Da bin ich wieder, Papa. Schön, dass du wieder da bist. Was hast du denn die ganze Zeit da draußen gemacht bei so einem Regen? Ja, ich hab versucht, guten Internenempfang zu bekommen. Hier draußen im Wald. Ja, also das ist perfekt. Aber zum Glück habe ich hier was gefunden, Hunde mitgenommen und dann kann ich heute Abend Freak Show hören, weil die haben voll die lange Pause gemacht.
Und wie soll das gehen? Was hast du denn da gefunden?
So ein USB-Stick?
Also, du darfst jetzt nicht sauer sein, weil das macht man jetzt so, dass man das Internet bekommt und wenn du jetzt hinter dir oder aus dem Fenster guckst. Das ist mein Datenölch.
Warum ist der denn da öfter?
Meinst du, wie viele Airbnb-Wohnungen hier sind?
Ja, und das sind auch alles nur Privatleute, so wie wir, und wir würden es wahrscheinlich auch so machen.
Kommen wir nicht auf den grünen Zweig. Also egal, du bist Amazon Prime-Kunde und froh.
Ja, Moment, nochmal dieses Argument. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass ich keine Probleme mit Amazon sehe. Also Amazon ist als Laden hoch problematisch, Arbeitsbedingungen etc., Nur daran kann ich nicht viel ändern. Daran kann unsere Regierung aber eine Menge dran ändern. Tut sie nicht, ist ein anderes Problem. Sollte sie sich ändern, muss man aber anders gegen vorgehen. Grundsätzlich finde ich ja, diese Leute wollen Dinge haben und wollen sie irgendwie geliefert bekommen oder irgendwo übernehmen. Das ist etwas, was sich natürlich mit diesem ganzen Online-Handel und Versand viel besser automatisieren und optimieren lässt, als der klassische Einzelhandel.
Dagegen sagt ja auch gar keiner was.
Und natürlich ist das derzeit problematisch, dass da stinkende Kleinlastwagen durch die Gegend fahren und Leute ausgebeutet werden. Das war das Wort, was ich gesucht habe.
Leute werden immer ausgebeutet, da können wir auch nichts machen. Die Wagen werden wahrscheinlich demnächst gegen Elektroautos ersetzt. Das ist wahrscheinlich sogar super, wenn der eine Fahrer acht Stunden am Tag Zeug ausliefert, anstatt dass ich eine Stunde im Stau stehe und eine Stunde zurückfahre.
Genau, und die 25-mal am Tag die Radwege zu parken.
Was aber nicht cool ist, ist, wenn ich bei Amazon drei Sachen bestelle und alle drei Sachen einzeln komme, weil das lauter Einzelhändler sind und nicht mehr Amazon ist wie früher mal.
Na doch, selbst wenn es über Amazon läuft, wird es ja geguckt, in welchem Standort alle Sachen verfügbar sind. Oder die Sachen verfügbar sind.
Und das wird soweit in ein Paket gepackt, wie es geht.
Na nicht, wenn das nicht von Amazon-Anbietern ist, sondern von irgendwelchen anderen und dann schickt...
Aber das steht ja daneben, ob der Versand durch Amazon abgewickelt wird.
Jetzt haben wir... sind wir noch in der Klammer eigentlich?
Um die Klammer nochmal kurz aufzumachen mit den Prime-Sachen, weil Tim gerade aufgelistet hat, was er so ausgibt. Ich muss echt sagen, ich habe nur Apple Music, ich glaube, mein Bruder zahlt Netflix, ich nutze es aber in der Tat nicht im Sommer. Und statt YouTube dir das Geld hinzuwerfen, werfe ich halt in der Tat über Patreon.
Und du trägst dann die Werbung.
Welche Werbung?
Also du lässt dir von YouTube die Infrastruktur-Dienstleistung schenken.
Ja, weil sie verdienen ja genug über andere.
Aber sagen wir mal, bei YouTube kommt ja nur Werbung, wenn man richtig viel konsumiert. Ich sehe die ja nie, die Werbung.
Du hast Ad-Block.
Die kommt aber auch so erst, wenn man zu viel wie YouTube geguckt hat. Dann kommen ja das mit den drei Sekunden. Und wenn man noch mehr guckt, dann kommt es auch nicht nur drei Sekunden, sondern 15 oder so was, richtig? Das ist so gestaffelt. Das heißt, ich gucke nicht so viel wie ihr.
Also auf dem Telefon habe ich es in der Tat, dass ich dann die Werbung kurzertrage. Ich gucke halt nicht so häufig übers Telefon.
Oder mein Ad-Block, das ist wirklich sehr gut. Als ich noch Ad-Block benutzt habe, habe ich keine Werbung gesehen. Ab und zu musste ich mal das Video reloaden, wenn dann der Werbeblock kam, aber Werbung war weg.
Also der Erfolg von Amazon ist auf jeden Fall vor allem die Verpeilung der anderen. Was hätten die alle so früh schon alle richtig machen können? Ich weiß noch, als das losging hier mit Büchern, ich soll mir Bücher im Internet kaufen. Ich gehe doch in meinen Buchladen, die ganze Diskussion, ne? Hatten wir dann am Laufen im Meter und das war irgendwie schon so ein Schmerz am Anfang. War man ja schon, hat kommen sehen, was sich da entwickelt.
Also ich hab echt viele Bänke bei Amazon bestellt, aber ein Buch glaube ich.
Nicht mal ein Programmierbuch.
Denn das hat nur alte Programmierbücher.
Ja, als ich meine Programmierbücher gekauft habe, da gab es noch keine Amazon.
Nicht ablenken. Was ich meine ist, ihnen ist es halt gelungen, eine Arbeit, jetzt wird für die Hörer und Hörerinnen das Eis vorbereitet. Jetzt wird schön geschmatzt und die Streamingzahlen brechen an.
Es gibt schon auch Läden, die das mit dem Delivery und mit dem Bestellen und so, wo das alles prima super läuft. Also das geht schon.
Und da sind Bücherläden die besten?
Letztes Jahr für mein Fahrrad brauchte ich lauter Teile. Da gab es so eine Fahrradboot. Ich glaube, ich habe sogar zwei verschiedene gefunden. Da kannst du prima auswählen, die haben einen geilen Shop. Da kannst du Plus, Plus, Minus, Minus drücken. Also wie sich das in so einem Warenkorb gehört. Du sagst am Ende, hier schickt mal. Da kannst du auch anrufen und sagen, hier hat mich vertan, könnt ihr das mal noch tauschen und so weiter. Und ich will hier Upgrade aufs bessere. Und das ging alles und super und easy. Und der meinte, wenn es nicht passt, dann soll ich es einfach zurückschicken. Wäre auch alles gar kein Problem. Also das geht alles.
Also ich finde, gerade das mit dem Bestellen und Hinliefern lassen bei Bücherläden, also ja, ich lese Bücher, geht total super. Weil, also hier ist ja auch so ein kleiner Buchladen bei uns um die Ecke. Da kann man hingehen und der hatte das mit Lieferung am nächsten Tag. Okay, dann holst du es halt ab. Aber ich meine, wenn du dir was bestellst bei Amazon und selbst wenn es am nächsten Tag kommt, klingelt der Haini wahrscheinlich am Ende wieder nicht. Und du hast es dann doch erst zwei oder drei Tage später, weil das wieder irgendwo beim Späti abgibt.
Wenn du Glück hast. Und jeder von uns hatte schon die allerdolsten Paket Nachverfolgungsgeschichten. Ich bin mir sicher.
Aber das Problem wird sich von alleine lösen.
Welches?
Durch die Auslöschung der Menschheit.
Nee, durch intelligentere Zustellstrategien. Da passiert ja wirklich eine Menge. Also allein so diese Locker-Dinger, diese ganzen Paket-Stationen.
Alles was für Hipster in den Städten.
Zukünftig auch in den Häusern. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt hier mit irgendwie, wir legen dein Paket in dein Auto, ob das so erfolgreich sein wird.
Das ist auch so amerikanisch. Ich glaube, ich verstehe ja nicht, wieso überhaupt so eine Idee kommt, sowas in Europa anzubringen.
Das ist halt für Vororte genau, sowas läuft hier in der Großstadt.
Kunden, die drive in Geldautomaten.
Nicht nur für Vororte, es ist gerade für die Stadt interessant.
Die finden da mein Auto nie.
Ja, aber dein Auto findet sich. Wir haben jetzt GPS. Schmatz nicht so.
Wedern, Schmatzen, scheißegal.
Also von allen Services, die ich gerade bezahle, würde ich wahrscheinlich Netflix am ehesten, weil ich das sehr selten benutze, abwählen. Aber das teile ich mir gerade mit zwei Leuten.
Das kann man sich auch teilen. Ich habe auch das von meinem Kumpel. Das ist super. Ich habe übrigens keinen bezahlten Schalbes pro Monat. Null.
Du teilst dir, aber du zahlst nicht.
Das heißt, du schmarotzt.
Du schmatzt und schmarotzt.
Mein Kumpel zahlt halt. Der hat nur mal vier Zugänge. Netflix findet das anscheinend super, also machen wir das so.
Du hast gerade nur kein monatliches Bezahlen, weil wir keinen WoW spielen, das ist zu warm.
Das ist aber zocken und nicht...
Ja, genau.
Ich würde auch gerne mal wieder WoW spielen...
.kündige ich dein Netflix, wenn du jetzt einen Monat lang mal segeln wärst? Ja, und weil man wahrscheinlich auch nicht... Kündigen wir da ein bisschen aufwendig bei WoW, könnte man dann einen Monat Pause machen.
Das geht bei Netflix auch. Soweit ich weiß. Ja, doch, hab ich schon mal gemacht sogar.
Ja.
Was ist jetzt die Moral von der Geschichte?
Was übrigens ihr hört hier übrigens, ist Mango Raspberry, nebenbei.
Das ist wirklich sehr lecker.
Ja, ich bin auch gleich fertig.
Keine Schleichwerbung.
Also, wenn es mal eine andere einkaufende Plattform gibt, wo ich irgendwie... auch meine komplette Historie habe. Ja, die Touran-Kauf-Experience ist jetzt nicht die Schlechteste.
Nee, ich würde das nämlich auch sagen.
Die ist sogar ziemlich gut.
Der Laden ist aber auch erfolgreich und vor allem, die haben auch einen korrekten Support.
Und der Musikladen in Berlin oder die Musikläden, die kannst du fast alle komplett in der Pfeife rauchen.
Hey, der Gitarrenladen, die zwei Gitarrenläden in Schlottenburg, die sich gegenüber sind, die sind wirklich sehr gut.
Aber es gibt sehr viel, sehr viel Schlechte.
Man kann Eisbrüste auch essen, ohne zu schmelzen.
Macht nicht so viel Spaß.
Man schmelzt einfach fließend.
Wir lassen die Hörer mindestens daran teilhaben.
Das ist eine Freak Show, wie sie im Buch steht.
Allein dieses History-Feature. Was habe ich vor acht Jahren da mal gekauft? Wie hieß diese Produktkarte?
Aber das ist bei Amazon lückenhaft. Ich weiß genau, dass ich bestimmte Dinge bei Amazon bestellt habe vor so einem Zeitraum und die sind nicht mehr da.
Weil sie sich mit der Firma zerstritten haben wegen irgendwelchen Gebühren, und dann nehmen sie die komplett raus.
Also die Produkte, die nicht mehr verfügbar sind, sind noch in meiner Historie.
Kann ich nicht bestätigen.
Ich habe vorhin nach meiner Heftzange gesucht.
Na, hast du Glück gehabt. Ist aber nicht...
Ich finde alles.
Ich nicht. Das kann sein. Wenn das ein Feature ist, kann man nochmal drüber reden.
Okay, beenden wir diese Plattform-Diskussion.
Kann man die ganzen Klammern wieder zumachen, damit wir zum Original-Thema kommen? Oder ist das dann komplett abgeschlossen?
Das Original-Thema ist jetzt abgeschlossen.
Hier gibt es noch das Thema, das finde ich lustig, Pizza bestellen 2018.
Genau, aber wir wollten ja eigentlich abschließen mit, wir würden für Twitter auch bezahlen, wenn es in Ordnung ist. Das ist jetzt eigentlich die Management Executive Summary.
Ich finde das Thema hört sich lustig an.
Wir könnten über Urlaub reden, aber ich will vielleicht mal was anderes vorherziehen. Habt ihr gehört, dass Apple Pay kommen soll jetzt endlich?
Mehrfach. Immer wieder aufs Neue.
Seit Jahren. Aber diesmal wird es noch konkreter. So war es noch nie so konkret, oder?
Na ja, Apple hat gesagt, dass es in Deutschland kommt.
Schicken sie den Daten-Elch auch dazu, damit du dann überall bezahlen kannst.
Was schicken sie dazu?
Einen Daten-Elch, damit du auch wirklich dann überall...
Daten-Elch!
Ja, dann musst du dann durch die Straßen reiten.
Elch-Pay. Da hat es erstmal ganz sinnvoll, wenn man diese drögen Kassiere in Deutschland erst mal adressiert von der Bank, oder wie auch immer, dass die das kapieren, wie das geht. Dass sie mir dann immer wieder ein Zettel hinlegen, und dann schreiben sie hier.
Das ist so ein interessanter Punkt, weil ich meine, was sich ja viele Leute nicht so richtig klar machen, und ich muss zugeben, das auch noch nicht vollständig durchdrungen zu haben, aber im Prinzip ist es ja so, wenn du heute so eine Bankkarte hast, ich sag mal Bankkarte, dann...
Hatte ich auch schon Wifi.
Hast du ja die Möglichkeit, das ist nicht bei jeder Karte unbedingt so, aber du hast verschiedene Bezahlsysteme auf einer Karte.
Du kannst die Chipkarte reinstecken, du kannst sie durch Magnetkartenleser ziehen oder kannst sie oben drauf legen.
Nein, nein, auch wenn du die Chipkarte einsteckst, hast du ja dann die Möglichkeit, oder solltest du zumindest, meiner Meinung nach ist es eigentlich rechtlich vorgeschrieben, dass du die Möglichkeit hast zu wählen, womit du dann auch bezahlst.
Wie es bei den Bahnautomaten ist.
Da wird man so gefragt.
Nämlich?
Ob du mit der EC-Karte oder mit der Geldkarte, und ich weiß nicht, was das Dritte ist.
Diese Fragen sind voll verwirrend, weil ich immer auf die falsche Anzeige gucke, während auf dem Hauptbildschirm steht, wie ich bezahle. Und dann denke ich, wann kommt dann endlich mal meine Pin-Abfrage?
Die User Experience ist natürlich aulig. Oft hast du dann diese Nachfrage nicht. Und dann verstehst du ja auch, ob kein Mensch weiß, was jetzt irgendwie Maestro ist und Pipapo. Aber dann eigentlich müsstest du auch wählen können, ob du mit PIN bezahlst oder dieses Lastschriftsystem erlaubst.
Erzähl, lass mal eine Tankstelle.
Ich dachte, das ist von Betrag abhängig.
Nee, die wollen Geld sparen, weil das ohne PIN billiger ist. Und dann riskieren sie lieber, dass du eventuell die bescheißt, weil da kriegen sie nämlich keine Rückerstattung, wenn das Betrug war oder irgendwie so. Ja, aber das kann ja halt eben gefaked sein. Ja, oder sie haben die Karte geklaut.
Ich habe so den Eindruck, das ist, also bin mir nicht sicher, das ist jetzt nur eine Vermutung. Also beim Supermarkt, wo man jetzt öfter einkauft, da kennen sie ja dann deine Nummer. Und dann könnte das Kassensystem sagen, ah, okay, letztes Mal hat der PIN eingegeben, den gibt's offenbar. Da können wir jetzt hier auch Lastschrift machen. Dann sparen wir uns wieder ein paar Cent.
Ja, außer sie wurde geklaut und er geht im gleichen Laden einkaufen.
Oder auch sie benutzt eine Apple-Uhr oder ein Telefon, wie dann mal eine andere Nummer rauskommt.
Genau, das ist nämlich so ein Aspekt von Apple Pay, der mir schon mal sehr gut gefällt, dass ich wieder unter Kontrolle habe, ob ich für den Supermarkt eigentlich erkennbar bin. Weil zahl ich mit dem selben Zahlungsprozent...
Also Apple Pay ist eigentlich so wie Bargeld, oder? Die wissen nix, der Händler weiß nix. Aber Apple weiß alles, richtig?
Nee, Apple weiß auch nicht alles. Apple weiß laut eigener Auskunft nicht den Betrag.
Klar, den müssen sie ja wissen.
Nur im Rahmen der Transaktion.
Du meinst, sie schieben da so eine Krypto-Transaktion zur Bank durch und wissen nicht, wie viel Geld es war?
Ist ihre eigene Aussage. Inwiefern das technisch sichergestellt ist, also unmöglich ist oder sie es nur nicht machen, weiß ich nicht. Aber das war ihre eigene Aussage über Apple Pay.
Ja gut, wir nutzen aber ihre Telefone so gesehen. Wenn sie es wissen wollen, könnten sie es wissen, muss man ihnen halt vertrauen. Aber wenn der Händler schon mal nicht weiß, wer ich bin, sondern sie einfach nur sicherstellen, dass sie das Geld kriegen, also ich würde das auch gut finden.
Auf jeden Fall allein dieser Unterschied, dass du nicht eben deine Bankkarten-Nummer abgibst, sondern quasi nur so ein Token, also selbe Zahlenlänge, aber immer wieder neu generiert. Also wenn du mit derselben...
Also sie können dich nicht mal tracken.
Genau, also wenn du mit Apple Pay zweimal hintereinander einkaufst, hat der Supermarkt oder der Händler oder der Geschäftspartner in dem Moment keine Möglichkeit festzustellen, dass es dasselbe System ist, was zahlt.
Dasselbe Kunde.
Dasselbe Kunde, dasselbe Gerät in dem Sinne. Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ein Aspekt. Das ist natürlich etwas, was dir nicht gefällt. Auf der anderen Seite sind ja auch viele Leute sehr bereit, da immer ihre blöden Payback-Karten und so weiter und Kundenkarten mitzureichen. Und das können sie ja dann mit Apple Pay auch machen. Und dann ist es ja sogar noch viel einfacher. Weil du kannst ja dann, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, ob sie Payback auch unterstützen, aber das wäre recht naheliegend. Du kannst bei Apple Pay, zumindest geht das in den anderen Ländern so, für Läden, wo du eine Kundenkarte hast, kannst du diese Kundenkarte mit auf dein Apple Pay noch mit drauflegen und quasi verfügen, dass, wenn du da bezahlst, deine Kundenkarte auch gleich mitgereicht wird und du dann die dir versprochenen Boni auch einheimsen kannst. Viele Leute sehen das ja auch als Vorteil. Kann man ja auch so sehen. Kann man auch anders sehen.
Ich werde immer total fassungslos angeguckt von Leuten, immer noch nach Jahren von Verkäuferinnen in Supermärkten. Nein, keine Payback-Karte. Aber so dieser fassungslose Blick. Aber da gibt es doch so tolle Punkte. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Hier in Berlin nicht so, aber draußen auf dem Land immer gerne. Ich werde immer gerne angestarrt. Wie man keine Payback-Karte haben kann. Aber was übrigens noch sehr lustig ist, ich hatte mehrfach die Experience mit dem Apple-Zeugs, dass dann die Kasse sagt, alles schick, alles schön. Die Kassiererin kommt dann mal an, ich soll ihr irgendeinen Zettel unterschreiben. Und ich sage, womit denn? Na ja, mit ihrem Namen. Aber ich sage, dem wissen sie doch ja nicht. Wie wollen sie das korrelieren jetzt mit meiner Buchung? Das steht da nicht drauf. Auf ihrer Buchung steht ja nicht mein Name. Ja, aber ihr Chef sagt, das ist immer so eine Begründung. Ihr Chef sagt, sie soll es machen. Okay, dann mache ich ein X auf den Zettel drauf. Ich sage, das ist meine Unterschrift. Ernsthaft, diese Konzepte, die sind von... Nee, geht ja nicht nur mit Apple Pay.
Ja, rufen sie dann die Security?
Nee, den Filialeiter. Einmal habe ich die Waren dagelassen, weil da kam der Filialeiter und meinte, nein, deine Geschäftsleitung hätte das und überhaupt... und da musst du jetzt unterschreiben.
Weil du mit Apple Pay bezahlt hast.
Ja, die Kasse hat natürlich gesagt, alles schick, alles schön. Weil wir gesagt haben, Freunde, das wollen wir jetzt ja ordentlich wieder zurückbuchen. Das geht auch, funktioniert auch, mit dem Zurückbuchen.
Ja, wie?
Die können das auf dieser Kasse, können das stornieren. Können das wie jede andere Kartentransaktion auch stornieren. Und?
Bist du das dann auch live aufs Gerät? In welcher Form?
Das hängt davon, wie ich es zahle. Wenn ich es mit der Uhr zahle, kriegst du nur ganz kleine Informationen. Wenn ich es auf dem Telefon zahle, kriegst du immer so diese... diese Payment, hast du so eine Payment-Historie, wo du mit Apple Pay bezahlt hast. Und da kam dann der Minusbetrag.
In Realtime, in dem Moment?
Ja, ziemlich Realtime.
Okay.
Also 2-3 Sekunden nach der Transaktion.
Wenn ich Fund im Laden abgebe, und dann zur Kasse gehe, mit dem Fund-Bong, und dann aber meine... ja nicht Kreditkarte, aber meine EC-Karte hinhalte und sage, buche das mal da drauf. Ob das gehen würde?
Das geht glaube ich nicht, weil sie können doch nur, wenn du bezahlt hast vorher, mit der Karte, dir etwas zurückerstatten, wenn es mit der Karte bezahlt...
Das merkst du immer dann, wenn du sozusagen irgendeinen Fehlkauf hast. Du kaufst einmal mal irgendwie für 100 Euro, stellst dann aber fest, das stimmt irgendwie alles nicht, und dann müssen sie dieses eine Item rausnehmen, für 20 Euro. Dann müssen sie erst mal die ganze 100-Euro-Geschichte wieder kartzeln, um dir dann die 80 nochmal zu buchen. Weil sie nicht einfach... Sie können einfach... Das geht, die Kartensysteme erlauben das, aber die trauen natürlich die Leute den Kassierer nicht. Sonst könntest du natürlich rechts und links auf Kartennummern irgendwelche Gutschriften drauf buchen, bis der Arzt kommt.
Hier kam gerade nochmal die Frage, wie sicher wir uns sind, dass man mit Apple Pay nicht dreckbar ist. Marco hat hier gerade schön zusammengefasst. Apple Pay ist sicher datengeschützt und systemintegriert. Apple bekommt nur die Summen für Statistiken, keine Einzelbeträge. Händler bekommt gar nichts. Besser als Bargeld. Gewicht, Hygiene, Diebstahl, Verlust, Niepin. Die Plastikkarte geht auch nach Sperrung von Apple Pay. Eintritts-, Board- und Kundenrabattkarten sind integriert. Geschäft, Browser, Apps, Inline, In- und Offline, Inline, Offline, Online. Watch, iPhone, iPad, Mac, Storno geht sofort.
Also funktioniert wie gesagt technisch ganz gut. Ich nutze das sehr intensiv. Jetzt gerade auch wieder in Kanada. Ich war jetzt für ITF-Meeting mal zwei Wochen in Kanada. Hab dort kein Bargeld benutzt. In Worten, keins. In diesem Falle war Montreo.
Apple Pay in Italien. Am fast jedem Straßenstand. Da guckt keiner mehr komisch.
Auch in Kroatien geht es hervorragend.
Letty wird auch dabei sein. Das EMF-Camp habe ich vor zwei Jahren.
In England nicht in Italien. Du sagtest, du hast was mit Italien.
Ja, ich sagte was mit Italien.
In London kannst du statt der Eustercard deinen Apple Pay benutzen. Das ist jetzt dein Problem. Im Bus, in der Tube, nimmst du die Uhr oder Telefone und machst ein Piep. Direkt im Bus? Nicht Ticket kaufen? Nein, direkt statt der Eustercard. Rein und raus, Piep, Piep.
Das muss ich kurz noch mal reinquatschen. Ich war ja wieder so begeistert in Schweden. Ich habe kein Wahgeld abgehoben. Ich hatte kurz dieses Mitten in der Pampa sein, da fuhren halt Busse. Wenn was ist, kann ich A im Bus mit der Kreditkarte bezahlen. Ja, kannst du. B laden wir doch mal die App noch für Skone runter, damit du überall fahren kannst. Natürlich kannst du auch In-App-Käufe machen, wenn du nicht in dem Land bist, schickst du einfach nur deine scheiß Telefonnummer hin, deine Kreditkartendaten und es läuft. Ich dachte mir so, ich liebe dich, Land. Einmal so seamless unterwegs sein. Ich hätte dann sogar, weil ich den Rückweg nicht über Schweden schon wieder fahren wollte, die Strecke kenne ich langsam auswendig runter nach Malmö, also Malmö, Kopenhagen, bin ich dann über Dänemark gefahren. Und selbst das hätte ich über die App kaufen können alles. Wo ich mir dachte, boah, ist das geil!
Das ist so schön zu sehen, gerade da unten, diese Integration zwischen Dänemark und Schweden, was den Nahverkehr angeht, so das alles ein System.
Das ist total großartig. Und jetzt habe ich gerade irgendwie Tickets gekauft, von London dann nach Lettbury. Ich so, geil, kannst du online kaufen, so ein Ticket, in welcher Form willst du das haben? Sollst du jetzt zugeschickt werden oder willst du es dir selber am Automaten ausdrucken? Und ich dachte mir so, oh, nee ey. Wenigstens die Deutsche Bahn hat so eine Option wie ein Online-Ticket, was du auf dem Telefon haben kannst. Aber da, auf dieser Insel scheinbar gibt es auch, sind die da noch nicht so weit, dass die da irgendwie Online-Tickets haben.
Also Oystercard ist auch fein, aber wenn man nur keine hat, dann nimmst du halt einfach Telefon oder Uhr und im Bus und in der Tube so, pizzz.
Ja, leider wird es jetzt für dieses EMF-Camp nicht reichen. Also kurze Erklärung, hatte ich das letzte Mal hier schon. Nee, mein Logbuch, haben wir das glaube ich erzählt. Also wir fahren jetzt zum Electromagnetic Field. Das ist ein Hacker-Camp in Britannien.
Was einfach der geile Name ist.
Das ist der beste Name überhaupt. Letty wird dabei sein, ich werde dabei sein und viele andere werden auch noch mit dabei sein. Und falls jemand noch nach Tickets sucht, könnt ihr gerne mal hier euch noch mal chatten.
Das letzte Mal Visum frei, ja.
Ich, ja mich betrifft das ja dann nicht, aber ja.
Ich dachte, du hast dich ausgebürgert.
Ich denke, du hast die Konvertierung angestoßen.
Keine Konvertierung. Ich nehme die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft zusätzlich an.
Und die Spacken zwingen dich nicht, deinen Tommy-Pasta abzugeben?
Welche Spacken meinst du jetzt?
Die deutsch Spacken.
Nein, das ist ja EU noch.
Stimmt, noch, stimmt. Nee, da kannst du Doppelstaatsbürger. Es geht ja nur um den Prozess, was du hast. Hast du recht, noch ist EU, wenn du es noch schaffst.
Wer jetzt noch seinen Antrag vor dem Brexit abgibt, kriegt beide.
Und darfst du ihn auch behalten, auch wenn die aussteigen?
Na klar, die Staatsbürgerschaft ist ja nicht an die EU-Mitgliedschaft gebunden.
Aber sonst muss man sich mit 18 entscheiden, welchen von beiden man nehmen will, oder wie war das?
Nicht bei EU. Ist ja gerade die Welle, auf der er reitet. Innerhalb der EU werden diese Doppelstaatsbürgerschaften unerkannt.
Wir können gleich noch mal über Brexit reden. Ich wollte ja nur darauf hinaus, dass in Britannien auch Apple Pay schon wirklich über alles. Du hast es schon erwähnt, hier mit Äußerkart, also mit öffentlichen Personalverkehr. Aber schon an der Bar vom EMF-Camp konnte man halt so mit der Uhr zahlen. Und das war irgendwie geil. Ich hatte damals mir so einen Account da mit dieser Buhnenkarte geklickt. Das ist jetzt irgendwie alles ausgelaufen. Von daher habe ich derzeit keinen Apple Pay. Aber naja, ich nehme mal an, dass wir im September wohl dann die Möglichkeit haben, theoretisch, wenn die eigene Bank, wo man ein Konto hat, auch mit Apple zusammengeht. Und derzeit haben sich wohl nur gemeldet Deutsche Bank.
Denen die Postbank gehört inzwischen, aber die Postbank ist erst mal noch nicht dabei.
Okay, N26, Theodor und alles andere war im Wesentlichen unklar. Also die haben sich irgendwie ganz klar dazu geäußert. Das ist auch nicht überraschend. N26 macht das wohl in anderen Ländern schon überall. Theodor wird auch dabei sein. Das interessiert mich natürlich nicht, weil das irgendwie keine richtigen Banken sind. Ob die Sparkassen dabei sind, ist unklar.
Ja, die haben so ein Statement abgelassen. Ich habe das gerade nur gesehen, wo...
Wir beobachten den Markt oder wie?
Das sagen sowieso alle, aber bei der Sparkasse stand noch, dass sie ja jetzt schon eine App hätten, die mit NFC bezahlen. Und Apple könnte sich ja dem Prozess gerne anschließen.
Sie können sich noch umgucken, wenn das mal losgeht.
Ja, das ist ja alles ein fortgesetzter Fail.
Und ING-DiBa, bei der ich ja eigentlich ganz zufrieden bin, die auch in anderen Ländern schon überall Apple Pay unterstützen, haben dann für Deutschland aber auch genau diese. Wir beobachten das jetzt erst noch mal. Was ist da hinter den Kulissen los, dass die in Deutschland alle sich so quer stellen? Das möchte ich echt irgendwann mal genau wissen.
Ja, also es ist ein bisschen unklar. Commerzbank will wohl auch, kommen direkt quasi nicht so sicher. Also es ist wie alles ein bisschen verwirrend. Boon, dieser Virtual-Creditcard-Laden, wird es wohl dann auch in Deutschland anbieten. Da kann man sich dann quasi so einen Account klicken und lädt den auf. Also wenn jetzt gar keine Bank, mit der man ein Kundenverhältnis hat, funktioniert, könnte man halt das machen. Aber dann müsste man schauen, wie die Kosten dafür sind.
Aber ihr hattet doch jetzt schon alle Apple Pay über uns im Service, oder?
Über Boon in UK.
Und später dann über sowieso in Frankreich. War noch eine Stufe einfacher.
Ja, aber ich hatte da noch irgendwie 5 Pfund drauf rumliegen. Und dann, die App ist auch zum reiern. Und ich habe mich dann irgendwie gar nicht mehr einloggen können. Und dann ist das irgendwie alles verfallen.
Ja, die Rive Eisenbanken testen mit 100 Kunden angeblich. Das liest man im Internet. Also da bin ich ja auch noch.
Das ist genauso wie die deutschen Telekommunikationsgesellschaften, die jetzt testen, ob man Kabel auch an Masten binden kann, anstatt mal 20 Kilometer über die Grenze zu schauen. Deswegen muss eine Reife Eisenbank erstmal testen, ob Apple Pay funktioniert.
Nee, die testen natürlich, ob die Cobol-Backends auch mit den Apple-Backends kommunizieren.
Der einzige Markt, den sie beobachten werden, ist der, ob die Leute ihre Bankkonten demnächst danach aussuchen werden. Ob die Apple Pay können oder nicht. Und das wird so sein, Leute, übrigens. Von daher könnt ihr eigentlich gleich anfangen mit dem Scheiß. Ihr habt doch eh keine Ahnung.
Wenn ich einmal gewechselt bin, dann wechsle ich nicht noch mal. Die sind dann alle weg.
Die Bank.
Clemens.
Ist auf jeden Fall dieser Hinweis mit der Sparkasse, und wir hätten doch gerne Zugriff auf NFC.
Und Fanta.
Finde ich insofern ganz interessant, als dass das natürlich immer wieder diese Frage nach sich zieht, könnte man Apple dazu zwingen, so etwas zu ermöglichen? Also wie frei muss der Markt an der Stelle sein, dass ein Hersteller, der selber einen Payment-Dienst hat, den auch nur selber mit einem Dienst verknüpfen kann auf dem Gerät oder ob andere diese Gerätefunktion auch benutzen können müssten? Das ist so eine regulatorische, rechtliche Frage. Und grundsätzlich denke ich, wenn hier auch in Europa sich immer mehr Leute fragen, inwiefern man Apple auch in dieses ganze Store-Geschäft und Payment-Geschäft reinreden kann. Dieser Zwang mit 30 Prozent, wenn irgendwas über den App-Store läuft etc.
Netflix zeigt hier gerade den Finger, oder?
Netflix versucht gerade da so ein bisschen drumherum zu kommen. Ist ja auch alles nachvollziehbar. Aber um bei Apple Pay zu bleiben, ist ja so, dass das Ganze eben verknüpft ist mit dieser Sicherheitsfunktion. Und Apple argumentiert mit, naja, da lassen wir euch nicht ran, weil wegen der Sicherheit.
Aber man könnte eine lustige AP machen, die sie ja kontrollieren für das scheiß NFC-Zeugs.
Das können sie natürlich auch nicht.
Das können sie auch nicht. Genau, das könnten sie machen.
Ja, aber haben sie nicht und könnte man sie dazu zwingen? Oder sollte man sie dazu zwingen können?
Aber sie haben sie doch jetzt geöffnet für irgendeinen bestimmten Zweck.
Nein, sie haben nur NFC als Reader quasi, aber du hast halt damit keinen Zugriff auf diese Secure Enclave. Also du hast zwar die NFC-Ausleser- und Kommunikationsfunktion, die ist jetzt in irgendeiner Form da, aber das reicht so noch nicht aus, um das zu machen, was die Banken auf anderen Geräten machen.
Was übrigens auch sehr lustig ist, möchte ich nur mal kurz erwähnen, weil ich es nämlich neulich auch mal benutzt habe. Wenn du dieses Apple Pay hast, dann kannst du ja auch Geld per iMessage verschicken.
Ja, das ist die andere Frage, ob das in Deutschland freigeschaltet werden würde. Das wäre natürlich ganz interessant.
Das ist User-to-User-Apple-Pay.
Neulich hat mir mein Kumpel mal 20 Dollar geliehen, weil man braucht jetzt nicht in Kanada so einen Schein. Hier, Schein, ich so iMessage, da 20 Dollar. Bitz, hat er die wieder gehabt. War so easy, wie man sich das folgt.
Mit oder ohne Paypal?
Ja, mit Apple Pay im iMessage.
Derzeit kann man sowas nur mit Paypal so machen, so einfach. Ja, das wäre natürlich ganz nice. Ich frage mich vor allem, ob das noch mal ein interessanter Spendenkanal sein könnte.
Wenn du mal Subscriptions einführen kannst, kannst du ja schon mal bei denen Alarm machen.
Soll ich dir mal einen Dollar ficken? Er sagt mir gleich, dass du unfähig bist. Man sollte auch mal probieren, Gelde in so eine iMessage-Gruppe reinzusenden. Aber da werden sie wohl dran gedacht haben.
Mach mal, schick uns mal Geld, Clemens.
Schick mal eine Gruppe, genau.
Erstmal schick ich dir was.
Multiplizierst du das? Ich hab den Bug noch nicht gemerkt. Schieb kleine Millionen rein.
BitGlobe, hier ist er.
Das bringt mich zu dem Punkt... Wolltest du noch kurz was sagen? Du quatschst mir bestimmt gleich wieder rein.
Tim Pritlove kann derzeit keine mit Apple Pay gesendeten Zahlungen empfangen.
So sieht es nämlich aus.
Loser.
Aber Tim Pritlove kann ja die anderen Zahlungen empfangen. Und ich hatte in der letzten Freak Show ja mal erläutert, wie das so alles hier so läuft. Und kurz zusammengefasst, diesen Wunschausdruck verliehen, dass doch fünf Prozent der Stammbürgerschaft sich in irgendeiner Form beteiligen sollten.
Hier.
Daraufhin gab es viele positive Reaktionen. Und zwar nicht nur in Form von Tweets, sondern tatsächlich auch in Form von Daueraufträgen. Und dafür möchte ich an dieser Stelle erst mal Danke sagen. Mein Ziel war ja so, auf 1.001 Dauerauftrag zu kommen. Dieses Ziel wurde erreicht.
Der Plan ist erfüllt.
Das heißt, du kriegst jetzt von deiner Bank schon zweites Ketten im Monat?
So in etwa.
Um das Ganze jetzt wirklich auf eine genaue Zahl runterzubrechen, müsste ich erst mal diesen August abwarten, weil August haben viele damit angefangen. Andererseits sehe ich ja quasi auch nur bei SEPA-Überweisung von richtigen Banken habe ich nur dieses Fleck Dauerauftrag. Wenn zum Beispiel so N26 einen Dauerauftrag auslöst, dann signalisieren sie den auf der digitalen Transaktionsebene nicht korrekt als solchen. Das heißt, es landet bei mir auch getaggt mit Gutschrift und nicht Dauerauftrag. Sprich, ich kann einen Dauerauftrag nur daran erkennen, dass ich sehe, von derselben Kontonummer kommt in folgendem zeitlichen Abstand selber Betrag. Sprich, ich muss da mal eine Analyse über die Zeit machen. Und man sieht natürlich im Dauerauftrag wiederum auch nicht an, ob er monatlich oder mehrmonatlich ist oder jährlich ist oder so. Aber so oder so, es lässt sich jetzt schon mit Sicherheit sagen, dass das ganz wunderbar funktioniert. Ich bedanke mich sehr. Keep it coming. Das ermöglicht offenbar mehr, als ich mir so ausgemalt habe. Und ich bin jetzt schon so ein bisschen am Überlegen und Planen, wie man dieses Geld hier sinnvoll investieren kann. Gibt es so ein paar Baustellen, wo schon immer mal ein bisschen was geschehen sollte, Webseite zum Beispiel etc. Und ja, mal gucken. Also, danke. Und wer noch keinen Dauerauftrag gemacht hat, kann natürlich trotzdem noch drüber nachdenken. Vielleicht bleibt es ja nicht bei 5 Prozent. Hast du gar nicht mitbekommen, ne?
Ich? Meistens, wenn ich jetzt nicht hier bin und ich gerade nicht im Moment in einer anderen Zeitzone bin, wo ich was Dringendes tun muss, höre ich euch gerne live zu. Das merkst du ja daran, dass gelegentlich mal so...
Ein Rant über den Chat fliegt.
War mir schon klar. Sag das mal, Dennis.
Aber so nachträglich, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, manchmal, wenn ich so mitkriege, dass hier Sachen diskutiert wurden, dann nutze ich die vielen Kapitelmarken und so und springe da hin. Aber jetzt mir nachträglich noch mal 4,5 Stunden reinzuziehen, das ist mir dann auch meistens so viel Autopanik gar nicht fahrend.
Du hast jetzt genug gesagt.
Soll ich dir auch was überweisen?
Bitte. So, kommen wir mal auf unsere, was wir so im Urlaub gemacht haben.
Welchen?
Ich hatte noch keinen.
Ich dachte, du hattest noch keinen, sogar keinen. Du hast diesen ganzen geilen Sommer keinen Urlaub gemacht?
Nö.
Was hast du denn die ganze Zeit gemacht?
Ja, ja, Sommer ist noch an. Geht jetzt den nächsten los.
Ich bin Berliner, ich war hier.
Ja, aber man konnte ja irgendwie auch nicht so richtig...
Der Sommer in Berlin war geil. Warum sollte ich denn dann jetzt wegfahren? Jetzt wo es scheiße wird, fahre ich weg.
Man kann ja auch die Zeit in...
Brandenburg. Ich empfehle, wenn ich sehr den Stechlin sehe.
Ja, der große Stechlin, ne? Zwei-Klasse-See-Deutschland, ich weiß. Aber für mich ist ja... Dieses Bild, was ich eigentlich jedes Sommer poste, ich glaube, dieses Jahr habe ich es noch nicht getwittert, aber geil Sommer, endlich in kurzer Hose computer spielen. Nee, dann klebe ich am Stuhl fest.
Das ist wirklich der einzige Nachteil in einem scheiß Lederstuhl.
Aber deswegen zocke ich oder arbeite ich auch gelegentlich im Bett ein.
Ich wollte von einem Erlebnis erzählen, weil ich habe mir ein Auto gekauft.
Ich dachte, wir sind beim Urlaub.
Dieses Jahr, das ist Teil der Kfz-Neukäufe. Dein war schon letztes Jahr, ne?
Ja, genau.
Aber Roddy war ja dieses Jahr zum zweiten Mal.
Roddy, zweimal.
Aber das gleiche dann wieder.
Mehr oder weniger. Ich habe mir eigentlich auch das gleiche gekauft. Ich habe mir eigentlich mehr oder weniger das selbe Auto nochmal ein neuer gekauft. Ich dachte ja und hoffte immer, dass man irgendwie auch mal in diesem Elektromobilitätsding mitspielen kann. Aber das war leider für mich keine Option.
So viele Erweisungen, so viele Daueraufträge waren es dann doch nicht.
Nee, nicht, dass ich mir so ein Model X shoppen wollen würde. Da bräuchte ich dann noch irgendwie ein paar hundert Daueraufträge mehr.
Da musst du warten, bis dir die Bank 500 Disketten schickt.
Genau.
Ja und dann ist ja für viele E-Modelle, selbst wenn man sie kaufen wollte, gibt es sie ja nicht.
Erstens kriegst du sie nicht, zweitens gibt es keine, die in der Lage sind, einen Wohnwagen zu ziehen.
Ich dachte, für das Model X, ich wollte gerade sagen, das Model X kann das doch.
Über 100.000 Euro Kaufpreis.
Du, wenn du das über 3 Jahre absetzt, das ist Wahnsinn geschenkt.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Ey, da ist so viel Strom drin, das kannst du locker als Betriebsausgaben absetzen. Machst du ein Podcaststudio und fahrst direkt aus dem Akku ab?
Verstehe.
Alter, 100 kW, da kannst du eine Weile mit podcasten.
Okay, weil hier gerade gefragt wird, ich fahre Touran und ich fahre auch immer noch Touran, das ist so ein Vernunft-Auto, nennt man das wahrscheinlich, ne? Volkswagen. Wie sagt der Otto so schön? Ein Wohnwagen ist zum Wohnen, ein Volkswagen ist zum Volksen.
Ja. Was jetzt für ein Touran?
Diesel? Nein, kein Diesel. Benzinartouran. Ja, Touran Touran.
Prenzlberger Kleinfamilien. I-Standard-Karriere. Ab zwei Kindern.
Genau. Da ist wirklich wenig Glitzer dabei. Ja, sorry, aber der hat irgendwie das, was ich brauche. Irgendwie ein Motor, ein Lenkrad, oben ein Loch drin, irgendwie eine Klimaanlage und einen Anhängerkupplung. Und Platz zum Scheißereintun. Und der Motor war ein bisschen stärker als der alte. Mit dieser Wohnwagen, den ich da durch die Gegenschiebe ziehe, kann auch gezogen werden. Das hat sich auch schon als ganz hilfreich erwiesen. Der alte war jetzt durch. Und als mir dann endlich die Entscheidung klar war, dass ich diesen Kauf jetzt auch tatsächlich mache, weil so oft kauft man in seinem Leben auch nicht Autos, dass man da so mal eben sich auf Amazon fragt oder so. Ich habe dann erst mal lange nach einem gesucht, habe dann so die Online-Portale abgescannt.
Achso, du wolltest was Gebrauchtes haben.
Ja klar. Ein Neuwagen war jetzt für mich keine Option, wegen Geld.
Da hat er ja tausend einen.
Da verfüge ich jetzt auch nicht, dass ich mir jetzt mal eben so einen Neuwagen kaufe. Allerdings wollte ich schon einen haben, der jetzt nicht 10 Jahre alt ist. Ich habe die ganzen Features angeklickt, die mir wichtig waren, und dann die Portale etwas rausbluten lassen. Dann kam das so, dann schaut man sich die Dinge an und denkt sich, hm, hm, hm, hm. Dann habe ich mich irgendwann entschieden und dann habe ich gedacht, okay, alles klar. Dann wäre jetzt vielleicht der Zeitpunkt gekommen, mein altes zu verkaufen. Wann mache ich denn das wohl am besten? Na ja, wahrscheinlich erst, wenn der Neue auch wirklich da und fahrbereit ist, weil dann hat man so einen Übergang. Dann fehlte mir allerdings auf, dass ich eigentlich nur noch in diesem Monat, das war dann der Juli, überhaupt noch TÜV hatte. Und die alte Karre, die wirklich aus dem letzten Loch japste, noch irgendwie tüvfähig zu machen, hätte sich nicht gelohnt. So, wie wirst du jetzt so ein Auto los? Gar nicht so einfach. Du kannst natürlich sagen, einfach verschrotten. Ja, also das Herz hätte ich es gebracht, aber es hätte halt nicht viel gebracht. Und dann gab es aber noch so eine andere Internet-Option. Nee, ich bin dann tatsächlich, wie man das heutzutage so macht, mir das sozusagen im Internet geklickt. Das kann man nämlich jetzt auch machen. Dann gibt es diese Bude, die heißt ernsthaft wirkaufendeinauto.de. Hast du auch eins verkauft?
Nicht bei denen, aber ich war schon mal da, habe mir von denen schätzen lassen. Fand ich aber zu wenig.
Ja, der Punkt ist, man wird seine Karriere auf jeden Fall los. Und das kann auch schon mal ein Feature sein.
War es für mich in dem Moment.
Ich hatte nur noch irgendwie wenige Tage und Urlaub und irgendwie alles brach über mit zusammen. Das Ding musste irgendwie weg. Und es war definitiv nicht in einem Zustand, in dem es irgendjemand hätte kaufen wollen.
Außer wir kaufen dein Auto.
Außer wirkaufendeinauto.de. Genau, und dann war ich ehrlich gesagt relativ beeindruckt. Also vielleicht mal kurz erklärt, wie dieser Laden funktioniert. Also die geben dir sozusagen das Versprechen mit, ich kaufe dein Auto. Wie der Name schon sagt. Und ich nehme an, dass du da alles los werden kannst. Was schon mal das Feature hat, du wirst es los. Und zwar sofort. Du fährst dann dahin, das ist relativ mager ausgestattet. Die haben so ein bisschen Büro und so eine kleine Halle mit Inspektion. Und dann kommt da irgendwie so ein Mensch.
Mit einem iPad.
Mit einem iPad und checkt irgendwie deine Karre. Und das tut er wirklich auf... Also ich war völlig überrascht. Ja doch, ich war schon so ein bisschen überrascht, wie schnell das ging. Und womit der so checkt.
Der macht das ein paar Mal am Tag.
Jaja, läuft dann mit so einem komischen, mit so einem aufgespannten Streifen, rund, also so ein Textil mit Streifen, Durchmesser ungefähr einen Meter. Ich so, was kann das jetzt sein und warum hält der das neben das Auto? Warum? Weil er dann quasi da mit Streifenreflektionen im Autblech erzeugt.
Im Lack sieht, wenn es nämlich eine Delle hat, dann sieht er die schneller.
Genau, der sieht sofort die Dellen. Das fand ich irgendwie beeindruckend. Dann setzte er sich in dieses Auto, fährt mit dir irgendwie einmal im Block und er rasselte einfach in Windeseile sofort alle Bugs runter, die dieses Auto hat. Und ich dachte mir die ganze Zeit so, genau, genau, genau. Ich habe noch irgendwie zwei Sachen gefunden, die mir noch nicht so ganz klar waren und wusste so, okay, der Typ hat einen ziemlich guten Eindruck davon, wie es da im Auto geht, nämlich schlecht. Also das stimmte alles, das wusste ich so. Und ja, deswegen war das natürlich dann auch sehr ernüchternd, wenn man dann sozusagen den Preis genannt bekommt. Ich habe mich dann aber trotzdem darauf eingelassen.
Du durftest dir ein Becher Wasser nehmen.
Kaffee kriegst du noch.
Und naja, wenn du dann sagst, okay, passt schon, dann nehmen sie das Ding ab, zacken irgendwie deinen Schein ein, Vertrag unterschreiben, dann gehst du da vom Platz ein bisschen wagenlos, Tag später kriegst du eine Mail mit hier abgemeldet, Kopie, Fahrzeugschein mit Stempel drauf. Tschüss.
Hast du noch was gekriegt von der LK?
Ein bisschen.
Sag mal.
Tausend.
Na immerhin.
Die war dann aber ordentlich durch.
Was übrigens echt krass ist, das wird natürlich jetzt niemanden überraschen, mich auch nicht mehr, aber das ist trotzdem in Deutschland, du kannst in so einem Auto eine Sonderausstattung drauf haben, was du willst. Aber der Lack, der Lack. Der Lack. Der Lack muss, und da ist ein Kratzer und ich so. Ja, ist Auto draußen Haltung in der Stadt. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Und da und Lack und da. Aber da fährt das Auto direkt zu unten, Sonderausstattung. Ja, I don't care. Aber der Lack, da vorne, auf der Motorhaube.
Ist ja auch ein Vorteil. Du kannst also so ein Auto mit Vollfeatures, mit so ein paar Dellen im Lack, was dir scheißegal ist, also mir zumindest, kannst du billig shoppen und hast alle Features, die du haben willst.
Ja, aber die Frage ist natürlich jetzt, vor allem das Ding ist, nicht die Person, die den Wagen gecheckt hat, sagt dir den Preis, sondern das dauert dann 10 Minuten, viertel Stunde. Und jetzt weiß ich es nicht ganz genau, aber wenn ich das richtig sehe, wird tatsächlich dann, die haben also so ein Backoffice, eine Zentrale, da gehen die ganzen Daten rein.
Auch die Fotos, die der macht.
Und einerseits machen die wohl eine Einschätzung und ich habe aber auch gehört, das weiß ich nicht, das haben die mir nicht bestätigt, aber das haben mir andere Leute erzählt, machen die tatsächlich eine Online-Auktion. Das heißt, die verticken quasi den Wagen, auch in Realtime. Weil Händler darauf bieten. Die sehen halt hier, wir kaufen dein Auto, folgendes Auto, von uns irgendwie gecheckt, die wissen, was hier bei mir ist, wir kaufen dein Auto, was da gesagt wird, stimmt. Und dann bieten die quasi auf diese Karre. Und dann gibt es halt alle möglichen Interessenten. Es gibt halt Schrottverwerter, deswegen ist das mit dem Lack auch so wichtig, weil umso mehr der Lack in Ordnung ist, umso mehr kannst du da Grotflügel einzeln weiterverkaufen, etc. Je nachdem, was das für ein Lack ist, etc. was du für Bauteile brauchst. Oder ob die Karre halt gleich für einen Export, sprich Richtung Osteuropa, geeignet ist, oder eben irgendein anderer Händler, der daran Interesse hat.
Das Gleiche gibt es ja für Unfall-Autos. Da gibt es auch so ein Auktionssystem, wie hast du das gerade genannt? Online-Auktions-Ding. Und die Angebote, die die machen, die sind dann sogar verbindlich. Also solange deine Beschreibung ordentlich ist, setzt du rein, hier Unfallwagen vorne, das und das passiert, tralala, Motor heile, aber irgendwie vorne rechts total im Arsch. Dann packen die das da rein und dann können die sich gegenseitig überbieten und müssen dann aber auch nehmen. Also es sind verbindliche Zusagen. So werden Unfallfahrzeuge verhökert und die Versicherungen müssen dann genau diese Summe nicht bezahlen, die man für den Restwagen da kriegt.
Also das fand ich auf jeden Fall eine interessante Experience und eine moderne Art und Weise mit so was.
Ja, von der Experience war es okay. Der Wert, wie gesagt, der bei mir rauskam, fand ich da nicht okay. Also es war jetzt nicht fies daneben, aber ich dachte mir trotzdem, da habe ich schon andere Angebote gehört. Aber trotzdem war es okay, war freundlich, nett, es gibt was zu trinken da. Wie du genau gesagt hast, ich habe es in Potsdam da mal gemacht, da war nicht so viel los.
Also du kannst auf jeden Fall einen belastbaren Mindestbetrag für dein Auto ermitteln. Das ist natürlich auch schon mal eine Idee.
Weil die wollen ja auch ein Stäbchen machen.
Das ist das, was Mindestbetrag meint, ja.
Kann man machen.
Ich meine, am Ende müssen die natürlich auch was bieten, um den Leuten das abzunehmen.
Was sie bieten ist, dass es halt sofort geht. Das ist ja für viele auch ein Feature. Dass sie sich drei Wochen lang nicht kümmern müssen, sondern einfach hin und her.
Dann versuch mal deinen eigenen Wagen, der nicht mehr so top ist, zu verkaufen. Da hast du dann irgendwie monatelang irgendwelche Leute, mit denen du Termine machst, die drei Stunden um dein Auto rumschleichen, Testfahrten machen wollen.
Und letzte Preis?
Ja, die falschen dich dann auch in Grund und Boden. Und dann bist du auch irgendwann genervt.
Was ich viel spannender finde, du hast jetzt ein neues Auto. Ist das denn schon zugelassen? Wir reden hier über Berlin, ne?
Das war das nächste Problem. Ist es zugelassen? Es hat ein bisschen gedauert. Wie viel? Na ja, lange. Also ich habe dann erst mal, viel zu spät natürlich, weil hätte ich auch schon früher starten können, mal geguckt. So Termin, Kfz-Zulassungsstelle Berlin. Genau, haben wir gelacht. Also es gab die nächsten sechs Wochen keinen Termin.
Bei mir, bei meinem Motorrad hat es drei Wochen gedauert. Und der Händler hat es gemacht schon. Die haben da schon sozusagen ihre festen Termine, trotzdem drei Wochen gedauert.
Genau. Ich habe da ein bisschen rumgefragt und dann gab es interessante Tipps. Und da gibt es mittlerweile so verschiedene Sachen. Also es gibt halt kommerzielle Zulassungsfirmen, die man da befragen kann. Es gibt da aber auch so einen Satz von Rentner-Omas, die irgendwie ihren Tag im Wesentlichen an der Zulassungsstelle verbringen. Die sitzen da rum. Da kannst du da irgendwie auflaufen, sagst du hier, Auto zulassen und dann checken die schon mal die ganzen Unterlagen, ob du irgendwie alles am Start hast. So, ja, hier, da. Und dann musst du hier schon nochmal unterschreiben. Und die kennen ja einfach diesen Prozess. Machen quasi so ein Pre-Processing für dich.
Damit alles später schneller geht.
Und wissen natürlich gern, wie man irgendwie an die sonstigen Termine kommt. Und haben einfach ein ganz anderes Interface in diese Zulassungsbehörden, weil die wissen halt genau, wie die da arbeiten und wo man das irgendwie zum richtigen Zeitpunkt reinschieben muss. Und kriegen dann teilweise erstaunliche Turn-Round-Zeiten hin. Also ich hab davon gehört, dass es andere dann in wenigen Tagen geschafft haben. War bei mir nicht so. Weil, erstens Sommer, also Urlaubssituation. Und derzeit haben die Zulassungsbehörden...
Berlin bloß die zwölfte Ausrede vor oder so. Egal, ob Sommer oder nicht.
Ja, aber das kommt noch dazu.
Infrastruktur, Apokalypse.
Ich weiß natürlich nicht genau, aber es kam noch dazu, dass die, ähm, wohl auch derzeit sehr viele neue Leute anlernen, die einfach noch nicht so schnell das alles bearbeiten können. Am Ende hat es, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht genau, drei Wochen oder so...
Hast du zwischendurch? Damit die Stadt voll geparkt. Achso, okay.
In der Zwischenzeit habe ich Urlaub gemacht. Und gerade als ich im Urlaub zurückkam, war es dann fertig.
Okay.
Und dann konnte ich erst mal ein Auto holen.
Ich habe mir mit dem Tesla letztes Jahr den Spaß gemacht, ihn mal selber anzumelden. Was ist denn das für ein Hubraum? Genau. Der Witz ist, wenn du einen Neuwagen anmeldest, ist es ja was anderes, als wenn du in die Brauchtwagen ummeldest. Die Brauchtwagen ummelden ist ja simpel. Da sind dir die ganzen Fahrzeugdaten schon festgestellt. Bei einem Neuwagen gibt es halt vom Hersteller so einen Zettel, so einen ganz offiziellen Zettel. Der ist auch normiert, so was da alle drauf zu stehen hat. Das stellt natürlich Tesla auch zur Verfügung. Gestern hat die Hinterzulassungsstelle. Und da wo ich den angemeldet habe, war das wahrscheinlich Elektroauto Nummer 2 oder sowas. Jedenfalls kickt er da so drauf und tippt und macht und tut. Und guckt mich dann an, da fehlen Angaben. Kraftstoff? Okay, da kamen aber noch zwei, drei Mal sowas. Ich Hubraum und noch so weiß ich nicht mehr, aber war sehr lustig. Sie war total, und was mache ich denn da? Jetzt schreibe ich jetzt ein Minus in mein System oder ein Leerzeichen oder ein...
Null.
Oder gibt es ja noch ganz andere Scherze. Deutsche Behördenwiererei. Es ist ja so, ich habe ein Kennzeichen mit E hinten dran. Und es gibt ernsthaft Streite darüber, bei den Zulassungsstellen, ob die mit E Bestandteil des Kennzeichens ist oder nicht. Was allgemein üblich ist, was nicht gemacht wird, ist, dass das selbe Kennzeichen nicht nochmal ohne E vergeben wird. So schlau sind sie. Aber bei manchen ist es so, habe ich dann noch durch so eine Twitter-Umfrage festgestellt, manche haben sozusagen, die haben zwar ein Kennzeichen mit E, aber auf ihrer Zulassung steht das Kennzeichen ohne E. Bei mir steht es aber in der Zulassung und auf meinem Schild mit E. Da fragt man sich, wieso, wen interessiert das eigentlich? Ja, das interessiert dich, wenn du mit Handy-Parken in der Stadt parkst und die Spacken vom Ordnungsamt meinen, besonders schlau zu sein. Weil die tippen nämlich immer mein Kennzeichen ohne E ein, dann sagt ihr Computer, nein, der ist nicht eingebucht in System. Ah, schon, drücken sie mir einen Zettel. Dann nehme ich diesen Zettel, schiebe wieder eine E-Mail, hallo, gucken sie nochmal in dem System, ich war mit E eingebucht. Dann kriege ich immer so Ansagen wie, aber E ist nicht Bestandteil des Kennzeichens, steht ja so nicht in der Zulassung, doch steht in meiner Zulassung mit E. Ach so, ja, so, so, so, deutscher Amtsschimmel, wir und so. Sehr lustig. Das E heißt, dass ich ein Elektroauto bin.
Beim Diesel steht ja auch nicht D und beim Benzin auch nicht D.
Dass du zum Beispiel eine Elektro-Tankstelle packen darfst?
Nö, nö, nö, nö, das geht auch für Elektroautos ohne E im Kennzeichen. Die Idee dahinter war eigentlich die, dass man sozusagen einfach von außen...
Moment, es gibt Elektroautos ohne E im Kennzeichen?
Ja, das ist weiblich, ich hätte das meins auch ohne E haben können.
Ach, okay.
Die machen auch manche Leute.
Und warum will man das dann haben? Ich finde das cool.
Vor allem in anderen Ländern ist das cool. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich als Elektroauto-Kennmer bin, dann kann ich zum Beispiel in Norwegen auch auf Busspuren fahren. Was ich jetzt nicht dauernd machen muss oder so. Es gibt auch in Deutschland ein Elektromobilitätsgesetz, das den Kommunen erlaubt, Sonderregelungen oder Sonderrechte für Elektrofahrzeuge einzuräumen. Und die Grundidee dabei war die, dass man sagt, wir machen das einfach erkennbar, indem wir einfach ein E-Feld-Kennzeichen geben. Dann kann eine Gemeinde zum Beispiel sagen, hier parken umsonst. Und die Polizistin läuft vorbei und sagt, eh drauf, alles schick, alles schön. So, das funktioniert aber in Deutschland nicht. Und zwar selbst zu dem Extent, dass ich eine Euro-4-Plakette, diese grüne Plakette an meinem Auto dran haben muss. Weil ich sonst ein Ticket kriege innerhalb des S-Bahn-Rings von Berlin. Weil die Leute, die das kontrollieren, sind so stumpf dressiert, dass sie ausnahmslos auf die Plakette gucken. Denen noch zu sagen, pass mal auf, additional rule, wenn das Kennzeichen E hat, fuck die Plakette. Nein, das geht nicht. Ein Beamter macht nur eine Sache. Der macht nur eine Sache. Deswegen fahre ich jetzt mit einem, ich bin wie ein geprüfter Diesel-Kennzeichen, auf meiner Windschirmscheibe, was ich sehr lästig finde. Aber das ist halt deutscher Amtsschirm. Aber die Idee war grundsätzlich mal da, dass man das macht und dass man im Rahmen dieses Elektromobilitätsgesetzes eben Leuten Vorrechte einräumen kann. Was manche Kommunen machen, manche denken darüber nach, manche machen überhaupt nichts. Dass das E dafür ein Kennzeichen ist. Das ist ähnlich wie diese Tag-Kennzeichen. Das gibt es ja schon länger für historische Fahrzeuge. Aber die haben jetzt selber Probleme mit dem Einbuchen ins Handy parken und all so Zeugs. Aber egal. Ja, schön, wir waren bei deinem Auto. Du hast das also anmelden lassen in schlappen drei Wochen.
Ja, also mehr gibt es jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt nicht so zu erzählen.
Das hat uns jetzt auch hinreichend vom Hocker gerissen.
Bei mir ging es primär um den Verkauf. Ein Nachtrag noch zu diesem Kontrollieren von Pagelraum. Mein neues Nummernschild, und ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr, ob das beim Alten auch schon so war, aber mir wurde das als relativ neu dargestellt, ist jetzt auch ein QR-Code drauf. Also nicht der QR-Code, der QR-Code heißt, sondern ein QR-Code mehr so der, ich weiß nicht, wie der technisch heißt, der so im Amtsbereich unterwegs ist, auf Amtsdokumenten, Finanzamt und so weiter, gibt es so verschiedene Bezahlen, Überweisungen.
Wo ist der da drauf?
Auf der Berlin-Plakette.
Okay, das ist jetzt kein B mehr, sondern das ist ein QR-Code.
Da ist ein B, aber noch so ein ganz kleiner QR-Code. Den siehst du nur, wenn du ganz genau hinschaust. Und mir wurde gesagt, ich weiß nicht, ob das so kommen wird, aber das war eine Aussage, die ich so aufgeschnappt und erst mal zur Kenntnis genommen habe, dass wohl darüber nachgedacht wird, diese Parkraum-Check irgendwann mit diesem QR-Code zu machen. Quasi Scanner an Nummernschild, Piep, und dann über die Nummer, die halt das Fahrzeug eindeutig identifiziert, darüber zu checken, ob da bezahlt wurde. Ohne jetzt immer wieder Plaketten auszugeben.
Momentan tippen sie das Kennzeichen ab. Aber eben manche schlauen mal ja ohne das eh.
Stattdessen so ein Selfiestick haben mit Scanner dran.
Und du meinst, die putzen dann die Nummernschilder dann jeweils fleißig oder wie?
Gute Frage, ja.
Du kriegst eine Strafe, wenn dein Nummernschild nicht geputzt wird.
So wird die Deutsche integriert. Natürlich elektrisch.
Es wird alles schlechter. Es wird kaum etwas schlechter.
Machen die natürlich nicht. Wir stellen ihnen extra Putzkoller ein, die vorher durch die Straße geht, die die Kennzeichen sauber macht. Und dann kommen erst die Kontolettys und checken die Nummernschilder.
Also RYD-Chip hätte jetzt mehr Sinn gemacht. Aber der hält wahrscheinlich...
Das ist zu modern, das ist zu dicht dran noch an der Präsent.
Eigentlich könnten sie auch gleich mit dem Auto mal ein bisschen mit Bluetooth quatschen.
Du bist ja nebenbei. Autos außerhalb des Zulassungsbereichs, wird vielleicht auch noch nicht so weit, sich rumgesprochen hat, ist. Du kannst ja inzwischen, du kannst dein Kennzeichen mitnehmen, wenn du umziehst, auch in einen anderen Zulassungsbereich.
Ja, das hat ein Freund von mir gemacht.
Das gibt es angeblich seit Januar 2015.
War Seehofer, glaube ich noch, hat das verbrochen, glaube ich. Nee, das nicht mit dem QR-Code, sondern mit dem, du kannst umziehen und kannst jetzt von hier nach Berlin nach München ziehen und dein Berliner Kennzeichen bieten.
Ja, ein Freund von mir, der ist auch nach lange Jahren Berlin Aufenthalt nach Dortmund gezogen, aus Gründen, die wir jetzt hier nicht weiter besprechen müssen, aber aus nostalgischen Gründen hat er dann auch sein Berliner Kennzeichen behalten.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ist das in irgendeiner Form relevant, was man für ein Kennzeichen hat?
Klar, wenn man eine emotionale Bindung zu seinem Kfz hat.
Also in dem Artikel, der uns hier gerade zugespielt wurde, ist noch die Rede, dass der frei gerubbelt werden muss. Das ist zumindest bei meinem Nummernschild nicht der Fall und dass das primär zum online Abmelden des Fahrzeugs gedacht sei.
Damit man jetzt nicht 5 Buchstaben, 2 Buchstaben und 4 Zahlen tippen muss.
Da meinen wir jetzt aber auch im neuen Fahrzeugschein, da muss man das abrubbeln, musst schon ganz lesen.
Was?
Im neuen Fahrzeugschein? Genau da kann man was frei rubbeln und dann damit abmelden. Hab ich nämlich auch.
Aber hier ist auch von verdeckten Sicherheitscodes auf dem Nummernschild die Rede. Also unklar.
Auf jeden Fall sicherer mit diesem QR-Code auf dem Nummernschild. Ach Leute.
Genau, durch das neue Verfahren wird Personal eingespart und kostenreduziert.
Welche Information liefert der QR-Code Antwort? Gar keine Informationen.
Es sind lediglich Zahlen hinterlegt.
Tim, du solltest vielleicht auf seriöse Seiten gehen.
Ich mach nur auf, was mir geschickt wurde. Tut mir leid. Wollen wir das Autothema beenden?
Bitte. Schon von einer halben Stunde.
Wer war denn jetzt in Südtirol?
Ich, aber ihr könnt erstmal erzählen.
Ich hab anzubieten Kroatien, Montreal, Frankreich. Du warst in Schweden.
Schweden und Brandenburg.
Ah, Brandenburg hab ich auch. Ich hab mein Landhaus. Ihr habt nichts angeboten.
Dennis? Dennis, du warst auch ständig unterwegs.
Und? Deutschland ist auch schön.
Ich war an der Müritz, an der Ostsee, an der Diemel, an der Möhne, am Edersee.
Hauptsache Wasser, ja.
Im Schwarzwald war ich, die sind ja auch schon.
Harz ist auch überall mit deiner Höllenmaschine?
Du warst auch im Harz, Tim.
Ich war auch im Harz. Wieso?
Sieht aber wie inne aus.
Ich erinnere nur an, ich mache mir bald so ein Ding an den Lenker und dann können wir auch bei 250 facetime.
Hast du schon mal gemacht?
Doch, einmal. Zum Testen. Aber ging nicht so gut. Ist schon ein paar Jahre her.
Warum ging es nicht so gut? Weil du so schnell aus der Funkzelle wieder rausnahmst?
Weil ich in meinem Helm noch nichts im Quatsch habe. Das heißt, auf dem Ton habe ich die andere Seite gesehen.
Soundmäßig hast du nur...
Und die anderen wahrscheinlich auch.
Das habe ich von einem schnellfahrenden Boot in Kroatien auf der dortigen Adria-Güste gemacht. Bild war geil, Ton war so...
Aber habt ihr jetzt aus euren Urlauben irgendwas Freak Show Relevantes zu erzählen?
Das Resümee auf jeden Fall. Also ich bin ich einfach, ich kräsche jetzt einfach rein. Also ich war wie immer in Schweden für insgesamt, kurz noch mal schauen, ich glaube sechs Tage bin ich wandern oder sechs Tage wandern. Meinst du nicht doch?
Vielleicht sieben?
Ich muss in mein Polar-Training-Tagebuch gucken, um es zu wissen, weil ich ja alles mit meiner Ur-Trecke, wenn ich unterwegs bin. Ich war n Tage unterwegs und, genau, wie schon erwähnt, also das nicht nur angenehm ist, irgendwie in Schweden unterwegs zu sein, ohne Bargeld, so Küstenwanderungen sind echt empfehlenswert in Schweden. Und manchmal, also ich bin da echt noch mal an meine Grenze gekommen, an der Küste, wo ich eigentlich nicht so mit gerechnet hätte, dass das so komplexe Wanderungen gibt. Also es hat schon ein bisschen so ein bisschen was vom Klettern gehabt.
Bist du im Sand gelaufen?
Nee, wirklich steile Küstenhänge, hänge ist nicht das richtige Wort, so Klippensteilküste mäßig. An der Westküste, genau. Das ist hier der Kullerberg, sagt dir das was? Und da an der Spitze habe ich nur auf dem Höhenprofil gesehen, dass das ziemlich steil hochgehen kann und auch ziemlich steil wieder runter. Und es war echt so mit Rucksack, 20 Kilo knapp auf dem Rücken, ist es dann halt schon so, wo man merkt, so sehr sportlich, da kommt dir auch niemand wirklich entgegen, weil selbst mit Wanderstücken hast du halt teilweise so Richtung, wie heißt das, Klettersteige, so ein paar Passagen, wo du halt wirklich drittsicher sein musst. Und da ist mir das erste mal so ein bisschen aufgefallen, dass man, also ich nehme ja immer mein Zelt mit.
Dass du zu viel Zeug mit dir rumschleppst.
Das hat man immer mal so, dass du dir zwei, drei Sachen zu viel mitnimmst. Aber so dein Grundbedarf ist eigentlich immer derselbe und da komme ich auch nicht wirklich viel drunter. Unter meinen...
Tolle Tipps hat mir neulich einer gesagt, weil ich auch gemeckert habe in mein Fluggepäck.
Das ist das, wo dir jeder sagt, das bringt ja nichts.
Zahnbürste absägen.
Ja, das gibt es so Freaks, die sich die Zeug so wegoptimieren, dass sie sagen, da unten sind jetzt 10 Zentimeter Plastik zu viel dran, die ich sonst schleppen muss, die sehe ich mir ab.
Das ist jetzt echt so der Punkt. Ich habe so ein bisschen über mich selber gelacht, weil ich habe mir letztes Jahr einen ultraleichten Sommerschlafsack geholt, dazu aber noch ein etwas dickeres Inlay. Falls es so die 15 Grad Grenze hat, dann ist es zum Draußenschlafen manchmal fast zu kalt. Vielleicht ein ähnliches Gewicht, aber die Packmaße waren weniger. Und ich habe einen großen 3-Jahre-Zeiten-Schlafsack, Daune. Und Daune ist halt immer sehr massiv, selbst wenn du den in einen Stopfsacksack reinmachst. Da habe ich so ein bisschen das wenigstens gespart. Und ich habe dann halt in der Tat die elektrische Zahnbürste mitgeschleppt. Ohne die gehe ich nicht gern wandern. Nein, aber mein Zelt splitte ich immer auf in, was der reine Zeltanteil ist, der Stoffanteil des Zeltes. Und das Gestänge extra. Und es ist halt total nervig, diese Pack-Säcke, die die konzipieren, ist natürlich eins in allem zu haben. Und das macht sich aber überhaupt nicht gut irgendwie zum Wandern. Und jetzt bin ich dann irgendwie dann auch auf die Idee gekommen, dass man sich doch einfach mal entweder mal so ein Kompressionssack dafür holt, dass man das halt so wirklich klein und fein wegoptimieren kann. Oder einfach selber mal was näht. 2,2 Kilo, sagt die Webseite. Nee, es ist sogar noch relativ viel, aber ich hab halt ein Zelt, wo man im Notfall auch zu zweit drin schlafen kann. Ohne Gepäck. Und wenn du mit Gepäck unterwegs bist, kannst du als Einzelperson, das ist eins zwanzig, eins zehn, ist das lang. Und ich glaube, das hatte ich auch schon mal in irgendeiner anderen Freak Show. Breit.
Du bist zwar vertically challenged, aber nicht so weit.
Nee, genau, nicht so weit. Eins zehn ist es breit, genau. Das ist ganz cool, weil ich pass mit meinem Wandergepäck auf jeden Fall alleine rein. Wenn ich aber mit jemand anderem noch unterwegs bin, muss man das Gepäck draußen lassen. Das haben wir dann auch gemacht. In Brandenburg war ich dann noch unterwegs drei, vier Tage mit dem Fahrrad. So Rennrad und ein bisschen Gepäck. Auf dem Oder-Neisse-Radweg auch sehr zu empfehlen, aber sehr sonnig. Da habe ich dann auch noch mal das selbe Problem mit dem Packmaß von einem Zelt gehabt. Die Zeltstangen sind das nervigste auf dem Rennrad zu transportieren. Ich habe für das Rennrad ein Fahrradtaschen-System, das du am Sattel befestigst. Dann kannst du eine Fahrradtasche mit einer Schiene drauf schnacken. Dann hast du zwei Seitentaschen und oben so eine Tasche, um ein bisschen was einzupacken. Das reicht, wenn du für vier Tage unterwegs bist. Dann passt das vom Gepäck her. Ich habe dann noch einen Rucksack für das Zelt dabei gehabt. Da war das wieder mit dem, dass du dein Zelt nicht als Rolle haben willst, sondern als Rechteck zusammengefalten. Ich nehme jetzt selber einen Packsack, damit das Zelt optimal reinpasst und ich für meine Ausflüge auf dem Rennrad und beim Wandern optimal ausgestattet bin. Dieses Zelt, weil das nur für eine Person ist, aber bei dem Fahrradwandern waren wir zu zweit mit dem Rennrad unterwegs, willst du ja eigentlich dein Gepäck noch vorne dran machen. Jetzt haben wir auch überlegt, was das Coole an dem Zelt ist. Ich habe so ein Dächlein über dem Zelt, dass wenn es regnet, kannst du es trotzdem ein bisschen aufmachen, um die Belüftung zu befördern. Das hat hinten Ösen dran, dass man so ein Zelt mit einer weiteren Plane, mit einer sehr leichten Abspannung, damit man so sein Rennrad und das Gepäck vorne hinlegen kann.
Ein Hipster-Traum.
Ja, genau, ein Hipster-Traum.
Nicht ein Carport hinten dran, sondern ein Bikeport.
Ein Rennrad-Showroom.
Ein Rennrad-Showroom hinten dran.
Showroom ist es ja dann nicht so richtig, weil du würdest ja die Fahrräder hinlegen, damit du die Lenker dann am besten noch nutzen kannst, zum Befestigen der Asses. Und dieses Träumchen von Wandern gehen oder Fahrrad fahren, und dann kommen diese Ideen so, was könnte man noch für Taschen nähen, falls ihr es noch nicht mitbekommen habt. Ich habe so einen kleinen Taschen-Fetisch. Auch so direkt diese Zeltstangen von dem Zelt, noch eine optimale Tasche zu bauen, die dann wirklich an den Rahmen ranpasst, damit das nicht mehr hinten irgendwo drauf rumflattert. Da werde ich auf jeden Fall demnächst mal ordentlich Sachen nähen müssen, damit dieses Rennrad und Fahrrad uns alles super gut ausgestattet ist. Und genau, der Ted hat gesagt, einmal Kullerberg. Genau, ich kenne mal von dem Wanderweg.
So ein Bullet kommt dir nicht ins Haus, ne?
Na, ich würde es nicht fahren wollen. Die andere Person könnte das gerne haben. Aber ich finde vielleicht auch, so ein Traik ist ja auch was Interessantes für so Fahrrad- und Wandertouren, wenn man mehr täglich unterwegs ist.
Aber wirst du nicht dann voll langsam mit so einem Ding?
Das ist halt so der andere Punkt. Also der Erste Linke ist jetzt mal hier, die Wandertour.
Aber mit so einem Rennrad, was vollgepackt ist, und dann noch mit Rucksack?
Na, es kommt drauf an.
Es kommt immer noch schneller als so ein großer Klopper.
Ja, also ich finde halt auch, auf dem Rennrad hatte ich...
Vor allem, wenn du dann zähltest, kannst du beim Rad noch ein bisschen rumradeln, bist flott unterwegs. Wenn du dann halt so ein Bullet hast... Ja, Rennrad ist schon anders flott.
Aber das ist jetzt auch nicht so eine holländische Holzkastenschaukel. Also, mit denen kann man schon... Guck dir die Fahrrad-Kurriere an mit den Dingern, die durch die Gegend heizen.
Na, die haben ja dann wahrscheinlich auch eh in dem Bullet noch einen E-Antrieb drin, weil ansonsten kniemäßig...
Und die fahren ja auch in der Stadt auf glatten Boden.
Na, das bin ich ja auch. Also der Oder-Neiser-Rad-Trick ist super asphaltiert.
Hast du ein Rennrad, nicht so ein Cross-Ding oder so? Nicht ein bisschen breitere Reifen?
Nee, ich hab glaub ich...
8 Bar!
Ja, das auf jeden Fall.
24 Millimeter.
Wieso hast du überhaupt noch Reifen, wenn du 8 Bar, die da reinpumst? Das verstehe ich auch mal nicht.
Der Trend geht zu breiteren Reifen, ne?
Hab ich auch davon gehört. Ich fand es interessant, dieses Rennrad am besten optimal zu benutzen, sodass du alles Mögliche wegbekommst. Ich hab auf dem Rennrad 9 Kilo gehabt an Gepäck. Das, was im Rucksack war, war im Wesentlichen das Zelt, ohne Gestänge und das Schlafsack-Inlay. Also wahrscheinlich 2 Kilo, was nervig vielleicht ist, weil du was auf dem Rücken hast. Aber bei dieser krassen Sonneneinstrahlung am Wochenende hab ich mich eigentlich gefreut, weil das die komplette Sonne abbekommen hat, der schwarze Rucksack und nicht mein schwarzer Rücken. Das war wiederum sehr praktisch. Also ich mein, das ist nicht ganz so warm dann.
Wirklich?
Ja, ja, wirklich.
Also ich könnte mir Schöneres vorstellen, als bei sonnigem Wetter einen Rucksack aufzuhaben.
Das stimmt, aber ich hab das halt am Hintern gemerkt. Also die Stelle, die frei war und die Sonne drauf gestiegen hat, ist halt richtig heiß geworden, sodass ich so dachte, so unangenehm, lass mal wieder baden gehen. Und so auf dem Rücken ist es halt, wenn du einen Rucksack hast, so ein bisschen schon...
Im Schatten des eigenen Senkels fahren.
Alternativ könnte man sich ja so ein Sonnenschirmchen an das zusammenbauen.
Aber dann ist das Rennrad endgültig albern.
Weiß ich, wenn ich so ein Sonnenschirmchen hätte.
Wäre schon die Frage, wo man sich so ein Ultraleichtgewicht Rennrad holt und dann mit 20 Kilo Gepäck durch die Gegend brettert.
Du bist aber da gelaufen an der Kürze. Die Fahrradnummer hast du im Brandenburg gemacht.
Genau, die Fahrradnummer war jetzt hier Frankfurt oder bis nach Märcherin, was so hoch an die Oste ist. Das sind so drei, vier, drei Tage gewesen. Und in Schweden bin ich gewandert.
Hinten gefahren mit dem Zug oder was?
Ja, ich habe mal wieder diese brillant dämliche Idee gehabt, mit dem Nachtzug zu fahren. Es gibt ja im Sommer einen Nachtzug, der von Berlin nach Malmö durchfährt, wo du...
Über die Brücke, nicht mit der Fähre mehr?
Nein, du fährst mit der Fähre. Und das ist der große Nachteil. Du fährst in Saßnitz auf die Fähre drauf und wirst in Trilleborg nicht aus der Fähre rausgezogen, sodass du in einem stinkenden, nicht belüfteten Zug sitzt und du denkst so, warum mache ich den Scheiß? Also es ist halt wirklich nervig, so bei 30 Grad in dem Zug zu pennen, keine Luft da drin.
Es gibt bloß einen einzigen Nerdfaktor an der Nummer, gerade in Sassnitz oder in Trilleborg. Wenn du da mal anguckst, die haben ja früher viel gemacht mit diesen Zügen. Die haben eine unglaubliche Weichenkonstruktion. Die schaffen das da, keine Ahnung, 12 Gleise oder sowas auf einer Länge von 20, 30 Metern mit einer riesigen Monsterweiche zu verteilen. Also mit dem einen Gleis, was vom Land kommt, oft irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 6, 8 Gleise, die in dem Schiff drin sind. Normalerweise, wenn du sowas an Land brauchst, brauchst du Kilometer dafür, um das aufzuteilen. Das ist eine ganz komisch krasse Weichenkonstruktion, die die da haben auf der Brücke, um diese Züge da rein zu verteilen. Aber ansonsten, das ist das Einzige, was da ein Nerdfaktor ist. Ich habe aber entdeckt, da gibt es Strom an Bord. Ich fahre ja auch gerne mit der Fähre zur Asienstraße Trellebeu. Da gibt es zwar keine offiziellen Eladestationen, aber es gibt dort Drehstromanschlüsse. Und die kann man auch benutzen, wenn man höflich fragt. Das ist nicht, dass man es jetzt braucht. Aber es ist schön, weil du eh 3,5-4 Stunden auf dem Ding sitzt. Das ist die ideale Zeit, wo das Auto still steht, um zu laden. Wenn man höflich fragt, kann man die benutzen. Die sind eigentlich für Kühllaster, damit die ihr Kühlaggregat weiter betreiben können, während sie an Bord sind. Aber wenn die jetzt nicht belegt sind, kann man da mal höflich fragen, kann ich da auch mal meinen Tester dran tun?
Das ist der Grund, warum du da nicht rausgezogen wirst. Man bleibt auf der Fähre stehen, weil dann die Stromversorgung des Zuges gewährleistet wird. Wenn sie dich rausziehen würden, würde der Zug halt keinen Strom mehr haben, weil keine Lok da ist, kein Lokführer und so weiter. Deswegen lassen die dich halt in der Fähre stehen.
Sie lassen dich nicht in der Fähre stehen, bei welchem Vorgang denn?
Das Schiff ist im Hafen angekommen, alle Autos, alles ist runter, nur die Fähre steht noch drin.
Und warum?
Der Zug steht noch drin.
Der Zug in der Fähre, genau.
Weil sie noch keinen Lok dafür haben.
Also du musst dann so lange warten, bis die kommt oder wie?
Genau, es ist ja eh eine Nachtfähre. Theoretisch interessiert es dich eigentlich nicht, aber der Fakt ist halt, die Überfahrt sind zwei, drei Stunden.
Drei und halb.
Drei und halb. Und ich meine, du bist halt ganz unten.
Du beschwerst dich darüber, dass sie dich nicht raus und in der frischen Luft warten lassen mit dem Zug, sondern dass der Zug so lange in der Fähre warten muss.
Das ist ja scheinbar kein... oder irgendwie eine Bläse.
Theoretisch könnte man das aber machen, weil du kannst natürlich auch neben dem Gleis so einen Stecker anbringen, wo du denn die Dinger drauf steckst, aber die Nummer sind sie nicht gekommen oder so.
Wenn da Leute aussteigen würden, dürften sie... also müssten sie aufs Gleisbett laufen und auf der Fähre können sie wahrscheinlich so aussteigen oder so.
Das ist die andere Frage, das weiß ich nicht, ob sie dich überhaupt aussteigen lassen.
Bei den Autos musst du raus. Du hast keine Option, bei der Fährüberfahrt in deinem Auto oder in deinem Camper zu bleiben. Du musst das Autodeck verlassen.
Genau, das darfst du auch nur von Berlin nach Trelleburg machen. In die Richtung darfst du das auch nur machen, mit auf der Fähre bleiben und da schlafen, weil dann die Fähre eine offizielle Nachtfähre ist. Die legt nach 24 Uhr ab. Nach 24 Uhr glaube ich. Damit darfst du drauf bleiben, aber die andere Richtung, da startest du, ich glaube, um 5 in Malmö. Und dann ist es halt offiziell keine eigentliche Nachtfahrt. Nee, in Malmö fährt der Zug los.
Ach so, der Zug.
Genau, und dann bist du in Trellebocken, und dann musst du da raus. Weil das ist dann offiziell keine Nachtfähre. Das heißt, da musst du die Überfahrt draußen verbringen, und dann darfst du erst in den Zug fahren.
Da auf dem Deck, dich da oben mit einer Isomatte, ist auch immer ganz okay.
Aber da wirst du dann, glaube ich, der Zug wird dann in Deutschland rausgezogen. So war es jedenfalls vor zwei Jahren, als ich mit dem Nachtzug auch zurückgefahren bin. Da wirst du rausgezogen und stehst dann wenigstens in Deutschland irgendwie auf dem Gleis rum. Aber ja, das ist wahr.
Aber wir sehen davon, aber es ist doch recht convenient. So hier rein, da, hups, raus und so.
Genau, wenn diese Belüftungssituation besser wäre, ist das in der Tat etwas, was echt cool ist. Und ich meine, ich habe irgendwie 20 oder 30 Euro für diese Fahrt bezahlt, weil das irgendwie, ich weiß gar nicht, welchen Tag ich los bin. Ich glaube, Samstag.
Aber Just-in-Time kann man diese Fähre nicht nehmen, ne? Du musst immer anmelden und...
Als Fußgänger kannst du die Just-in-Time nehmen, glaube ich.
Du kannst auch kurzfristig buchen. Das Ding ist selten voll. Also jetzt zur Hochreisezeit, klar. Aber wenn du jetzt sonst einfach dahin fährst, kannst du auch vor Ort ein Ticket holen. Oder Klickset unterwegs.
Und Motorräder nehmen die auch?
Genau.
Motorräder sind sowieso kein Problem, weil die quetschen sich irgendwo in die Ecke. Ich verstehe.
Fahrräder halt auch. Du kannst auch beim Fahrrad auf die Fähre drauf.
Und werden Motorräder verspannt oder stabil genug?
Nee, die werden verspannt.
Und da haben die auch Zeug da.
Also die sind da komplett ausgestattet.
Du merkst, die sind auch Vollprofis. Das ist sowieso interessant, wenn das so richtig voll ist, wie die dieses Autodeck sortieren. Die sortieren dich ja vorher schon. Die erste ist ja die, die dein Ticket checkt. Die schickt dich schon mal grob in so eine Linie.
Schmale Autos und breite Autos.
Ja, und dann Campingdinger oder sonst sowas. Und da steht einer, bevor du jetzt wirklich auf das Ding drauffährst, der guckt dein Auto nochmal genau an und sortiert dich in die Spur. So kurz vor dem Schiff oben oder kurz vor dem Eingang. Und das ist irre, wie die da die Autos... Du fährst da einmal rein, hinten rum. Du fährst einmal rein, fährst hinten rum, und dann wieder vor, fast bis du wieder vorne rausfällst. Und innerhalb dieses Prozesses mischen die die Autos, entschieden die so hin und her, dass da wirklich gut gepackt und das Zeug da alles ist.
Muss ja auch, wenn es nicht ganz voll wird, gleichmäßig verteilt sein, damit es nicht Seitenlast kriegt und so.
Aber das machen die halt viermal am Tag. Deswegen, also jetzt nicht dieselbe Crew immer, aber deswegen...
Was noch ganz interessant ist, weil du auch Zug sagtest, das fand ich spannend. Man ist dann von Kullerberg irgendwie in Mölle gewesen. Da heißt dieses Dörfchen, was da oben ist. Und man läuft ein Stück auf einer alten Zugtrasse. Das haben sie halt als Fahrradweg ausgebaut. Und ein Stück muss man als Wanderer auf diesem Weg gehen, weil die Weiden ab und zu gesperrt sind. Und man steht da vor dem Schild und liest so, ja, ja, früher, bis Anfang des 19., 20. Jahrhunderts, 20. Jahrhunderts, sind da Züge von Berlin nach Mölle durchgefahren, also nach Schweden so an die Spitze. Und das fand ich irgendwie auch ganz spannend, weil ich glaube, das muss ja auch zu der Zeit gewesen sein, noch gewesen sein, wo Kurt Tucholsky Schloss Kripsholm geschrieben hat, weil da ist er ja auch auf der Fähre mit dem Zug unterwegs.
Diese ganze Geschichte mit Zug über Fähre über Ostsee hat echt Tradition. Wenn du auf dieser Fähre selber mal guckst, gibt es eine deutsche und eine schwedische Fähre. Jetzt fährt noch eine davon, weil die andere ist irgendwie kaputt oder in Reparatur oder so. Deswegen haben sie das auch ausgedönt, aber es gab mal zwei, die da gefahren sind. Die eine hieß Sassnitz, war das deutsche Schiff, die andere hieß Trelleboe, war das schwedische Schiff. Diese haben sich immer hin und gegenseitig abgewechselt und da haben die so Bildergalerien drin, über die Jahre hinweg, weil es sind ja Generation X von diesem Schiff auf dieser Strecke. Und selbst zu DDR-Zeiten, wo ja so mit Grenzen und hin und her und so, haben die aber Regenverkehr da gemacht. Eben auch mit Zügen und mit Tralala und so. Und das geht schon eine Weile. Und diese ganze Geschichte mit dem Zug nach Skandinavien über die Fähre rüber, hat echt, also von Berlin, hat echt Tradition.
Ist nicht der eine der Strecken jetzt mit so einer Elektro-Fähre irgendwie oder wollen sie die da machen?
Das ist aber zwischen Dänemark und Schweden. Ja, so auf dieser Höhe, da fährt es den Klo.
Jetzt muss ich ja direkt mal gucken, weil ich bin eben auf dem Rückweg, also ich bin angekommen dann halt auch in Helsingborg und von dort rüber nach Helsingor mit der Fähre. Weil warum nicht, geht ja immer alles da drüben. Und das ist halt echt spannend, weil wie du halt auf Höhengrad schon sagtest, die zwei Länder nehmen sich an der Stelle nichts. Du hast super häufig kommst du an Orten vorbei, die schwedische und dänische Flagge haben. Du merkst das in einem Stadtverkehr nicht, weil die Fähre alle 20 Minuten da rüber düst und...
Ja, auch die Bahnen, wenn du guckst, die Bahnen, da sind halt einfach so Haltestellen. Und zwar ganz gohne. Du kannst halt anfangen von Kopenhagen aus bis rüber nach Öland. Also nicht auf Öland drauf, sondern nach, wie heißt das jetzt, das Städtchen da direkt an der Brücke, nach Öland rüber, da kommen wir jetzt nicht drauf. Aber das ist alles da unten so ein Fahrplan. Du musst halt genau hingucken, da ist irgendwo eine kleine Linie auf dem Fahrplan drauf. Ach so, ja, das ist eine Ländergrenze. Deswegen musst du auch aufpassen. Wenn du in dem Zug sitzt und auf dänischer Seite rumfährst, gibt es irgendwann mal so eine Ansage, wenn du jetzt sitzen bleibst, bist du demnächst in Schweden. Das ist aber wie gesagt auch Fahrplan-mäßig und Ticket-mäßig ist das alles integriert, die machen sich da keinen Kopf.
Das ist wirklich angenehm zu reisen an der Stelle. Ich bin dann eben, weil ich einen Tag eher fertig war mit Wandern, bin ich halt dann auch einen Tag, habe ich mein Ticket umgebucht und bin von Kopenhagen zurückgefahren nach Berlin über Hamburg. Das war irgendwie sehr lustig, weil du hast irgendwie super, der Klassiker hast halt super Netz da drüben gehabt in Schweden und in Dänemark halt auch und dann irgendwann steigst du aus der Fähre aus, fährst ein Stück. Und es ist ja, wo ist es denn hin? Wir müssen in Deutschland sein. Das ist echt so deprimierend. Aber wer auf Küstenwanderung steht und so generell die ganzen Wanderwege da in Skone, das ist gut zu erreichen von Deutschland aus und echt sehenswert.
Wir sind für Leute, da wir uns auch gerne mal über Fernsehsendungen unterhalten. Es gibt, glaube ich, auf Netflix gibt es das auch. Es gibt eine dänisch-schwedische Fernsehserie. Die kann man auf Netflix auch im Original gucken. Finde ich nämlich sehr spannend. Die machen es wirklich dänisch und schwedisch gemischt auch. Total krass. Schwedisch komme ich ganz gut klar, aber dänisch muss ich mich echt dran gewöhnen. Ich habe mich erst mitten in der zweiten Season angefangen, die langsam zu verstehen. Weil es echt schon noch ein bisschen anders war. Das spielt aber eben genau da in diesem Umfeld.
Die gibt es ja im Englischen auch. Gespielt von Diana Krüger.
Ja, haben sie denn da noch mal gemacht, da zwischen Mexiko und einer Grenze zwischen Mexiko und USA, noch mal nachgespielt, aber mit demselben Plot und alles und hin und her.
Ja, aber die Diana Krüger ist das.
Das Original.
Links in den Chat.
Die Brücke kann ich wirklich auch empfehlen. Ist auch gut gemacht.
So, was ist zu Schweden?
Noch einen kurzen Einschub, weil ich ja so in diesem DIY-Dings schon ganz schön drin bin. Mir ist dann nämlich halt aufgefallen, weil hier auch jemand nochmal dieses Ein-Personen-Leicht-Zelt irgendwie einen Kilo, 1,2 Kilo reinpostet. Also dieses Hilleberg-Zelt ist halt echt super geil konstruiert und ich bereue nach wie vor nicht, diesen Kauf gewagt zu haben. Aber ich sträube mich davor, das Innenzelt gegen noch so ein Netz-Zelt auszutauschen, weil ich weiß gar nicht, was die dafür haben wollen.
Ist auch Schweden, Hilleberg.
Ich glaube genau, es ist eine schwedische Firma und produziert aber mittlerweile, ich glaube, in Island. Hast aber auch nach wie vor den Namen drinstehen von der Nähere.
Wie, jetzt hast du da so eine Stoffbahn, so ein Innenzelt, so komplett und das kann man gegen Netz tauschen, dann ist das noch leichter, oder was?
Genau, noch leichter und atmungsaktiver.
Ist aber auch kälter dann.
Genau, aber ich meine, wenn du jetzt so bei 30 Grad unterwegs bist, wo die Temperatur, naja, bei 15 Grad, finde ich, merkt man schon den Unterschied. Wenn man nur den Sommerschlafsack dabei hat, merkst du den Unterschied, ob du in einem zeltigeren Ding unterwegs bist oder in Schweden hast du ja die offenen Shelter. Ach, im Übrigen, ich habe eigentlich versprochen, auch so ein gemeines Bild reinzuposten in den Slack meiner Sicht in Schweden. Und ich hatte wirklich in der letzten Nacht auf den Öresund-Kanal von meinem Schlafsack aus einfach den geilsten Blick überhaupt. Gleich mal gucken, ob ich das hier reingebaut bekomme. Also wirklich, da kannst du kein Hotel für bezahlen, für diesen Blick. Aber ja, genau, der Silleberg-Zelt kann man halt das Innenzelt nochmal austauschen gegen...
Da steht der Preis.
Ja, es ist mir zu viel.
Da sagt jemand, das Mecht-Zelt kostet 210 Euro.
Vor allem gibt es hier gerade den Tipp, hast du das schon gesehen, Letty?
Natürlich kenne ich Extremtexte hier. Die sind großartig. Ich bestelle da immer meinen Merino-Stoff. Und genau, das ist mir halt dann in den Sinn gekommen. Diese Mecht-Zelte sind eine ganz coole Sache. Aber mir ist halt ein Nachteil an dem Silleberg-Zelt, in der Konstruktion der Reißverschlüsse aufgefallen, die mir immer wieder mal Probleme macht. Und das will ich jetzt einfach mal mit selber nähen ausprobieren, ob ich das anders, ich will jetzt nicht sagen besser, aber schon noch mal irgendwie anders gelöst bekomme. Genau, und da will ich jetzt mal gucken, weil ich da so ein bisschen Lust drauf habe, selber da mal rum zu engineern, ob ich dann da was Gutes auf die Reihe bekomme. Um dann eben vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen das Gewicht zu reduzieren, aber primär auch einfach, um nochmal eine bessere Belüftung zu haben. Und Entschuldigung, aber das war der Blick meines letzten Abends, wenn es dann extrem flexibel dauert.
Aber so ein Innenmesh-Zelt ist natürlich interessant, wenn ich dran denke, dass nächstes Jahr wieder Konk, äh, nicht Konk, als Camp ist.
Ja, vor allem...
Da ist ja auch eigentlich immer ziemlich warm meistens. Also gefroren habe ich da selten auf dem Camp, glaube ich. Ja, geht gar nicht, ne? Nee, hat man immer... Eigentlich war da immer zu heiß im Zelt, immer.
Ja, was halt noch ganz spannend ist für diese Hütten, wo man jetzt nur so den Ausblick auf das Wasser sieht, du hast halt manchmal das Problem, einige Kommunen kümmern sich da sehr darum, dass da keine Wespen und so Viecher ihre Nester einfach bauen.
Aber nicht alle.
Aber du kannst es auch manchmal ja nicht vermeiden, dass da irgendwo eine Wespe rumflattert. Und das ist halt nachts, wovor ich echt Angst habe. Weiß ja nicht, ob die nachts sind, die wahrscheinlich eh nicht aktiv, aber... Genau, aber so ein Mesh-Zelt zu haben, was du halt in dieser Hütte einfach auch rein machen kannst.
Einfach über das Nest legen kannst?
Nee, aber du hast halt meistens irgendwie... Kannst du da irgendwas anhängen? Also mit einem Nagel oder so?
Ja, aber wenn du kein Mesh-Zelt hast, sondern das normale Innenzelt, dann ist das doch genauso dicht. Also das ist doch beides dicht. Oder um was geht's?
Ja, einfach nur, dass du halt dann zusätzlich, wenn du so ein Mesh-Zelt hast, dann hast du vielleicht auch so was wie ein Moskitonetz, so als Alternative dann hast für in Hütten schlafen, wenn man es irgendwo dran aufhängen kann. Also dann hätte man zwei in eins mit so einem Mesh-Zelt, dass das atmungsaktiver im Zelt ist und leichter. Und dann zusätzlich halt auch dafür. Genau, Moskitonetz ist dann halt das, was man wählen würde um so ein Mesh-Zelt.
Wo ist denn dann das Mesh-Zelt?
Das kommt drauf an, in welcher Stärke du das kaufst. Bei Extrem-Textil gibt es, glaube ich, sogar wirklich für Moskitos geeignetes Mesh. Also was halt dichteres Mesh ist als...
Aber das normale Mesh ist gröber, oder wie? Dass da Viecher durchkommen könnten, oder was? Weil es so leicht sein soll. Dann kann man es ja auch gleich weglassen.
Das stimmt.
Na ja, ich meine, wenn du...
Die Elche passen dann auch.
Und Hasen spielen dir nicht ins Gesicht, aber das machen die eh nicht. Wegen Schlangen oder wie? Weil ich würde schon immer was holen, damit da keine Moskitos durchpassen.
Ja, aber du brauchst vielleicht Moskitos jetzt nicht unbedingt hier in Deutschland oder Schweden. Und warum du einen Innenzelt generell haben willst, ist, dass wenn du dein Außenzelt noch hast, hast du halt nur das Außenzelt, aber kein Zeltboden. Du hast dann zwar ein Footprint, wo du dein Zeltboden drauf machst, aber kein Zeltboden. Das heißt, wenn es regnet, würde es dir quasi unterm Arsch das Zelt bieten.
Also bei meinem VOD Mark 3 Long, wie auch immer, da ist das Innenzelt, der Boden mit dran. Aber der Boden ist so ein bisschen dicker, stabileres Zeug. Und das Außen ist so dünner, aber ist auch kein Netz. Aber so, ja. Aber stimmt schon. Für den Sommer könnte man da so moskito-mäßig haben. Aber gröberes Netz würde ich nicht haben wollen.
Also es ist jetzt nicht gröber im Sinne von, da hast du dann so ein Loch, also so ein großes Loch.
Ja, aber wenn da Moskitos durchpassen, wäre mir das zu grob, würde ich mal behaupten. Also Moskitonetz sollte schon sein.
Moskitos und Stechmöcke, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob die eine andere Größe haben. Weil ich weiß, dass es halt bei Extremtextil definitiv so eine unterschiedliche Stoffe dafür gibt, was so ein Netz angeht. Hier gibt es grobmaschiges und feinmaschiges Moskitonetz. Das gibt es bei Extremtextil. Und ich vermute mal, grobmaschiges hilft gegen Mücken und Fliegen und größere Insekten. Und das kleinere wirklich wahrscheinlich für alles. Hier steht, wenn es gegen kleine Insekten geht, die vor allem in kühleren Klimaten vorkommen, benötigen sie eher ein feinmaschiges Netz. Genau, da müsste man halt mal gucken, was man genau braucht.
Die Chap-Dame macht ja anscheinend selber, bestellt es einfach bei ihr, was sie braucht.
Also in Schottland sind die richtig fiesen Mücken richtig klein.
Genau, wie hießen die doch gleich? Sandflies.
Ja, die sind so wie ein Eintagsflieger.
Aber die kommen durch das feine auch schon nicht durch. Und durch das grobe wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Na ja, weiß ich nicht, wie grob das jetzt ist. Aber wenn du da so ein Tornetz aufspannst, dann hast du auf jeden Fall keine Ruhe. Alles klar.
So, abgeschlossen das Thema.
Ja, lass mal auf den nächsten Urlaubsbericht wechseln. Halbe Stunde haben wir durch jetzt in Schweden. Was hab ich vergessen?
Sie hat ja über die Oder auch berichtet. Da gibt es nämlich auch wirken.
Aber wenig dieses Jahr.
Dafür kommen jetzt die Wespen überall. Habt ihr den tollen Tipp gehört?
Ich war in Venedig.
In Venedig?
Ja, noch nicht abgesoffen. Die hatten ja sogar zu wenig Wasser. War das nicht so? Die konnten nicht mehr paddeln, weil kein Wasser mehr?
Keine Ahnung, aber die werden demnächst bestimmt genug Wasser haben. Also lange lebt das da nicht mehr. Gibt ihm noch 50 Jahre. Dann ist Klimawandel. Wenn das Wasser um einen Meter ansteigt, dann bleibt da nicht viel übrig.
Da ist ja Taucherparadies.
Ja, dann kannst du in Ruinen tauchen.
In der Suppe dann?
Aber du gehst, also ich war ja noch nie da. Ehrlich gesagt, es hat mich jetzt auch nicht besonders gereizt da hinzugehen. Hat sich so ergeben. Und dann verbringt man ja auch, also ich war so in der Gegend, und dann verbringt man natürlich auch mal einen Tag in der Stadt, um das so abzuhaken. Ja, check, weil ja, okay, es ist irgendwie ganz lustig. Man hat das Gefühl, wenn man alle Touristen wegbeamen würde, dann wäre da nur noch irgendwie Crickets und Tumbleweed.
Ja, außerhalb der Saison dahin ist eigentlich interessanter. Für weite Teile des Festland-Italiens würde ich wahrscheinlich sagen, dass das du trifft, aber...
Die ganze Erde vielleicht eigentlich?
Bestimmt noch mal extra, ja. Das kann ich mir auch vorstellen, wenn man da vielleicht im November oder so hingeht.
Witzig soll es da auch sein, wenn es da Hochwasser ist.
Aquareiter.
Und die dann alle, als wäre überhaupt nichts, bis hier einfach durch das Wasser warten und einkaufen gehen und als ob das das Normalste von der Welt wäre. Also ich habe bisher nur Fotos gesehen, auch von Leuten, die da waren zu der Zeit. Und ich dachte, hä? Überall sonst würden sie jetzt Sand-Säcke und sonst was aufbauen und ausflippen. Also wirklich Fotos von genau diesem Phänomen ganz großartig. Aber ja.
Auch wenn der Reinhard vom methodisch inkorrekt mir mit dieser Beobachtung zuvor gekommen ist in seinem Podcast, weil er auch in Venedig war, wollte ich das an dieser Stelle auch nochmal wiedergeben. Du ziehst dann durch diese Stadt im Wasser auf einer Insel. Haus zu Haus, überall Glasfaser boxen. In jedem scheiß Haus.
Das ist aber nicht nur in Venedig.
Aber ist doch klar, Kupfer würde wegrosten, Glas nicht.
Du drängelst dich dadurch die Touristen und da steht da mittendrin einer irgendwie auf der Straße und schleißt einfach eine Glasfaser vor deiner Nase. Und es ist so frustrierend wieder gewesen.
Nee, ich sag dir jetzt mal genau, das hab ich schon ein paar Mal vorher gebracht und dann kommen die Deutschen wieder und sagen, ja, aber willst du, dass es auch hier so aussieht wie da? Dass die Glasfaser hier alle an der Hauswand hängen draußen?
Das kam sofort auf Twitter, natürlich kam das sofort. Ja, Denkmalschutz.
Ach, Denkmalschutz, Denkmalschutz, der nur das dämlichste, was du hast. Wir haben schon x-mal darüber gesprochen, dass wenn jetzt du gerade hier in pregnancy mountain, wenn jetzt mal auf die Idee kommt, die Telekom jetzt auf die Idee kommt zu sagen, hier würden wir mal Glasfaser hinmachen. Glaubst du, wie viele Hauswirte oder Hausbesitzer erstmal sagen, ne, ich hab grad das Treppenhaus renoviert. Hier kommt mir jetzt kein Glas rein. Aus genau dem selben Grund, die tackern jetzt einfach draußen an die Wand und fertig. Und zwar jeder, wie er Lust hat. Da wird nicht der Hausbesitzer gefragt, ob ich den Kabel dazu tackern kann oder nicht. Zumindest auch meine Urlaubsbeobachtung in Kroatien ist ja da auch der große Telekom Provider, wer? Die Deutsche Telekom. Die haben sich da nämlich mal den Encomment gekauft und sind jetzt sozusagen der Staatsbetrieb in Kroatien. Das ist die Deutsche Telekom. Die Deutsche Telekom macht da jede Menge Sachen, die sie jetzt zu Hause nicht spielt oder nicht spielen kann oder nicht spielen will. Da gibt es auch Glasfaser, aber wird halt nicht gezuckt. Wie habe ich meine Erlaubnis, das mal hinzulegen. Das wird halt einfach an die Wand getackert und fertig und dann hast du das. Deswegen spielen die das da. Hier musst du halt dröffig Erlaubnisse haben und vom Tiefbauamt und Absperren und bla bla bla. Das muss ja unbedingt alles eingebuddelt werden, frostsicher, damit so ein Kabel nicht erfriert. So ein Glasfaserkabel, da musst du noch eine gewisse Tiefe haben. Da gibt es super 1.003 Baubestimmungen. Das hast du da in den Ländern nicht. Da gibt es halt so einen, wir machen das so, dass wir dein Haus nicht kaputt machen und ansonsten erst don't tell, ran mit dem Ding an die Wand und fertig. Und das wird halt hier in Deutschland, das Land der Häuslebau, so strikt abgelehnt, dass du dich da jetzt gar nicht aufregen musst, dass es da Glasfaser gibt, die es hier nicht gibt. Das liegt nicht daran, dass die Glasfaserbuden das nicht wollen würden, aber das ist halt so.
Ich hab nur gesagt, da ist das so. Natürlich ist das Problem mit Fiber-Tüten-Home.
Das sieht immer so scheiße aus.
Das ist das Home. Naja, aber ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass man das halt nicht irgendwie auch ohne weiteres nach innen verlegen könnte.
Nee, die tackern ja gleich ein Haus zum nächsten Haus, zum nächsten Haus, zum nächsten Haus und so weiter.
Aber dafür haben die ja alle Netz.
Ja, wenn sie das in Deutschland machen, dann würden sie sich anbeschweren, weil da irgendjemand kommt und das durchknipst.
Hausfassade. Da gibt es bestimmt 1003 Dinge dazu. Das wird nur noch übertroffen von den Regulierungen in der Schweiz. Aber ansonsten kannst du nicht einfach über deine Hausfassade tackern, hallo. Wer haftet denn da außer dem Kabel? So, so viel dazu. Sorry, weil das habe ich schon x-mal gehört, das Argument. Kannst du in Spanien gucken, kannst du in Frankreich gucken, da wird überall diese Taggarnett an die Wand und fertig.
Ich habe nur erzählt, was ich gesehen habe. Dann habe ich mir einen Mietwagen genommen und der hatte CarPlay. Genau.
Besser als eingebaute Navigation in 99% der Fälle.
Ja, aber bist ja immer davon abgesehen, mein Telefon mit irgendwas in einem Mietwagen zu verbinden. Ja, aber wenn du... Aus Datenhygienegründen, in beiderlei Hinsicht.
Durchaus, aber der Unterschied so zwischen Tag und Nacht.
Aber ich habe eine populäre Behaltung für meinen Telefon, die klemme ich mir einfach in die Lüftung von dem Kreis Mietwagen, klemme mein Telefon rein, dann habe ich mein Navi.
Ist aber nicht dasselbe, also das CarPlay ist schon ganz pfiffig, das muss ich auch feststellen. Ich hätte das wirklich zu dem Zeitpunkt noch, zu keinem Zeitpunkt irgendwo testen können, mangels Car mit CarPlay.
Hast du denn bei Rückgabe das wieder ausgebucht und gelöscht?
Da musst du gar nichts buchen, du steckst das einfach ran und dann hast du da CarPlay.
So mit USB-Kabel, Lightning-Kabel oder was? Und wenn du das absteckst, sind deine ganzen Kontaktlisten aus dem Autoradio wieder ausgelöscht?
Nein, da wird überhaupt nichts gesynkt. Natürlich probieren sie dir Fort-Apps und so weiter noch zu installieren, da sagst du halt brav nein und dann war's das. Aber du hast dann halt CarPlay. Und ehrlich gesagt, mir war bisher überhaupt nicht klar, wie CarPlay eigentlich funktioniert.
Ja auch nicht, wie du siehst.
Also ich hab immer nur so Screenshots gesehen, aber mich ehrlich gesagt da noch nicht groß mit irgendwelchen Videos beschäftigt, die das sicherlich am Internet lang und breit ausführlich erläutern. Prinzip ist ganz einfach. Der merkt einfach, dass da ein zweiter Bildschirm ist, geht in diesen CarPlay-Modus. Und dann hast du halt von allen Apps, die CarPlay unterstützen. Das ist die Lord Vader. Wenn du dein Mikrofon auch genau so einrichtest, dass es dir auf die Nase zeigt.
Moment, es ist ein zweiter Bildschirm. Das heißt, es ist nicht so wie in den ersten Generationen von diesen ganzen Autokopplungen, dass er dein Telefon oder dein iPod-Display komplett blockiert und sagt, ich bin jetzt ferngesteuert.
Nein, dein iPhone funktioniert genauso wie vorher. Und immer deine Frontmost-App ist auch automatisch auf CarPlay die Frontmost-App. Das heißt, ich habe jetzt nicht so viel rumgetestet mit Apps, die das nicht unterstützen. Wie es dann ist, dann ändert sich glaube ich nichts.
Ich habe eigentlich immer nur Maps und iTunes benutzt. Das verhält sich in jedem.
Apple Maps oder Google Maps?
Apple Maps. Und beides verhält sich auf jeden Fall deutlich besser.
Google Maps gibt es noch nicht. Das kommt jetzt erst. Mit iOS 12.
Weil da erst CarPlay freigegeben wird? Oder was für Third-Party-Apps?
Nicht für Third-Party-Apps, sondern für Third-Party-Navigation-Apps. Also es gibt ja jetzt schon Podcast-Apps, Audio-Apps, die können schon. Und für Navi-Apps wird das jetzt auch eröffnet. Ja, und das ist einfach schön gelöst, weil du hast quasi 90% des Screens ist extra Display Space, der alles das begleitet, was du eben auch auf dem Telefon gerade machst. Das heißt, es ist sozusagen einfach nur ein erweiterter Screen Space, aber du kannst natürlich auch auf dem CarPlay-Display interagieren.
Wäre schön, wenn man jetzt wirklich als zwei Displays nutzen könnte, wenn man sagen könnte, auf dem Car Display bleibt mein Maps, und auf dem Telefon benutze ich jetzt mal die Telefon-App.
Ja, so dachte ich halt auch irgendwie zuerst darüber nach, aber es hat sich dann einfach beim Benutzen als eine extrem sinnvolle Verhaltensweise ergeben. Weil, also erstmal bildet es ja das nach, was auch auf dem Telefon passiert, weil im Hintergrund müsste die App ja dann auch immer weiterlaufen und im Speicher gehalten werden etc.
Machen ja die Navi-Apps, wenn ich telefoniere.
Die Navi-Apps, ja, aber andere Apps, also egal, du hast auf jeden Fall dieselbe Logik. Das, was du benutzt, ist auch da vorne. Es gibt da keine Konfusion.
Und sie gehen eh davon aus, dass der Telefon irgendwo versteckt ist, dass es nicht in deinem Sichtfeld ist, sondern dass man jetzt so unten reinsteckt, wo so ein Lightning-Anschluss ist und so eine Mittelkontrolle oder sonst was.
Du kannst es halt, du kannst an deinem Telefon weiterarbeiten, wenn du das möchtest, aber du kannst eben auch einfach auf CarPlay alle Apps bedienen, die CarPlay unterstützen. Und du hast halt die most recent Apps, die da eben was zu sagen haben. Hast du so einen kleinen Sidebar links und noch so einen Home-Button und das war's. Sehr einfach, aber extrem praktisch will man irgendwie sofort haben. Ich hab mir überlegt, ob es eigentlich irgendwelche valide Nachrüst-Kits gibt für ältere Autos, um irgendwie so CarPlay-Funktionalität auf den eigenen Bildschirm zu kriegen.
Jetzt dieser Tage lesen, es gibt einen Anbieter, der bietet sozusagen Aftermarket, wie das so schön heißt, Aftermarket CarPlay an.
Für?
Aftermarket, für doller Auto. Nicht speziell das Automodell, sondern irgendwie so als separaten Bildschirm oder sowas. Warte mal, war gerade dieser Tage.
Ja, aber nicht mit dem Bildschirm, der schon im Auto ist?
Nee.
Aber dein Fahrzeug, obwohl es jetzt gar nicht mehr so alt ist, kann das nicht?
2013, VW? Wolltest du noch mehr sagen? Ich weiß nicht, ob die das heute schon können, die neuen, also keine Ahnung.
Aber hier sagt ja auch einer im Chat, dass das höherwertige Navi im VW...
Sony.
Besser ist.
Sony anwies new version of its top rated aftermarket CarPlay system.
Ah, hast du da link...
Das ist halt so, hier guckst du erst mal, da ist so ein Kästchen da und mit Bildschirm und das klebst du dir halt irgendwo hin, klebst du dir auf deinen Bildschirm von deinem Auto oder wie auch immer.
Naja, das ist ja nicht zum draufkleben gedacht, sondern eher tatsächlich zum einbauen und das könnte durchaus ein... in den Rahmen reinpassen. Das Problem ist natürlich, dass du dann in diesem eingebauten System auch nennenswerte Funktionen hast. Da muss ich überhaupt noch mal gucken, ob da überhaupt irgendwas abgebildet ist, was man unbedingt braucht. Ich hätte kein Problem, damit das einfach zu ersetzen. Hast du den Link gedruckt?
Schicke ich dir, ich bin auf diesem Rechner, den ich hier mit habe, habe ich jetzt keine, die Slack-Gruppe nicht.
Dann machst du Webseite auf.
Schicke ich dir so. Paff. Ja, nun kannst du dich ja den Kost posten.
Extra Arbeit machen, das mag ich.
Ja, inzwischen richtig, und du weiter redest richtig jetzt hier auf dem Slack hier, richtig jetzt hier dein Chat ein. Ich habe ein anderer Rechner hier.
Ja, ist ja in Ordnung. Ich mache das schon für dich, kein Problem. Die Hörer mögen das auch, wenn diese Pausen entstehen.
Ja, dann kehrt man ein bisschen Ruhe ein.
So. Der Chat moniert. Tim Pritlove ist ja in letzter Zeit sehr seltsam. Er ist mit Neuerungen sehr kritisch. Nach Monaten bis Jahren nutzt er es und dann ist es ganz toll. Douglas Adams, Fragezeichen. Airpods, CarPlay. Also Airpods habe ich doch... Natürlich habe ich dich ausgemacht.
Und das iPhone X natürlich, ne?
Was damit?
Hat ja auch ewig gedauert. Du wolltest ja von deinem iPhone 5 SE nicht runter. Bei iOS 7 hast du da auch ein paar Jahre.
Das war ja auch scheiße, das habe ich auch komplett ausgesessen. iOS 7 habe ich nicht benutzt.
Ja, das sage ich ja.
Ja, das war ja auch scheiße. Das ist ja auch daran, dass alles, was iOS 7 gebracht hat, komplett überarbeitet wurde. Na ja, ist halt nicht immer alles toll, was neu ist.
Nee, haben sie ja alles wieder rausgemacht.
Das sage ich ja schon die ganze Sendung. Es wird alles schlechter eigentlich.
So weit würde ich jetzt nicht gehen. Wie ist dieser Typ, den sie gekillt haben?
Aber um noch mal kurz auf diese Kritik einzugehen, also AirPods habe ich relativ früh adoptiert. Und CarPlay, na ja Gott, ich meine, CarPlay ist halt nirgendswo. Wie soll man denn das benutzen?
Aus seinem Mietwagen.
Ich habe mich da auch ehrlich gesagt noch nie zu geäußert, weil ich da einfach schlicht keine Erfahrung mit hatte.
Aber jetzt ist schick.
Und das iPhone X, ich weiß nicht, man kann ja skeptisch sein, oder? Ist das ein Fehler?
Ist es skeptisch zu sein?
Alles Zweifelhafte muss angezweifelt werden.
Man kann ja skeptisch sein. Sollte ich danach behaupten, es wäre immer noch scheiße, obwohl ich es toll finde, das macht doch auch keinen Sinn. Also ich sehe da jetzt kein aktives Fehlverhalten. Ansonsten hat Douglas Ennis natürlich Recht. Und das ist ja auch nicht einfach. Oder? Ich meine, ich bin Laptopscomputer gewohnt extrem. Und der Gedanke, jetzt irgendwie iPad-only zu gehen, der kommt mir nicht in den Sinn.
Nee, auf gar keinen Fall.
Aber ich kenne so Leute, die mit so was liebäugeln. Aber ich denke, das ist gegen die Natur.
Das ist vollkommen korrekt. Ich nehme jetzt inzwischen so auf meine Urlaubsurlaube, die nicht nerdigen, nämlich auch nur noch ein iPad mit. Aber auch nur deswegen, um Murphy zu bestechen. Weil ich ganz genau weiß, ich sitze im Flieger und komme an in Lyon oder so was, steige aus dem Flugzeug und habe das Telefon voll mit Alarmmeldungen. Das ist mein Mail-Server oder mein Domainserver oder sonst was gerade schwieriges Problem hat. Und um das zu verhindern, nehme ich das iPad mit. Wenn ich es nicht dabei hätte, dann würde es natürlich passieren. Und wenn ich es dabei habe, weiß aber Murphy, dass es so keinen Spaß macht. Weil dann stehe ich einfach locker aus, klappe das iPad auf, bootet den Server oder was auch immer und dann ist es gut. Und da hat er keinen Bock drauf. Also iPad dabei haben hilft dagegen. Ist so wie Ring-Shoes mitnehmen. Nur mitnehmen. Nicht benutzen.
Wow, hier ist gerade ein schöner Link im Chat gelandet. Das VW sehr wohl CarPlay hat, aber in China. Und man kann sich irgendwie die Sachen nachträglich einbauen.
What could possibly go wrong, so eine Firmware aus China in den VW einspielen?
Schön, schön.
Das sieht gut aus.
Cool.
Wow.
Jetzt fährst du mit deinem Touran mal nach China und lässt dir das da einbauen.
RCD 330. Das muss einfach nur mit dem Quad-Log-Stecker des vorhandenen Radios verbunden werden. Altes Radio raus, neues Radio rein. Der Clou des Teils auf den üblichen Plattformen wie Amazon und Ebay, da kann man meistens deutlich unter 200 Euro haben.
Juhu!
Das ist ein Replacement-Radio aus China oder für den Touran-Radio oder wie?
Das ist einfach das Modell, was in China verkauft wird und was CarPlay hat. Was ihr beachten müsst.
Jemand zwischendurch mal ein bisschen an der Firmware.
Hat kein RDS. Ok, scheiß rauf. Als Menüsprache können nur Englisch und Chinesisch gewählt werden. Dann ich halt Chinesisch. Aha, Anzeigesteuerung per Multifunktionsanzeige im Tacho geht nicht.
Google und andere soziale Dienste sind nur eingeschränkt benutzbar.
Ach, an dein GPS machen sie dir aus, weil in China ja auch verboten ist. Ich weiß nicht, es waren anfangs die ersten iPhone-Generationen, die dort gab. Apple hat ja relativ früh angefangen, bloß ein iPhone-Mittel rauszubringen. Aber dann haben sie mit den Radios noch Unterschiede gehabt und so. Aber dann gab es eine Variante, die sie in China rausgebracht haben, und dann GPS disabled.
Augen auf beim Kauf! Es sind auch geflashte Geräte und solche mit Jailbreak im Netz unterwegs. Aber es gibt hier einen Amazon-Link.
Den haben die VW Lawyer noch nicht getötet. Ich prangere das an.
Und ist das auch Amazon oder ist das ein Ho-Chiming-Flower-Power-Enterprises-Marketplace-Shop?
amazon.de, 6,5 cm Auto-Stereo-Radio CarPlay, verkauft von Bluetooth für VW Golf, CarPlay, Touran, CC.
Erhält dich bei diesen Anbietern.
So, jetzt sag noch, dass es...
All Seeing International. Klingt schon mal gut, aber Vereinigtes Königreich.
Sag noch, dass es für mein Baujahr passt und ich klick gleich mal hier, glaube ich.
Und schon sind wir wieder in der Amazon-Diskussion. So, in Schweden waren wir ja. In Venedig waren wir ja.
In Kroatien waren wir auch.
Der ist schön da übrigens, kann ich nur empfehlen. Mir hat es gut gefallen.
Ich hörte, man kann da so gut schnorcheln.
Das ist sehr... Also gerade so Wassersport, bin da ein bisschen rumgepaddelt, auch mit Bötchen gefahren.
Was, seid ihr jetzt schon wieder in Schweden?
Nein, in Kroatien. Und es macht wirklich Spaß. Ich fühlte mich da auch gut aufgehoben. Es gibt ja so Gegenden, wo du gleich, oh, Tourist...
Was sind die gewohnt?
Erst mal so richtig auf den Nerv gehen und so. Die haben auch so die Normalen. Du kommst da an, ein Split am Flughafen, kommt auch so ein Typ, willst du ein Taxi? Dann sagst du nö, dann wünsch dir einen guten Tag und lässt dich aber gehen. In anderen Ländern hast du die halt noch wie Kletten am Arsch. Das nervt halt so ein bisschen. Dieses Tourist hier kannst du ausgenommen werden. Aber das funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut. Kannst überall mit Karte zahlen, mit Apple Pay bezahlen.
Und ich hab Deutsch unterhalten.
Du wirst lachen, es gibt da etliche.
Ich war oft genug in Kroatien, um das zu wissen.
Ich war auch in einem Hotel, wo da eine Knabe, der war halt irgendwo in Hessen geboren. So ein kroatischer Auswanderer, der dann wieder nach Hause gegangen ist, der sprach fließend akzentfrei Deutsch. Das geht in der Tat. Da gibt es eine Menge Leute, die da rumfahren. Was ich auch sehr interessant fand, wenn man durch die Stadt guckt, wenn da Autos rumstehen, was die für Kennzeichen dran haben, würde man ja nur meinen, dass da vielleicht auch viele, was ist ich, Serbische oder zumindest Slowenische Kennzeichen oder so etwas gibt. Aber da gibt es halt kroatische und deutsche Kennzeichen. Das war eine nette Experience. Und würde ich jetzt auch mal wieder empfehlen, ist vor allen Dingen so, wie man ja früher so manchmal so sagte, Mallorca ist ein zusätzliches Bundesland, halt so einfach von der Erreichbarkeit her, als es noch eher Berlin gab, so acht, zehn oder zwölf Flüge am Tag oder so weit hin und zurück. Dann gibt es natürlich jetzt immer noch so mit 350 Airlines, billig Airlines, Berlin Split für 30 Euro oder sonst irgendwas. Da ist übrigens Season bei denen, wenn die Flieger jetzt im Oktober einfach aufhören, dann hören auch die da auf. Die basieren also sozusagen ihr Sommerbusiness gerade in dieser Gegend um Splitter auf den Flügen, die da aus ganz Europa einschlagen. Du kommst halt für billig Geld dahin. Das ist ein EU-Land, das ist kein Euro-Land, aber ist auch kein Schengen-Land, witzigerweise. Das heißt, du musst noch durch eine Passkontrolle, aber es ist halt ein EU-Land. Das heißt, du kannst auch mit deinem Ausweis einfach reisen und es ist easy peasy. Wie gesagt, sehr angenehm, günstig und noch nicht so touristisch verkommen, sagen wir mal.
Ja, es gibt so Ecken, da ist es schon ein bisschen extrem, aber es gibt auch genug Ecken, wo man noch so ein bisschen chillen kann.
Also du warst nicht zum Beispiel da, weil sie ja auch die ganzen Game of Thrones-Fans da auch alle dahin düsen oder so. Das ist halt schon noch so ein bisschen Touri-Zentrum. Aber ich war halt jetzt in Trogir, kann man ja sagen, der ist so vom Flughafen Splitz nochmal so in Laufweite entfernt, nach Norden wieder ein Stückchen. Und mit schönen Altstadt und so. Und wie gesagt, viel Wasser und die ganzen kleinen Inselchen. Da kannst du also auch sagen, ich will jetzt hier weg vom Festland auf so ein Boot mit so einem Wassertaxi, auf so eine Insel. Gibt da ordentlich Bits, ist wie gesagt EU-Land, das heißt EU-Roaming hast du auch und alles. Also hast den ganzen EU-Vorteil eigentlich dort.
Da segel ich vielleicht auch mal hin.
Da war viel. Da war viel, viel Privatsegelei und so, was man da gesehen hat.
Das ist auch ein beliebtes Revier allerdings, ist das so für die Segelleute wohl schon sehr teuer geworden da. Also aufgrund des hohen Betriebs. Also das hat so den Ruf, dass das jetzt schon mittlerweile eher unerschwinglich ist. Und wenn man so Segeln und kleine Inseln und Schönen und so haben will, dann ist Griechenland wohl gerade die deutlich bessere Option. Aber zukünftige Urlauber so ab Wochenende.
Genau, genau.
Was aufgefallen ist, was echt komisch ist, weil die ja wie gesagt kein Euroland sind, es gibt dort Geldautomaten, bis der Arzt kommt. Du hast immer zwei Läden, Geldautomaten, zwei Läden, Geldautomaten, zwei Läden, Geldautomaten. Das ist irgendwie keine Ahnung. Es ist mir vollkommen unklar, wer diese ganzen Dinge alle benutzen soll. Aber es ist mir noch nicht ganz klar, wie das System funktionieren soll. Wahrscheinlich sind diese Geräte zwischen so billig, um die zu befüllen oder sonst was zu machen. Dann stellt sich jeder Eisladen so ein Ding rein. Ich weiß es nicht, aber das muss mir vielleicht jemand erklären, wie das kommt.
Geile Amazon-Einträge für diese CarPlay-Teile hier.
Ach ja, stimmt. Hier gibt es einen Chat-Eintrag nach kroatischer Verwaltung. Achtet auf jeden Fall besser auf die Adria. Die geben sich ernsthaft Mühe dort, Umweltschutz zu betreiben, gerade auch in dem Wasser dort und in den Küstenflächen und so. Das merkt man auch. Und klar, wie er sagt, jemand klar tauchen und so, geht. Gibt aber auch Seeigel. Wir waren in so einer Gruppe da, und die hat sich glatt eingetreten, wie das so sein muss.
Das war eigentlich immer das Erste, wenn es nach Kroatien geht. Die haben ja auch hauptsächlich steinige Küsten. Da gibt es ja überall diese Gummilatschen, die jetzt so ein bisschen unattraktiv aussehen. Aber das wäre wieder der Vorteil, mit dem Boot unterwegs zu sein. Weil da hast du diese Einstiegshürde im Basen, das Wort ist es nicht.
Wir waren auch dann da baden, vom Boot aus. Das macht auch mehr Spaß, als die Steinchen da hoch krabbeln. Yay, Kroatien, finish.
Wenn ich jetzt anfange zu reden, fängst du nicht gleich wieder mit irgendwas an?
Probier mal aus, only one way to find out. Ich hab schon zweimal ausprobiert.
Ich wollte nur kurz diese CarPlay-Announcen hier nochmal vorlesen. Sehr schön, aus China. Das Radio No Scratch wie neu entfernt die neue Auto unbenutzt. Es gibt einige unvermeidbare Demolition-Spuren auf der Befestigungsstelle. Originalproduktion, keine Kopie. Der Vertrauen ist erweckend.
I see all heißt doch der Shop, oder? Erhält dich bei diesen Anbietern, klickst oben. Da war nur ein Anbieter und der hieß irgendwie all see.
All seeing international.
Ja, das ist natürlich mega fishy. Ich muss das alles nochmal ein bisschen hinterherrecherchieren. Aber sieht auf jeden Fall durchaus so aus, als ob es da Optionen gibt. Und mal schauen, ich meine, kann man auf sowas wie RDS verzichten, wahrscheinlich. Ja, kann man, wenn man dafür CarPlay hat. Was guckst du mich so an, Clemens?
Ich gucke nur, ich überlege, ob ich das selber benutze.
Ob du das selber benutzt, ob du was selber benutzt?
Also jetzt aktiv.
Na, die Frage ist, hörst du Radio?
Ja, gelegentlich.
Dann benutze du auch RDS. Was sagt dir denn, welcher Sender das ist?
Das ist schon nicht ganz falsch. Dapp Plus.
Ernsthaft?
Das ist eingebaut im Tesla, nehme ich.
Ah, verstehe.
Kann auch UKW, aber kann auch Dapp Plus. Das ist ja sowieso alles digital.
Hiermit auch nicht. Na mal gucken, vielleicht mache ich es auch nicht und habe Angst. So, was haben wir denn noch Schönes? Spätestens. Ah, Endspot. Ich wollte mal kurz einen Tipp geben. Und zwar zum Thema Podcasting-Apps. Ich hatte ja neulich schon mal Castro vorgestellt. Und du sagst, dass das toll ist.
Ich denke, die sind jetzt auf Rente.
Castro, oder?
Auf jeden Fall ist es immer noch toll. Und es gibt jetzt ein Update 3.1. Oder gab es vor zwei Wochen oder so. Und jetzt wird es langsam interessant. Es ist zwar noch nicht so hundertprozentig Pritlove-compliant, aber they are getting there. Erst mal eine sehr schöne Sache. Sie haben ja letztes Mal mit der 3.0 Kapitelmarken eingeführt. Das ist schon mal geil. Jetzt haben sie wirklich ein ganz einfaches Feature eingebaut. Das ist eine Idee, auf die ich noch nicht gekommen bin. Und zwar kann man, wenn man jetzt einen Podcast lädt, der Kapitelmarken hat und man weiß vorher schon, dass man bestimmte Sachen nicht hören will, also Freak Show zum Beispiel, Urlaubsberichte.
Aber man kann sie abselektieren.
Genau, dann kannst du vorher sagen, will ich nicht hören.
Dann sprengt er gleich dran vorbei. Dann muss er aber sehr sauber gesetzt sein, ne?
Na ja, auch wenn sie nicht sehr sauber gesetzt sind, ist es vielleicht besser. Das ist ja dann deine Entscheidung, ob du dem dann folgst oder nicht.
Aber ich kenne einige Podcasts, die damit deutlich Erträglicher werden und vor allem, wenn man halt mal ein, zwei Sachen hören will, vorher schon weiß, was oder auch nachhören und dann in so einer Situation ist, wo man ungern mit seinem Telefon interagiert, also Auto fahren, laufen, etc. Dann ist das wirklich cool und praktisch. Und zweite Sache, die auch noch sehr nett ist, das ist Side-Loading über iCloud Drive, d.h. man kann, wenn man jetzt einen Podcast manuell runtergeladen hat oder irgendwas anderes, was man dann hören will, sich das einfach in iCloud Drive in den Castro-Ordner reinwerfen und dann synkt das quasi über iCloud und wenn du dann deine Castro-App aufmachst, dann taucht der eben auf als ungehörter Podcast. Sehr praktisch, auch wenn ich so eigene Sachen mal vorhören will, Testversionen oder so, die nicht im Feed sind, wie kriegst du die da rein? Und jetzt kann ich die einfach auf meinem Mac, kann ich die irgendwie einfach zack in die iCloud Drive reinschieben, start die App und schon hab ich die in meinem normalen Player, kann Kapitelmarken testen und alles. Also wer noch nicht überzeugt war, Castro ist wirklich, wirklich toll. Also ich bin großer Fan von dem Handling. Es gibt jetzt noch eine Sache, die mich wirklich, zwei Sachen, die mich wirklich nerven. Das eine ist, dass man in diesem Archiv, wo man dann doch einiges reinfallen lässt, nicht suchen kann oder überhaupt eine ganze Historie nicht suchen kann. Und dass die Historie noch nicht in die normale Queue eingebaut ist. Also das ist so ein generelles Ding, was irgendwie die Client-Developer noch nicht so ganz verstanden haben. But maybe it's just me. Bei mir ist aber so, ich höre halt sehr oft Podcasts und die, nachdem sie gehört sind, sind die für mich noch nicht vorbei.
Noch nicht verarbeitet.
Aus zwei Gründen. Erstens möchte ich unter Umständen schnell nochmal was nachhören danach. Und zweitens habe ich auch oft das Problem, dass ich einfach dabei einschlafe und keinen Sleep-Timer gesetzt habe. Und dann sind sie irgendwie weg. Und meine Erwartungshaltung wäre halt, dass ein Podcast, den ich gerade eben gehört habe, eigentlich in derselben Liste, in derselben Zeitleiste ist, wie die Nächsten, die ich hören will. Und da ich nun eine Q habe, in Castro stellt man die Q ein. Das ist so quasi die Liste der nächsten Sachen, die sich automatisch zusammensetzt, aber die man auch manuell pflegen kann. Und ich würde halt erwarten, dass ein Podcast, den ich gerade gehört habe, entsprechend in die andere Richtung scrolle, einfach noch da steht. Erstens, dass ich sehen kann, was waren die letzten Podcasts, die ich gehört habe, weil man da nochmal was nachschlagen wollte, weil man da nochmal in die Show-Notes gehen wollte, warum auch immer. Und dass das nicht dann in einem komplett anderen Menü, irgendwo anders, wo du mit ganz anderen Wortmitteln recherchieren musst, verschwindet. Das finde ich blöd. Und dann unsitte auch noch die Medien-Datei gelöscht wurde, weil du es ja schon gehört hast. Und wenn du kurz danach nochmal hören willst, musst du es wieder runterladen, was unter Umständen nicht geht in der Situation.
Mal zwei Fragen dazu. Reine Interessen ist die Frage, wo kommt denn das her? Ist das jemand aus der deutschen Podcast-Szene? Oder der zumindest mal?
Nee, das ist so, die sind so zwei Iren.
Okay.
Der eine ist auch in Irland und der andere ist, glaube ich, in den USA.
Okay, aber die können trotzdem Trust the Germans oder wie sagtest du Don't Doubt the Germans, die können diese Kapitelmarkennummern, sowas alles schön. Können die denn jetzt auch, das ist jetzt die zweite Frage, du machst jetzt bei manchen Podcasts schon diesen, wie sagst du, also den Text mitnehmen, sozusagen die Transkription. Natürlich willst du jetzt nicht auf dem Handy oder sowas mitlesen, aber ein Feature von dieser Transkription ist ja, dass man suchen kann. Und das heißt, jetzt gibt es da schon irgendwelche Ansätze, dass man jemanden eine Podcast abschreibt, die das benutzt. Gibt es erstmal ein File-Format, ein standardisiertes, und dann gibt es dazu irgendwie einen Podcast ab, die das kann, wo ich dann sagen kann, da war doch der Freak Show, da hat auch Tim was gesagt.
Nein, weil der einzige Podcast, den ich kenne, der so richtig so ein Podcast ist und der konsequent Transkripte hat, ist meiner, Forschergeist. Wir entwickeln das gerade. Das ist ja auch noch ein Beta-Feature vom Podcast.
Wie weit sind die Erfahrungen bezüglich Files-Standardisierung?
Naja, Standardisierung ist ein großes Wort. Das Problem ist, dass wir uns selbst noch nicht so richtig einig sind, in welchem Format man das eigentlich darstellen will.
Also mit Reinen ins File oder mit Metafile daneben?
Ja, nicht nur das, wie das File aussieht. Wie bildest du eigentlich einen Transkript korrekt ab? Das befindet sich gerade noch ein bisschen in der Werbung. Das Problem ist, oder was heißt Problem? Die Ist-Situation ist, derzeit werden Transkripte in diesem doch recht lausigen WebVTT-Format weitergereicht. WebVTT ist so ein W3C-Standard, der im Wesentlichen eine Kopie von diesem ollen SRT-Subtitle Format ist, was sich so in der RIP-Szene durchgesetzt hat.
Warum ist das gruselig?
Eine Transkription ist halt nicht Untertitel. Untertitel sind dafür gedacht, um bei Frames, bei Video eingeblendet zu werden. Man kann das zwar benutzen, um Textbereiche von bis mit Start und Stop zu machen, dafür ist es schon irgendwie ganz gut. In diesem WebVTT ist dann noch so reingehackt, dass du dann auch noch so ein Wer spricht-Information mit reinbauen kannst.
Man muss ja Untertitel einfärben können.
Einfärben oder was auch immer. Aber es ist halt auf Untertitel ausgelegt. Und Transkripte sind eigentlich etwas komplexere Wesen. Da willst du irgendwie noch ein bisschen mehr Informationen haben. Und gerade wenn du sie an Podcast bindest, ist halt auch die Frage, wie viele Informationen von dem Podcast selber bringst du noch in die Datei mit rein? Wie identifizierst du diesen Podcast? Wie viele Metadaten hast du da? Wie viele Spuren kannst du irgendwie unterscheiden? Welche Metadaten zu den Personen willst du da noch einen Avatar mit dabei haben? Baust du den irgendwie ein? Wie machst du das? Und ja, all diese Dinge. Und dann hast du natürlich wiederum das Problem, dass du ein Transkript-Format musst halt auch überlegen, ok, in was für einem konkreten Format machst du das? Ist das zum Beispiel auch ein Format, was auch human writable ist?
Also, dass man einfach tippen kann?
Ja, wenn jemand jetzt so Transkripte schreibt, dass man eben auch so ein Format gut targeten kann, kann man natürlich ja sagen, ok, ja, nee, vielleicht ist das nicht so eine gute Idee. Man hat halt irgendein eigenes Format und dann überführt man das in das Format und dann könnte man ja auch XML nehmen und so weiter. Dann machst du halt wieder ein großes Fass auf und es gibt da jetzt einfach keinen konkreten Vorschlag und ehrlich gesagt, bei Potlap, wir haben da jetzt schon viel darüber diskutiert, ich hab da auch viel darüber nachgedacht, es ist knifflig. Du willst halt auch Transkripte vielleicht auch für etwas mehr benutzen, als nur zum Wiedergeben des Textes selbst. Sondern du möchtest es halt irgendwie auch nice machen. Also, ich kann ja mal kurz, wer vielleicht Lust hat, kann ja mal kurz auf Forschergeist gehen. Mein Podcast, den ich da für einen Stifterverband mache, der übrigens ziemlich gut ist, wie ich finde. Da habe ich das jetzt so eingebaut, dass, also wir arbeiten da sozusagen gerade dran, dass das Transkript im Prinzip genauso dargestellt wird, wie so der Chat im Slack aussieht. Das heißt, ich verbinde auch die einzelnen Teile, die alle eigene Zeitmarken haben und füge die zu so einem Blog zusammen. Aber wenn man so längere Blöcke hat, will man vielleicht auch noch Absätze unterscheiden. Das wäre schon ganz nett. Auch diese ganze Strukturierung ist relativ wichtig im Format, dass man das eben auch ordentlich in PDF überführen kann und dass man da einfach auch ordentliche Datenwiedergabe draus machen kann. Aber so wie das jetzt auf der Webseite ist, ist es eigentlich ganz nice. So, damit kann man auf jeden Fall schon mal arbeiten. Aber ein gutes Austauschformat ist so eine Sache. Letztlich könnte man das natürlich irgendwie mal definieren. Ob das dann übernommen wird, weiß ich nicht. Es wird sicherlich irgendjemand mal vorschlagen, man könnte doch einfach WebVTT verlinken und dann ist es das. Ja, okay, vielleicht läuft es darauf hinaus. Wäre ich nicht so richtig mit glücklich, aber es ist halt schon da. Es müsste am Ende natürlich ein Link im Feed sein, weil du kannst nicht das Komplett entwenden. Naja, ich würde das schon wollen. Dann hast du aber dieses fortwährende Problem, dass aufgeblähte Feeds in der Regel Podcast-Klien komplett durcheinanderbringen. Ich habe ja schon nicht alle Sendungen.
Nicht in die Feeds, sondern in den Medienfall. In den Audiofall mit reinmachen.
Wie schwer willst du es Podcast-Verzeichnissen machen, diese Daten auch auszuwerten? Also schon das Kapitelmarken mit dem Feed hat einen riesen Vorteil für Verzeichnisse. Wenn du es verlinkst, kann jedes Verzeichnis auch den kompletten Inhalt mitindizieren. Und wenn du dann auf so ein Portal wie FüD...
Aber um jetzt auf meine Frage zurückzukommen, wir stehen da noch sehr am Anfang. Das heißt, man kann das transkribieren. Du hast auch was, der Webplayer macht es sehr schön. Das habe ich selbst mal Leuten gezeigt in Montreal, die auch so Audio-Mitschnitte machen. Unsere Truppe aus Neapel, die auf den ITF-Meetings immer die ganzen Mitschnitte dort machen, mit Live-Chat und so. Die waren recht beeindruckt davon. Aber so was Standardisierung angeht, ist da noch nichts. Auf Phonik spielt auch schon Betas mit automatischer Transkription. Das ist aber alles 5 Fuß, oder was?
Na ja, also, auf Phonik verwendet WebVTT. Automatische Transkription ist ja nochmal ein anderes Problem. Automatischer Transkription ist halt die Qualität derzeit noch ziemlich mies. Du kannst es so benutzen für so persönliche Recherche, also seit einiger Zeit.
Indizier doch mal. Schmeiß mal ein paar Stunden Podcast rein, sammeln wir ein paar Keywords raus, okay.
Ja klar, aber wenn du das veröffentlichen willst, dann ist das ja auch deine Aussage von, das ist genau der Inhalt meines Podcasts. Und wenn du da über kritische Themen redest und dann wird irgendwo ein Nicht vergessen, dann publizierst du auf deiner eigenen Webseite das Gegenteil von dem, was du gesagt hast. Ohne das vielleicht selber zu wissen, weil du das nicht alles gegengelesen hast. Also das ist halt auch ein Problem auf der Ebene. Und deswegen kann man solchen automatischen Transkripten nicht so ohne weiteres vertrauen. Abgesehen davon, dass hier einfach auch Dünnekinds drin haben. Also die kommen halt mit Terminologien, Eigennamen, Genuschel und so weiter einfach nicht klar. Da ist einfach die KI noch nicht so weit, dass sie das alles herbeidanen kann.
Kann man da nicht so ein bisschen Mensch-Maschine-Kopplung machen? Das heißt also maschinell transkribieren und dann noch mal einen Jungen dransetzen, der das halt mitliest. So als Volontierarbeit. Ich meine, ist ja nicht jeder eine Elvira, die das nahe und los eintippt vom Band. Aber...
Das ist eins unserer Forschungsprojekte bei POTLOVE gerade. Aber auch das ist nicht ganz so einfach. Also ist es sicherlich machbar, aber... Wir haben jetzt auch große Sommerpause gehabt. Mal gucken, ob wir da...
Jetzt auch kein POT.LOVE-Treffen. Kein We-Has-Fit, kein Dingsen-Treffen im November.
Subscribes gibt's nicht mehr dieses Jahr. Nee, nächstes Jahr im März. Ich würde es mir mehr wünschen als jeder andere, dass wir da vorankommen. Aber noch ist es halt nicht so weit. Aber ich denke schon, automatische Transkripte in Massen überarbeiten wäre zum Beispiel etwas, was für die Freak Show ganz gut funktionieren könnte. Also wenn wir jetzt quasi das automatische Transkript nehmen und dann auf eine Plattform einspielen, wo man sagt, hier, alle mal herhören, werft euch mal daran, so, und jeder kriegt dann irgendwie eine Minute zugeteilt. Also die Idee ist quasi nicht nur kollektiv darauf zu arbeiten, sondern darüber auch automatisch die Quality Assurance zu machen. Also du hast halt einen Satz, und wenn der selbe, so ein Blog, und wenn der schon einmal, also der wird ja erstmal automatisch transkribiert, so, dann sagst du ja, ich will teilnehmen. Und dann klickst du, und dann kriegst du halt irgendeinen Ausschnitt. So, hier hast du eine Minute Inhalt, kannst du mal hören, und dann gucken, ob der Text, der da steht, passt. Und da, wo es nicht passt, klickst du drauf, änderst du, return, wird abgespeichert. So, das wird halt vielen Leuten vor die Nase gesetzt, so dass, wenn viele daran teilnehmen, halt viele Bereiche schnell schon ein erstes Mal überprüft worden sind, beziehungsweise korrigiert worden sind.
Wenn man schlau ist, gibt man einen Block mehr als eine Nase.
Genau, und wenn du nimmst dann die korrigierten Versionen, wirfst du die anderen wieder vor. Und wenn halt 3N, wie viel auch immer, Threshold, Menschen für einen Block sagen, ja, so ist das richtig, wie das jetzt da ist, dann könnte ich das halt auch automatisch approven, ohne mir jetzt eben 4 Stunden Transkription auch nochmal selber durchlesen und abhören zu müssen, um zu sagen, ok, jetzt passt das. Ich könnte also einfach sagen, ok, diese automatische Transkription, weil 24 Stunden hier ist quasi von Hörern abgenommen worden, die auch den Kontext der Sendung kennen, das ist ja auch nicht ganz unwichtig, also die so mit Begriffen und Referenzen und Memes klarkommen. Und dann ist es halt so drin, und dann könnte man natürlich dann auch, wenn die Leute sich anmelden, dann auch entsprechende Credits verteilen und die in die Shownotes packen.
Gamification Galant.
Ja, Gamification oder sagen wir mal einfach auch die entsprechenden Credits geben. Also wenn jemand mithilft, dann das einfach auch listen und nennen und so. Das wäre ja sehr schön und ich denke, das könnte ganz gut funktionieren. Die technologische Basis dafür würden wir gerne schaffen. Da sind wir halt konzeptionell schon recht weit, aber vom Code her steht da ehrlich gesagt noch nix. Ja, so wäre es schön. Deswegen investiere ich jetzt auch relativ viel Arbeit in dieses Transkript für den Forschergeist. Einfach, um erstmal eine Basis zu haben, mit dem man sozusagen zeigen kann, so könnte es sein. Und ich hoffe, dass man irgendwann dann eben auch über diesen Weg gute Transkripte für andere Podcasts machen kann. Alles, was halt viel gehört wird, denke ich mal, hat dann eine Chance, darüber auch so überarbeitet zu werden. Und ich würde es jetzt auch gerne sehen, mal so eine sendungsübergreifende Suche zu haben, dass man eben vielleicht wirklich mal Freak Show recherchieren kann. Da kriege ich immer wieder so Anfragen. Ihr habt doch irgendwann mal in irgendeiner Sendung was über, hm, hm, hm erzählt und so. Und dann, ja, nee, keine Ahnung, weiß ich auch nicht mehr ganz genau. Wird schon irgendwann gewesen sein, so. Ich habe die automatischen Transkripte der letzten 10, 12 Sendungen, habe ich, glaube ich, so auf Platte, aber das ist alles noch nicht so zusammengefegt, dass man da jetzt wirklich einen Service draus machen könnte. Magdrucken, aber auch das sind so Dinge, das sind alles so Dinge, wo ich vorhin schon meinte, mit den Spenden und so werden auf einmal Sachen möglich, wo man einfach mal ein bisschen investieren kann und ein bisschen nicht nur jetzt unbedingt so auf dem Open Source Weg erfolgreich wird, sondern vielleicht auch einfach mal ein paar Leute an ein paar knifflige Sachen ransetzen kann, damit hier so die Metaebene Experience noch ein bisschen geiler wird.
Irgendwelche Plans, den Chat da noch mit einzubeziehen? Der hat ja auch...
Den Chat, den wir jetzt gerade haben? Ja gut, solange das auf Slack läuft, ist das glaube ich illusorisch. Achso, du meinst... Ja, na klar, das wäre natürlich auch nice. Du meinst jetzt direkt mit der Webseite verbinden?
Nee, nee, nee, den Chat halt mit aufnehmen in die Sendungsaufzeichnung.
Ja, für die Show Notes wird das...
Also eine Transkription des Chats, sozusagen, technisch gesehen, nicht transkribierende, das ist ja schon...
Den Chat als solchen einfach nur aufzeichnen und wiedergeben?
Ja, mit im zeitlichen Kontext zur Sendung.
Achso, ja...
Auch durchsuchbar natürlich, das ist die Idee dabei. Ich muss jetzt nicht den Chat nachlesen, aber man weiß dann immer, hier wurde über das und das gesprochen, oder du sagst dann manchmal, hier sagt der Chat das und das, das wäre halt schön, wenn man dann gucken könnte, was der Chat dann auch gesagt hat.
Das ist in der Tat ein guter Punkt, da hab ich auch schon mal... Ansatzweise gab es schon mal ein paar Leute, die ein paar Bots gemacht haben, erstmal um so Show Notes zu sammeln, also diese Links aus dem Slack rauszuziehen, das ist immer sehr nervig, macht immer sehr viel Arbeit. Das wäre immer sehr schön, wenn da etwas mehr automatisiert werden könnte. Aber das Recht, natürlich wäre es auch ganz gut, da müsste man natürlich die Ansage an den Chat anders machen.
Wieso, wir können auch reinschreiben, was wir wollen. Du nimmst das halt einfach mit, mit dem Time Stamp und packst es dann da rein.
Aber derzeit ist der Slack ja auch bewusst nicht öffentlich. Also wer da jetzt dran teilnimmt, weiß zwar, dass jeder jetzt da mitliest, aber das versendet sich ja auch und Slack löscht ja den Kram auch irgendwann wieder. Ich habe da kein ewiges Archiv von dem und alles, was ihr da gesagt habt, wird auch irgendwann vergessen werden. Das wäre natürlich dann in dem Moment was anderes. Aber du hast recht, das wäre an sich ganz cool, weil das funktioniert tatsächlich bei Podcasts auch ganz cool. Also hier, Huxilla hat das mal das Konzept gemacht, ich weiß nicht, ob sie das immer noch machen, ich fand das eigentlich ganz geil, dass sie Sendungen aufgenommen haben und bevor sie dann veröffentlicht wurden, wurden sie erstmal live gesendet, waren aber schon aufgenommen. Na ja, du streamst quasi die Sendung erstmal, machst dann aber einen Chat und die Macher sind quasi mit im Chat, aber machen gerade nicht die Sendung, sondern können dann schon während der Sendung live aufkommende Fragen diskutieren. Habe ich so noch nicht gemacht, fände ich mal ganz interessant, das mal auszuprobieren, aber hat sich bisher so jetzt noch nicht für mich ergeben. Das müsste man dann schon mal ein bisschen durchdenken, wie man das dann konkret organisiert. Aber du hast recht, all diese Dinge sind wünschenswert. Allein, es fehlt noch ein wenig die Coding-Power und Zeit und so weiter. Aber vielleicht tut sich da jetzt was hier. Mit dem Metaebene-Support kann ich demnächst einfach auch mal ein paar Leute mehr auf Dinge ansetzen, wo ich sonst immer auf Goodwill angewiesen bin.
Ich habe seit Anfang des Jahres ein Projekt, ich weiß nicht, ob das interessant ist, das ist auf jeden Fall Nerdig. Soll ich da nochmal kurz was zu sagen? Ja. Es ist ja mittlerweile bekannt, dass ich so gelegentlich mal so ein paar Netze baue und so, für Events auch. Aber auch bin ich so mit reingeraten in ein Projekt, was ich sehr spannend finde, seit Anfang des Jahres, befasse ich mich mit Richtfunk und zwar ernsthaft. In dem Sinne auch ernsthaft, nehme ich unter anderem vom Fernsehturm am Alexanderplatz aus. So ungefähr 240 Meter Höhe, ist auch mal ganz lustig, da draußen ein bisschen rumzuhopsen und dann Antennen zu schrauben und so. Und das macht eine ganze Menge Spaß, weil man eben auch mal so ein bisschen was ausprobiert. Die Firma, die das betreibt und darin investiert, ist auch nicht so wie, ja dann klickt ihr halt auf eBay einen alten Linksys-Router und dann spielst du da oben WRT drauf und guckst mal, dass du dir aus einer so einer Chips-Röhre da eine Antenne baust. Also jetzt nix gegen die Leute, die das gerne machen, aber das ist halt schon wie immer spannend, da auch mal mit ernsthaften Equipment zu arbeiten. Und wir haben jetzt schon mehrfach eingesetzt, Gigabit Linksys auf wirklich ein Gigabit transportieren mit Turnaround-Zeiten unter einer Millisekunde, weil es wird ja auch immer gerne rumgekreischt, Richtfunk wäre ja scheiße, weil es hätte so ein Delay und sowas, ist aber gar nicht so, wenn man das richtig macht. Und jetzt, was wir hoffen, jetzt im Herbst noch zu testen, bevor das Wetter für den Winter wieder schlecht wird, ist mit 10G. Mal so 10G quer durch Berlin ballern, so vom Funkturm runter, ist auch immer ganz lustig. Na wir versorgen jetzt hauptsächlich auch so Events, also auch mal so Sachen, wo du halt jetzt nicht einfach mal so einen Anschluss hinkriegst. Beispielsweise waren jetzt Leichtathletik-Meisterschaften, Europameisterschaften in Berlin, und da gab es dann auch einen Marathon dazu. Und wir haben dann die Marathon-Strecke, wo diese Zählpunkte sind, dann auch mit Links versorgt. Da war jetzt nicht so ein dramatischer Trafik, das hätte man jetzt auch mit LTE bauen können, aber because we can. Und das ist halt schon sehr spannend, so vom Turm aus oben, was du alles siehst, oder von wo aus überall man den Turm sieht. Und das halt eben auch nutzen kann.
Das nutze ich schon immer als Referenzpunkt, wenn ich von außerhalb von Berlin komme, alles klar. Da wohne ich, weil ich bin ja mehr oder weniger um die Ecke. Also wenn ich da ankomme, bin ich zu Hause.
Schon cool. Auf der einen Seite der Tolle ist, du siehst ganz Berlin, auf der anderen Seite du hörst auch ganz Berlin. Wenn ich da mal so einen Check mache, wer da noch so oben sendet. Das ist laut, ja. Ich höre dann auch mal, welche Access Points, die irgendwo laut am Norden Damm stehen. Nach Siemenstadt sind jetzt auch so 10 Kilometer oder so was. Der hat vielleicht nicht ganz korrekte regulatorische Sendestärke auf seinem Wireless-AP oder so was. Also wenn er da wirklich steht, aber er heißt halt irgendwas mit Norden Damm. Was auch sehr spannend ist, wir benutzen auch lizenzierte Spektrum. Also wir haben auch Gerätschaften für 18 und 26 Gigahertz. Wo du dir dann von der Bundesnetzagentur, musst du schön brav so einen Antrag ausfüllen. Den gibt es auch für temporär und so. Dann muss man aber sehr genaue technische Angaben machen und dann weisen sie dir die Frequenz zu. Und die ist dann aber auch die dir auf dieser Strecke. Und das heißt, du kannst dann auch ordentlich powern. Damit kriegen wir dann eben auch wirklich einen Gigabit. Also um genau zu sein, unser Rekord ist bei 945,2 Megabit. Aber die auch wirklich garantiert und stabil irgendwo hin in Berlin. Wo man den Ton sehen kann. Da weißt du, dass wir diese Sachen, diese extrem mit dem Extremspeed, aber die Gigabit-Zeugs immer nur so ein paar Tage betreiben, weil wir jetzt nicht so viel Regen hatten in den letzten Monaten, kann ich dir noch nicht sagen. Als wir im Februar angefangen haben mit dem, also wir haben Anfang des Jahres damit angefangen, im Februar haben wir auch diverse andere Tests gemacht. Da war halt eben nur so ein bisschen Getropfe und ein bisschen Magischneier und so. Das stört noch nicht so. So richtig den richtig schweren, fetten Landregen haben wir noch nicht. Auf der anderen Seite, auf den lizenzierten Strecken, die berechnest du relativ genau auch mit dem Power und mit einer großen Powerreserve eben für Regen und so. Und dadurch, dass das ja lizenziertet Band ist, kriegst du da natürlich auch eine Power-Zuteilung. Und die kann teilweise auf manchen Bändern bis zu 60 Kilowatt gehen. Nicht, dass wir jetzt irgendwie 60 Kilowatt auf dem Turm oben hätten, aber du kannst halt da mit Power gegensteuern, was du in den offenen Bändern, in den ISM-Bändern bei 5 Gigahertz oder so halt eben nicht einfach machen darfst. Da bist du halt eben schon darauf limitiert, wie so ein WLAN-Ding, so ein WLAN-Access-Point, mit dem halt der Dapfer kommt. Ein lizenziertes Ding? Naja, die gibt es ja in verschiedenen Varianten wieder. Und unser Top-Ding oder so, das kostet schon so 10.000 Euro eine Seite.
Marathon-Jungs oder hier Berliner Leichtathletik können das auch bezahlen, oder die Firma kriegt da eine entsprechende Kohle.
Ja, wir benutzen auch andere Equipment. Aber diese lizenzierte Zeug, das merkst du auch schon einmal. Das haben schon ein paar Profis ein paar Jahre in der Hand gehabt. Vom Handling her auch. Es sind dann auch immer zwei, wenn du sowas machst. Zwei, wo du zwei Radius an einer Antenne betreibst, eins horizontal polarisiert, das ist dann vertikal.
Ist das dann eigentlich so bridge-mäßig, dass du dann so ein Ethernet-Port hast und deine Hardware dahinter weißt von nichts eigentlich und denkst, da ist Ethernet, oder ist es einfach so dazwischen geklemmt?
Genau, selbst wenn du zwei hast, die machen die Link-Aggregation. Also die zwei Dinger, also wenn du zwei Radius, eins horizontal, eins vertikal, das machen die selber so. Sie knobeln sich so aus, dass es für dich aussieht wie ein Ethernet. Das ist halt physikalisch ein Gigabit, beziehungsweise bei den neuen 5G- und 10G-Strecken ist das halt ein 10G-Link physikalisch. Und die knuspern sich das aus, dass sie die aufteilen auf zwei Radius und drüben wieder zusammensetzen. Und das geht halt wirklich ganz gut. Das macht auch Spaß, da mal zu basteln und da mal zu gucken, was so geht, auch mal so Sachen wie mit passiver Umlenkung mal spielen und so. Oder halt einfach nur gegen eine Schüssel ballerst, da ist nur ein Kabel hinten dran und noch eine Schüssel. Weil du kannst zwar sehr viel sehen, aber siehst halt eben nur die Dächer. Du siehst halt nicht in jeder Häuserschlucht runter. Und da kann man halt eben auch an dieser Stelle noch mal ein bisschen was basteln. Also das ist ein recht interessantes Experimentierfeld. Und man kann das, wenn man da ernsthafte Equipment benutzt, das muss jetzt nicht so teuer sein. Wir haben auch eine Ubiquiti R-Fiber da oben auch am Start. Die macht auch schon sehr ordentliche Resultate bei fast unmerklicher Latenz. Und so ein Ding, so eine R-Fiber, ich weiß nicht, was die jetzt kostet aktuell. Aber unter 1000 Euro kann man damit auch spielen. Mit dem lizenzierten Zeug würde ich sagen an den Horizont dran, weil notfalls drehst du halt den Power hoch. Da hängt davon ab 826 Gigahertz und ob du eine Strecke genehmigt kriegst dafür. Was übrigens ganz erstaunlich ist, das ist zwar wahnsinniger Papierkram und alles, aber eine dauerhafte Strecke ist ja was anderes. Aber du kannst da halt eben auf Freitag Nachmittag anrufen, Bundesbehörde, dann kannst du da Freitag Nachmittag deinen Antrag einrichten um 2.00 und um 3.00 oder halb 4.00 hast du die Zulassung dafür. Ja, irgendwie keine Ahnung. Das war auch der erstaunliche Punkt dabei. Wenn man das alles brav macht, wenn du natürlich Fehler machst in deinem Antrag, dann kann er eine Runde drehen in der Behörde. Aber wenn du das alles richtig machst, geht auch das. Also das ist schon handhabbar. Aber kostet auch Geld. Aber wie gesagt, für kommerzielle Events kann man das machen. Wir machen auch gerne mal so Events, die jetzt nicht so richtig die Kohle haben. Da kann man auch mal ein paar Bits droppen oder so. Da muss man natürlich gucken, dass man nicht selber noch dramatisch drauf zahlt oder so. Aber es gibt da Möglichkeiten. Und es ist auch sehr lustig, den Turm da sich alleine rumzutreiben. Der ist ja mal schön durch renoviert worden nach der Wende, aber man sieht immer noch an manchen Ecken diese lustigen Sachen. Der Turm ist ja ein Schwarzbau gewesen zu DDR-Zeiten, weil da gab es einen Bauantrag dafür. Das gefiel aber dem Bauamt gar nicht. Aus 1.300 Gründen gab es auch in der DDR. Und dann hat halt irgendwann jemand von der Partei gesagt, wir müssen den aber bis dann und dann haben und haben ihn einfach nur weitergebaut. Und was es natürlich auch nicht gab zu der Zeit, es gibt natürlich keine Turmbauindustrie. Das heißt, es gibt natürlich jetzt niemanden, der dir so das Standardmaterial, was du an so einem Turm hast, liefert für einen Turm. Jedenfalls damals nicht.
Musste alles speziell für den Turm gemacht werden?
Nee, oder adaptiert. Wenn du dir den Turm mal genauer anguckst, da hängt zum Beispiel so ein Kran draußen dran. Das ist ein alter Eisenbahnkran. Den haben sie umgebaselt. Und die Ausstiegstüren, das sind so Luken, das haben sie irgendwie aus dem U-Boot-Bau geschlaut. Also Sachen, das ist schon ganz lustig. Und wie gesagt, die Aussicht ist da auch ganz nett. Und das Wetter ist lustig. Also gerade so im Februar oder so, da bin ich mal da rausgegangen, bin aus dem Ausstieg, der ist so nördlich, so ein bisschen nordöstlich, da steigst du im Februar raus, denkst, ist ja geil, ist ja T-Shirt-Wetter. Und dann guckst du zwei Meter um die Ecke, da geht ja ein Blizzard um die Nase, das glaubst du nicht.
Das war noch, als es aus der Tür rauskam.
Nee, aber es ist halt wirklich auch einfach so, wenn es leicht regnet, hast du da oben sehr lustige Phänomene. In der Regel, wenn es nicht windstill ist, hast du auf der einen Seite regnet es richtig, also wie sich das gehört, von oben nach unten. Auf der anderen Seite regnet es von rechts nach links und von links nach rechts. Und wenn der Wind entsprechend steht, regnet es an einer Stelle auch von unten nach oben. Genau, aber du guckst halt raus da und denkst so, Moment, Regentropfen... Wie war das jetzt gemeint?
Auf welcher Höhe warst du da, von dem Restaurant oder noch weiter oben?
Über dem, das ist der Teil, das sind diese Ringe.
Aber noch in der Kugel oder noch weiter oben?
Nee, nee, oberhalb der Kugel, wenn du guckst, da wo auch dieser Kran hängt, das sind so Ringe, das sind so, keine Ahnung, sechs oder sieben Etagen, immer so zweieinhalb Meter auseinander. Und wir sind da so ein bisschen... Wir sind auf der Höhe, wo die weißen Blinker, die weißen und roten Blinker dran sind. Wenn du jetzt guckst, auf den Turm, der blitzt ja. Und da, neben den roten Blinkern, da haben wir unsere Antennen dran. Rundherum, so sektormäßig, haben wir die Stadt gut abgedeckt. Dass man jetzt auch einfach mal was von hier... Ihr könnt jetzt aus dem Kofferraum so ein Ding nehmen, das Ding anpeilen und dann gegen den Sektor gehen. Also so breit strahlende Antennen. Nö, mit denen machen wir keinen Gigabit auf den Sektor. Der Sektor ist so begrenzt auf ungefähr 250 Megabit. Aber das reicht dann auch so immer bis Schloss Charlottenburg. Easy Pisa, steigst du aus dem Auto aus, nimmst die Antenne raus, so ein kleines Stativ, so ein Lampenstativ, so... fallen da mal so 200 Megabits aus der Gegend raus. Symmetrisch, bitte schön. Und alles, was halt mehr braucht, das machen wir halt über dedizierte Strecken, die wir dann eben meistens dann auch lizenziert anmieten. Aber das ist ein ganz lustiges Spielobjekt. Ja, glaube ich. Ja, nichts für Leute mit Höhenangst.
Was fährt ihr da jetzt für ein Protokoll konkreter über diese Strecke?
Ethernet, also das ist eine Layer-2-Infrastruktur, die ich gemacht habe, worauf dann natürlich IPv6 und IPv4 angeboten wird. Aber du kannst auch einen nackten Layer-2 von uns mieten. Du brauchst zum Beispiel jetzt diese Marathon-Leute. Diese Zählsystem ist leider ein ziemlich dämliches Protokoll-Design. Und die sind darauf angewiesen, dass diese Kästchen alle in einem Laden sind.
Also Zählsystem ist, wenn die Läufer mit diesem Chip im Schuh über die Schwelle laufen.
Da gibt es mehrere davon und das, was sie jetzt am Start hatten, setzt voraus, dass diese Kästchen glauben, sie sind in einem Laden drin. Ziemlich dämliches Design. Man kann das auch am Wide Area-Betrieb machen, indem man jeder in dieser Kästchen eine Public IP-Adresse, Public V4 IP-Adresse zuweist, was wir auch wellig hatten, aber dachten, diese Systeme sehen nicht so aus, könnten sie China überstehen, weil in dem Moment, wo du eine Public IP V4-Adresse in Betrieb nimmst, hast du sofort, aber sofort, Checker drauf, vornehmlich aus China, Russland, Ukraine, USA. Und die Kästchen und die Software sahen nicht so aus, als würden sie das aushalten. Also haben wir den in LAN gebaut, also in Layer 2 Infrastruktur, dass sozusagen LAN-Ports in der ganzen Stadt verteilt hast. Dafür ist es designt, aber wenn du das als Grundinfrastruktur hast, kann ich dir natürlich darauf auch ein V6 oder V4-Feed anbieten. Mit ordentlichem Peering und so und scharf. Das ist auch so mein Punkt, wo ich da reingekommen bin, weil die Leute, die das machen, haben sich gedacht, ja, das mit dem Radio kriegen wir ganz gut hin, aber jetzt nochmal ISP werden und was muss man dazu alles machen und ach, beim Reib und dann da AS-Nummern, was ist das und IP-Adressraum und blablabla und Peering und so und da habe ich gesagt, ja, das mache ich euch die Haare schön. Das kann ich, das habe ich schon ein paar Mal gemacht und das war auch immer noch sehr lustig. Mal so gucken, was so geht da an dieser Stelle. Wie sich so manche Firmen aufbenehmen. Zum Beispiel erstaunlicherweise Microsoft Peering angefragt. Microsoft so, jo, füll mal hier dieses Formular aus, klick, paar Stunden später, so ist konfiguriert, zack, fertig, Peering da, alles easy peasy. Apple, Mail geschickt, Anfrage geschickt, Crickets and Tumbleweeds.
Genau.
Ja, will ich jetzt nochmal nachfangen, aus dem Hobsen ein paar von denen auf den ITF Meetings rum, da werde ich nochmal gegen treten. Auch zum Beispiel sehr, sehr auf, äh, äh, sozusagen sehr, sehr kooperationsbereit, ähm, Google. Wie ist denn so? Google peern? Ja, ist konfiguriert. Egal. So, wollte ich nur mal erzählen, kann ich vielleicht mal nochmal, wenn wir nochmal ein paar lustige Episoden da haben jetzt, das Projekt ist ja ongoing, da nochmal was zu erzählen, aber so für all die Nerds, die meinen, ach ja, und Funk und Richtfunk, ist ja alles kack und so. Da geht noch was.
Hm, noch nicht so richtig viel, ehrlich gesagt, weil ich da gerade noch so in der Progress-Phase bin. Genau, ich habe mir überlegt, dass ich jetzt demnächst meine Selbständigkeit, die ja bisher nur Leuten bekannt war, mit denen ich irgendwie bisher vorher zusammengearbeitet habe oder im Büro gesessen habe. Und ja, ich fand unseren letzten Gast, wo ich da war, den Alexander, ziemlich spannend, was er so erzählt hat, was er so macht. Und wir haben uns im Nachhinein noch kurz unterhalten. Das hat mich so ein bisschen nochmal zum Denken angestoßen. Und ja, was ich gerade plane, ist so ein bisschen meine Selbständigkeit auszubauen. Und genau, to be continued an der Stelle.
Magst du verraten, worin deine selbstständige Tätigkeit bestehen könnte?
Genau, also es wird im groben VSS bei Datenvisualisierung an sich bleiben, weil das macht mir schon sehr viel Spaß. Aber ich merke halt auch so ein bisschen, da hat Huckel ja schon mal mit dem Zaunfall gewinkt, so durch das Backend-Coden. Das macht mir halt auch mittlerweile eine ganze Menge Spaß. Und ich finde bei der Visualisierung, so mit Python zu arbeiten, als Backend und Visualisierung, dann im Frontend, hat man so eine echt schöne Pipeline, womit ich aber auch eigentlich auf längere Sicht nicht alleine bleiben will. Also meine Selbstständigkeit ist erst mal so ein Schritt to be continued, wie ich gesagt habe. Aber genau, ich habe jetzt überlegt, das wird jetzt mal angestoßen, um dann halt auch später vielleicht mal ein bisschen mehr Freizeit auch für andere Projekte zu haben.
Selbstständigkeit heißt ja eigentlich immer?
Genau. Erst mal nur selbstständig sein. Aber noch nicht...
Noch keine Kunden.
Ach so, ja genau, nein, noch keine Kunden. Ich mache zwar immer noch kleinere Aufträge.
Also du möchtest auch keine haben oder was?
Doch, doch, nee, ich möchte auch Kunden haben. Nein, aber ich bin gerade dabei, mir überhaupt so meine Webseite aufzubauen, damit man auch so ein Showcase hat, damit Leute mal sehen, was ich überhaupt so mache. Und hat mir dann so doofe Gedanken gemacht, wie also eigentlich wollte ich nie auf sowas wie LinkedIn und Xing sein, aber wenn man selbstständig ist, nee. Habt ihr das Gefühl, manchmal, nee, braucht man das nicht?
Nee, braucht man nicht.
Das brauchst du dann, wenn du dich gerne von doller Firma abgeworben haben möchtest aus deiner...
Oder wenn du jeden Tag 23 Headhunter-Mails mit unsinnigen Jobangeboten haben möchtest.
Genau, ich bin halt gerade so dabei, so auszuloten, was ist sinnvoll und wo will ich die Finger davon lassen?
Also, LinkedIn bringt dir als Selbstständiger so gut wie nix. Da bringt es dir mehr, wenn du hier im Podcast sagst, ey yo, ich hab ne Webseite und mach Datenvisualisierung und du kriegst garantiert 10-mal mehr sinnvollere Anfragen, als du jemals über LinkedIn kriegen würdest.
Oder wenn du dir jetzt zum Beispiel sagst, was machst du denn für Datenvisualisierung? Einmal, so ich geb dir ein Datenwerk, du machst mir eine schöne PDF-Serie draus, oder eine Webseite, oder auch so dynamisch sozusagen, dass man sagt, guck mal, ich hab hier laufend diese Daten, kannst du mir mal designen, wie ich die auch laufend weiter visualisiere. Ich möchte mir gerne eine Webseite aufbauen, wo man die sehen kann die ganze Zeit. So lebendes Grafana.
Ja genau, also es ist bei mir immer bisher dynamisch im Sinne von interaktiv gewesen, dass man also dynamisch und meinst wahrscheinlich jetzt eher sowas wie...
Stehende Daten oder bewegende Daten.
Genau, das ist für mich kein Unterschied. Aber was für mich ein Unterschied zum Beispiel wäre, weil du sagst, das PDF-Print habe ich bisher nie gemacht, es sei denn ich exportiere meine Grafik, die ich fürs Web oder für irgendwas gestaltet habe, gestaltet, gecodet und gestaltet habe. Also ich kann halt nach wie vor, wenn ich kein Mensch, der mit Illustrator umgehen kann, und ich finde es auch viel zu mühselig, eine UI zu verstehen anstelle etwas selber zu coden, weil ich da in dem Denkfluss eher gerade drin bin.
Aber machst du das einmal, um dann einmal aus einem bestehenden Datenberg mit Code, Grafik, Visualisierung zu erzeugen? Oder kann man auch so sagen, ich habe hier einen Stream von Daten, der läuft auch noch weiter. Klar habe ich jetzt hier schon etwas akkumuliert über die letzten Wochen, Monate, Jahre, aber ich möchte jetzt gerne das Fortlaufen weiter haben. Kannst du mir eine Webseite designen, die das macht? Auf meinem Server-Host, wo dann meine Kunden die fortlaufenden Daten sehen.
Du hast wahrscheinlich dann wohl nicht in vorigen Folgen zugehört, was die Letty sonst so macht, ne?
Nur wenn ich live dazuhöre.
Nein, also in der Tat, beides mache ich. Ich habe einen Kunden im Medizinbereich gehabt, wo ich sogar eine ganz interessante Visualisierung gebaut habe, weil ich einen anonymisierten Datensatz von Patienten bekommen habe, der jetzt eben austauschbar ist für jede Art von Patientendaten, die so aufgebaut sind, wo man einfach selber das eben hosten kann auf dem Server und die Daten dann einfach dahinter austauschbar macht. Und was halt super spannend ist, so vorher war für mich Visualisierung meistens das Endprodukt. Und da war es aber der Anfang von einer weiteren Pipeline. Also in der Medizinunternehmen wurde diese Software dann eingesetzt, um das gesamte Verarbeiten der Daten überhaupt anzustoßen, um so einen ersten visuellen Eindruck der Daten zu haben. Was irgendwie vorher für mich nie so ein Punkt in der Visualisierung war, weil ich habe irgendwie vorher beim Tagesspiegel auch mal gearbeitet, und du hast so diesen Journalismusbereich, wo ganz klar die Visualisierung ist das Letzte, was entsteht. Und da war es aber so das Erste, was entsteht, um dann weitere Schlussfolgerungen, weitere Analysen auf den Daten fahren zu können. Was halt interessant ist, und ich kann halt genauso mit Daten arbeiten, als auch mit Streams im Sinne von APIs, die eine Streaming-API sind. Also das ist halt auch gar kein Thema. Da habe ich mittlerweile auch vieles gemacht und baue jetzt auch gerade für meinen aktuellen Job, den ich ja auch noch habe, eine API auch selber mal auf. Also wie muss man so Daten ablegen, bereitstellen und so weiter. Das schaue ich mir zum Beispiel auch gerade an. Und das ist so ein bisschen das, wo ich halt auch merke, da gibt es vielleicht so den größten Konflikt, um zu beschreiben, was ich mache, weil ich halt viel im Backend mittlerweile auch unterwegs bin. Aber halt auch genauso Visualisierung im Sinne von einer Webseite, die da am Ende rauskommt, die eben irgendwo gehostet werden kann, von mir gehostet wird oder eben auch mal nur lokal laufen kann. Weil ich weiß, dass das für die Medizinsoftware eine Zeit lang erstmal noch lokal gelaufen ist, weil es nur für eine Person relevant war, die an der Pipeline gearbeitet hat. Genau und mein Bereich ist halt mittlerweile auch ganz schön breit gefächert, wie mir letztens aufgefallen ist. Ich habe irgendwie mal angefangen, aus dem Medizinbereich Sachen zu visualisieren, bis hin zu eben Donaldismus und Kulturdaten.
Ich wüsste, was du als erstes mal visualisieren sollst.
Ey, nicht dein Kalender! Ja, was hätten wir denn gern?
Naja, dich. Also du müsstest mal dein Portfolio sozusagen, also ich meine, wenn man als Visualisierungsexpertin unterwegs sein will, könnte man ja schon mal bei sich selber anfangen, um das mal aufs Spitz einzuwerfen.
Das ist lustig, weil darüber habe ich nachgedacht, weil ich habe irgendwie gesucht nach Inspiration. Also ich design halt auch, ich würde es natürlich Design direkt nennen, aber ich gestalte gerade die Webseite neu und habe erst mal geschaut so, was will ich eigentlich für eine Webseite, wo kriegt man so Inspiration für eine Webseite, die nicht für einen Designer gemacht ist, weil Designer haben immer die schönsten Webseiten, weil sie irgendwie Grafiken bauen können, und es sieht irgendwie alles nice aus, und du denkst dir so, ja geil, dann guckst du dir deine eigene an. Und dann dachtest du, wie kann man Visualisierung in einer coolen Webseite verpacken? Und da ist mir gerade eben noch keine gute Idee gekommen. Vielleicht habe ich gerade eine Idee entwickelt.
Du solltest dich selber visualisieren.
Genau, vielleicht sollte ich mich selber machen.
Deine Datenpunkte nehmen, die relevant sind und dafür...
Wir sollten öfter über solche Dinge reden, in Podcasts, damit mir Ideen kommen.
Ich meine, das ist so das, was ich...
Jetzt wird erstmal ganz brav analog aufgemalt. Genau, die Federtaste wird jetzt geöffnet, der Notizzettel rausgenommen, ein Stift.
Das sind...
Sehr geil.
Um das mal noch kurz einzuwerfen, ich bin, was meine Organisation angeht, wirklich krass analog unterwegs. Ich habe irgendwie so dieses Trello und Asana ausprobiert und ich bin zu blöd, um das digital gut hinzubekommen.
Nee, die Tools sind scheiße.
Und ich liebe meine To-Do-Zettel auf irgendwie so quadratischem Papier, wo ich alles fleißig abhaken kann. Und deswegen, ich schreibe mir wirklich sehr, sehr viel auf.
Also Trello und Asana, das sind auch Tools, die auch Probleme lösen wollen, die keiner hat.
Ja, manchmal bin ich kurz davor, ich glaube, das überlege ich mir jetzt auch ernsthaft, so eine einfachen, to-do-ähnlichen Apps, die simple and stupid sind. Also ich finde nach wie vor Apple Notes schon mal ein sehr guter Anfang für so einfache Sachen. Ich mache mir immer so gerne Wochenübersichten.
Diese Stühle machen mich fertig nach einer Weile.
Aber was ich halt eigentlich wissen will, so ein bisschen nicht nur wegen Zeit-Tracking, sondern auch so wie mit deinem Copper, sich so einen Timer zu stellen, um dann mal eine Pause zu machen. Eigentlich hätte ich sowas ganz gerne und schön für mein iPhone. Und ich bin mir mittlerweile überlegen, diesen Blödsinn einfach mal selber in Swift auszuprobieren. Weil ich mir denke, es gibt nichts, was ich cool finde. Ich habe selbst diese blöde Forest-App, falls ihr die irgendwie kennt, lieber Schett, mal ausprobiert. Das ist ja der furchtbarste Mist, den ich je gesehen habe.
Ich sage ja die ganze Zeit, es wird alles schlecht.
Und das sagen die Jugendlichen hier quasi.
Ja, ja, wir sind Listen.
Also ich glaube, du weißt jetzt schon, was zu tun ist. Ansonsten denke ich, kann man dich schon ansprechen?
Mich kann man immer ansprechen. Also es ist mir auch aufgefallen, dass ich nirgendwo meine richtige E-Mail-Adresse absetze, meine komische Arbeits-E-Mail-Adresse.
Sag doch mal jetzt mal, was dein Kontaktpunkt ist.
Also man kann mir auf Twitter erst mal anpingen, falls man ansonsten auch meine E-Mail-Adresse ist.
Du liest doch Twitter nur alle drei Monate.
Das stimmt so nicht. Es fällt mir wirklich schwer daran zu denken, dass ich es habe und ich entschuldige mich ganz offen dafür, dass ich Leuten manchmal nicht zurücksprache. Die E-Mail-Adresse ist in der Tat mit Contact, Englisch C, at letty.io. Die beste Variante und ich werde das auch mal ganz groß auf meine E-Mail, auf meine Homepage bauen. Genau und was ich in dem zuge, das können wir an späterer Stelle auch nochmal genauer ausführen. Das habe ich auch kurz erwähnt in der Sendung mit Alexander, ich diesen Static Site Generator, der in Go geschrieben ist, gerade so lieben gelernt, weil ich diese Webseite, die ich baue, so ein bisschen so Content trennen wollte, aber auch überlege, vielleicht jetzt wieder, so vielleicht einen Blog zu bauen, wo ich so zum einen meine Lehrveranstaltungen, die ich ja gegeben habe über Information Visualization mit JavaScript, mit den Libraries so ein bisschen aufgebaut habe, auch mal da so zu verwursten, weil derzeit ist es halt nur ein Repository auf GitHub mit den ganzen Materialien. Und da überlege ich halt auch nochmal, ob so ein Blog vielleicht nochmal was Cooles ist auch für eine Webseite, um so was nochmal an so einer zentralen Stelle mit anzudoggeln. Und da ist dieses Hugo halt so, du kannst einen Blog machen, du kannst aber auch nur eine Homepage dir daraus bauen, weil du irgendwie, einfach würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber die haben eine super gute Templating-Engine, wo du halt mit der Markup-Language dahinter dir deine Seite zusammenbauen kannst und somit ein bisschen CSS-Geraffel, oder SCSS besser gesagt, die die Seite auch so ein bisschen schön machst.
Hoffentlich in ordentlich.
Was das? CSS? Habe ich da gerade gehört, dass du da drüber gucken möchtest, weil ich das zu mache?
Da hörst du nur raus, dass ich in letzter Zeit so viel kaputtes HTML und CSS gesehen habe, dass ich am Verstand der Menschheit zweifle. Nee, also das Leute, weiß schon so, diese Leute, die für jede Variante von dem gleichen Element eine eigene Klasse machen und nichts von diesen Selektoren verstanden haben und dann hast du so eine Klassen- und ID-Wüste im CSS und das C, das Cascading, wird komplett ignoriert und das sind eigentlich nur noch... Box One, Box Two, Box Three. Oder Link, Underline, Link, No Underline, Link in Paragraph, Link in Headline, Link in...
Okay, na gut, ich glaube, dass ich da wirklich gerade versuche, eine Menge besser zu verstehen, weil ich habe CSS auch lange nicht gut geschrieben und auch nicht richtig verstanden. Lese aber gerade immer mehr dazu. Und ich meine, jetzt die Arbeit mit den Designern zusammen hilft da auch so ein bisschen weiter, um auch so ein paar Sachen nochmal zu entdecken und zu wissen. Aber das ist nach wie vor so eine Wüste für sich.
Aber auch da sei nochmal, hatte ich glaube ich vor einer kurzen Zeit schon mal erwähnt, der CSS-Sennengarden erwähnt.
Der CSS-Sennengarden?
Der CSS-Sennengarden, das ist eine der besten Seiten überhaupt, mit der ich so mein CSS-Handwerk lernte, weil das ist eine Seite HTML sehr schön strukturiert und die Leute können da CSS einsenden und jedes Design sieht komplett anders aus, obwohl es immer exakt das gleiche HTML ist. Und ich dachte, die Seite wäre mittlerweile schon tot, weil das ist noch aus CSS. Nee, auch von einer, weiß nicht, als ich vor einer Weile wieder mal damit zu tun hatte. Auf jeden Fall finde ich, die Seite, die ist jetzt immer noch mit HTML5 und CSS3 schicken die Leute die absolut krassesten Designs und es ist immer das gleiche HTML. Das ist das Verrückte.
218 verschiedene Designs.
Ja, klick mal, kannst ja mal das erste anklicken. Und jede Seite ist wirklich so komplett anders. Und jetzt mittlerweile auch mit Animations und so weiter. Und da kannst du halt, ich habe am Anfang dann immer so geguckt, so ja, wie haben sie denn das gemacht? Und du kannst dann halt mit dem Inspector auf die Elemente gehen und weil das HTML so simpel ist, ist es halt auch nicht so eine krasse Wüste, sondern du siehst dann halt auch ziemlich genau, wie sie bestimmte Elemente gemacht haben. Und das ist, finde ich, eine sehr, erstens eine coole Inspiration und zweitens sieht man da auch, was überhaupt so möglich ist mit Selektor-Magic und so, weil das HTML hat halt eben nicht 1000 IDs und 1000 Klassen.
Was ja auch so ein bisschen meine, ja eine meiner Lieblingsseiten mittlerweile geworden ist, weil sie wirklich gute, gut strukturierte Artikel zu verschiedenen CSS-Themen haben. Das ist dieses CSS-Tricks.
Ja, die ist auch sehr gut.
Gerade so dieses Flexbox-Geraffel, das total großartig. Also da habe ich eine Menge. Ja, genau, damit habe ich bisher noch nie so viel gearbeitet, aber mit den Flexboxen, damit erschlage ich so fast alles bisher. Das ist echt cool, macht Spaß damit zu arbeiten.
Ja, das habe ich ja dieses Jahr erst gelernt, dass es jetzt mittlerweile endlich wirklich Grid in CSS und so HTML gibt. Also eher in CSS. Und wer das nicht kennt, das sind so die Gestaltungsraster, die man fast aus dem Print kennt, nur aufs Web übertragen und das erste Mal in ordentlich. Also wer schon immer damit zu kämpfen hatte, Elemente nebeneinander, übereinander, in bestimmten Anordnungen mit Floats zu positionieren. Das geht jetzt mit den CSS-Grids ziemlich cool.
Ja, das ist schön. Huckel, wenn du hier gerade schon so kluge Sprüche von dir gibst, Single-Page-Layout oder Multi-Page-Layout?
Wie Layout?
Layout, Single-Page versus Multi-Page.
Kommt auf den Use-Case an. Depends, aber wenn du eine App machst, dann macht Single-Page mehr Sinn. Also wenn du zum Beispiel eine Webseite hast, dann würde ich persönlich auf URLs auf einzelne Reichen versetzen.
Auf jeden Fall, wer Interesse hat, tolle Visualisierungen zu bekommen und schon immer die passende Expertin gesucht hat.
Sie sieht jetzt immerhin schon mal anders aus als das erste Mal hier.
Mit diesen I.O.-Adressen. Eine Kollegin von mir, die hat die Domain yippie.io. Die finde ich auch sehr schön.
Was mir im Übrigen dann noch so einen kleinen Konflikt hat, ob ich unter letty.io auftrete oder unter meinem richtigen Namen. Und da finde ich, ist das Problem, da hast du mich, Clemens, ja auch schon mal drauf angesprochen. Eine Person mit demselben Namen in derselben Stadt gibt es auch schon.
Auch prominent auf Twitter.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Katja Dittrich, du kennst bestimmt diese lustigen Tortengrafiken, die immer so in einer Zeitung aufbauen, die es auch einzeln gibt. Katja Berlin.
Genau, und das ist halt so, wo ich gerade überlegt habe, ich habe zwar auch katjadittrich.com, aber ich will die nicht so prominent mittlerweile so vermarkten, weil ich mir halt denke, es ist voll blöd, wenn Leute sich halt vertippen, dann kommen sie bei der anderen Person raus. Warum ich mir jetzt halt auch überlegt habe, dass ich mit letty.io so als, ich will es jetzt nicht Business-Webseite sagen, aber schon so in die Richtung, dass das diese Marke Letty werden.
Den Hucke gibt es ja auch nur aus Namespace Gründen.
Naja, dieses Nickname sozusagen.
Das erste, was aus der Tastatur rausfiel. Nee, eigentlich das letzte in dem Abend, aber das sollte mich jahrelang begleiten.
Hucke die Hucke. So, dann haben wir das auch in der Tonne. Eigentlich sind wir schon fertig, aber ich wollte noch eine kleine Frage in die Runde machen, wo ihr vielleicht noch eine Meinung habt. Und ihr könnt mir auch die Idee ausreden. Hab ich darüber nachgedacht, ob ich mir nicht vielleicht doch mal so nass hinlegge? Warum brauche ich das? Einfach so als Auslagerungsort für Zeug.
Sozusagen dediziert, damit du, wenn du dein Mac bootest, aber trotzdem mit einem anderen Rechner noch an den Storage rankommst.
Ja, und auch so Daten, die man jetzt wirklich nicht unbedingt immer so im Operations-Teil eines Rechners rumliegen muss, sondern die einfach wirklich nur archiviert sind.
Aber wo willst du das betreiben? In deinem Büro?
Hier.
Hier und vielleicht auch eines zu Hause für den ähnlichen Bedarf.
Okay, meine Antwort ist kurz. Ich glaube nicht an Plastikboxen.
Das ist ja nicht eine Plastikbox.
Aber alles andere ist teuer und laut und verbraucht Strom und heizt.
Das ist das einzige Statement, was ich verbrieft machen kann. Also ob du jetzt ein FreeBestie-Router, eine Stromspanne zu Hause mit einem Atom-Board hast.
Ich glaube, ich noch Atom, wenn die noch so heißen. Ultrasparsam, war aber auch sehr teuer von Supermicro. Aber läuft seit drei Jahren schon.
Aber ich glaube, Tim hat jetzt nicht unbedingt nach so einer Bastellösung gesucht.
Tim, warum klickst du nicht einfach an den CNG-Link und hostest dafür den ganzen Scheiß in einem Rechenzentrum? Was? Natürlich gibt es das. Du bist halt nur zu cheap dafür.
Im Rechenzentrum braucht man dann auch schon wieder was. Also es ist ein anderer Preis dann.
Ja, aber dann hast du es nicht hier stehen.
Aber Rechenzentrum sind 50 Euro im Monat oder 16?
Das ist ja fast nichts im Jahr. Was habe ich denn dann da im Rechenzentrum?
Ja, super.
Habe ich da im Rechenzentrum, was habe ich denn da? Da muss ja auch was sein.
Also ich bin grundsätzlich, nur mal um jetzt meinen ernsthaften Feedback zu geben, ich bin grundsätzlich von der Idee abgekommen oder bin auf dem Trip, so wenig wie möglich Hardware selber zu betreiben. Weil Murphy stellt sicher, dass in dem Moment, wo ich mich darauf verlasse, dass das Ding geht, ich sitze im Flugzeug, komme an, Hardware ist kaputt. Und dann hast du keinen Vogel da, der neben dem Ding rumschraubt, der der Ding bootet oder sonst irgendwas. Und das ging mir jetzt zu den letzten 20 Jahren derdig auf die Ketten, dass ich jetzt einfach gesagt habe, nee, ich gucke mal, ob ich das nicht einfach auch loswerde, diese ganze Hardware und einfach dann virtuelles Zeug irgendwo hoste oder so. Aber das ist natürlich jetzt für ein Nass...
Kommt ja auch auf die Datenmenge an...
.bedient, was mir ist mit deinen Daten halt nicht so...
Das wäre die nächste oder eigentlich die erste Frage, was für eine Größenordnung Daten...
Und wie schnell du die haben musst. Oder wie schnell du das hinschieben können willst.
Im Zweifelsfall halt viele, viele, viele Giga und Terabyte.
Ja, Größenordnung, zig Giga, Terabyte, hunderte Terabyte.
Ist schon ein Unterschied, ein Terabyte oder zehn ist ja schon mal wichtig.
Viele Computer machen viele Backups, da kommt einiges zusammen. Du willst irgendwie all deine Fotos, irgendwie all den Kram...
Ja, aber das schließt auch online schon mal aus. Du willst das lokal haben.
Nein.
Doch, ich sag das so.
Davon rede ich ja die ganze Zeit.
Also ich hab zu Hause, der macht jetzt nicht nur meinen NAS, sondern der ist halt auch gleichzeitig mein, was ist er, mein PPP-over-Ethernet-Rechner, weil ich das nicht diese Billigbox da machen lassen will, sondern das macht meine Kiste selbst. Das ist aber egal, aber da sind zwei Platten drin, ZFS, ein Mirror. Da läuft auch Time Machine-kompatibles Netatalk, sodass mein Laptop, wenn ich es zu Hause aufklappe, dort gleich Backup hinmacht und so weiter. Das habe ich seit über zehn Jahren, wahrscheinlich 15, und update das alle paar Jahre wieder. Inzwischen bin ich bei so einer stromsparenden Lösung, dass ich mir da auch gar keinen Kopf mehr mache und kein schlechtes Gewissen mehr habe. Also das funktioniert super.
Ich habe ein System, wo ich mindestens sechs Platten reinschieben kann mit entsprechender Redundanz. Wenn eine Platte kaputt ist, dann ist da eine rote Lampe und sagt, tausche mich aus. Und um auszutauschen, ziehe ich die raus, schiebe eine neue rein, fertig.
Ja, das wird schon schwierig.
Naja, ich meine, das ist so das, was so ein Drobo macht. Das gibt es irgendwie von Synology und so weiter. Also in dieser Kategorie Produkt gibt es sowas.
Ja, und dann fragst du halt die Falschen an der Stelle.
Das kann ja sein, aber es sind ja jetzt gerade keine anderen da.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was sie bei Synology machen, dass da die rote Lampe angeht, also wenn die Platte richtig physikalisch kaputt ist. Aber das ZFS hat halt dieses Feature, wenn es halt kaputte Blöcke kommen, da muss ja nicht gleich so richtig die Platte physikalisch kaputt sein, dass schon die rote Lampe angehen würde. Aber für ZFS, da sagt, oh, hier geht es aber langsam los mit den Fehlern. Da müsste man ja dann einen Skript haben, was auch immer, und was irgendwie denn eine rote Lampe ansteuern kann. Also das kann man sich nicht so selber basteln. Das, was du willst, sieht danach fertig Lösung aus. Das ist aber dann kein schickes ZFS, würde ich mal behaupten. Und ich hätte keinen Bock auf irgendein... wo die da nicht ordentlich durchchecken.
Es muss halt als Backup-Target funktionieren. Es muss irgendwie Time Machine-kompatibel sein. Es muss irgendwie alle gängigen Protokolle unterstützen. Und einfach...
Sorry, das ist zu einfach gegriffen. Unter anderem deswegen, weil wir leben in einer sehr schnellwiegen Zeit. Und gerade Backups möchtest du vielleicht doch ein bisschen länger haben, auch dein Backup-System. Und das ist halt eben schon schick, wenn du selber bastelst mit irgendwas, mit ZFS oder so, dann hast du, sagen wir mal, eine gewisse Zukunftssicherheit. Selbst wenn du eine Inzidenology kaufst, das Ding kann morgen bankrupt sein. Und dann benutzt du irgendeinen proprietären Scheiß für your mirroring, d.h. selbst wenn du die Platten ausbaust, also was, kannst du mit dem Scheiß nichts mehr anfangen. Und dann fängst du wieder von vorne an. Klar, deine Inzidenology wird jetzt nicht total sofort umfallen, wenn die Jungs bankrupt gehen, dann kann man das immer noch migrieren oder so. Aber das ist immer so...
Wie du schon sagst, also wenn die bankrupt gehen, dann kann man das irgendwie schon nochmal migrieren. Ich sehe da ehrlich gesagt, weniger Bedrohung in solchen Szenarien, als in dem Szenario, wie mein FreeBSD läuft jetzt nicht mehr wegen Dollarfehler. Und ich kriege es selber nicht gepickt.
Ich hatte es noch nie, dass ein FreeBSD wegen irgendwelcher Fehler nicht mehr läuft. Noch nie in 15 Jahren, 20 Jahren FreeBSD.
Moment, stopp, da gibt es eine Kategorie Fehler, die ihr nicht macht. Bedienungsfehler.
Doch, natürlich, gerade am Anfang.
Du bedienst das nicht. Der Städter läuft ein Jahr durch und du machst dann nichts.
Ja, aber da kann ich nicht eine Platte rausziehen und eine neue reinschieben und dann läuft es weiter.
Mit Redundanz? Du sagst am ZFS oder der ZFS hier, diese Platte ist kaputt. Du ziehst die raus, steckst eine neue rein, sagst hier Replay, und fertig.
Ich schiebe eine 4TB Platte rein, wo vorher eine 2TB Platte war. Dann habe ich 2TB mehr als vorher.
Nein, das nicht, weil nicht im Über, da muss ja dein zweites Ding genauso viel Space haben.
Ja, aber du hast noch diesen Drobo-Fail schon hinter dir. Der dir das Flower vom Himmel versprochen hat, wie toll das alles ist und wie toll war es.
Jetzt kannst du den Tumbleweed-Sound nochmal anmachen.
Naja, gut, dieser Daten-Fail war halt am Anfang. Du, ich benutze das Ding so selten, weil es einfach im Wesentlichen Daten hält. So, das ist jetzt kein Backup-Target, das ist einfach nur ein reiner Archiv-Speicher. Und als solcher muss ich sagen, funktioniert er.
Ich habe vor vielen, vielen Jahren bei Freunden mit einem kleinen Gewerbe mal so ein Promise-Ding angebracht.
Ja, es könnte sein, dass ich das tue, ja.
So ein Promise-Thunderbolt-Ding angebracht. Das läuft heute noch, wie Sau, mit Management und tralala. Und inzwischen drei gewechselten Platten.
Die Promise-Sachen sind dann auch mit premium Preisen.
Ja, waren sie damals auch, das ist halt Mac-Equipment. Fertig, aber das ist jetzt wie gesagt, die Erfahrung ist ein paar Jahre alt, aber der Ding läuft immer noch.
Kannst du dich eigentlich an das Custom-System vom Kongress erinnern?
Diese Promise-Pega-Sauce-Dinger.
Der wurde ersetzt, der Shuttle steht bei mir zu Hause, der alte da läuft.
Dennis, deine Aufgabe für zu Hause heißt, hör dir mal Podcasts an. Dass sie nicht wieder reinkommen, bevor du nicht selber Podcasts angehört hast. Damit du mal weißt, wie das ist.
Ich hab mich mit Hucke unterhalten.
Ja eben. Machs nicht fertig.
Fettig oder?
Fettig machst du mich.
Ja, das ist ein Drobo, das war doch ein Fail.
Für wen jetzt?
Für dich? Du hast doch nur rumgeflucht mit dem Scheiß.
Nein, ich hab am Anfang einmal, als es Daten gefressen hat, rumgeflucht.
Und es hat nur einmal Daten gefressen?
Das ist ein Drobo 1, das ist wirklich seit am Anfang.
Ja, aber was willst du denn jetzt von uns hören?
Ich will es überhaupt erst mal hören, aber als Clemens gerade was vorgeschlagen hat, habt ihr ja dazwischen gequatscht.
Clemens schlägt nur Outsourcen vor, das ist kein Vorschlag, das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Ich hab mir gesagt, was ich vor ein paar Jahren mal benutzt habe, was immer noch läuft.
Promise-Dinge sind teuer.
Ist halt kein Nass.
Wieso ist das kein Nass?
Der steckt nicht auf dem Ethernet, in dem Sinne kein Network-Attached Storage, sondern ist halt mit Thunderbolt. Das gibt es jetzt mit Thunderbolt 3, das heißt, dass es ordentlich flinkt, dass man da seine Daten mittelfristig auch mal draufkriegt. Ja, weil hier bei deiner komischen 1-Gigabit-Infrastruktur von 1874, die du hier hast, in der Metaebene willst du dich ja nicht am Netz hängen haben, dein Nass. Alter, das sind nur 100 Megabyte pro Sekunde. Das ist einfach nothing.
120.
Backups reicht das.
Ja, dann reicht dir auch dein Backup in die Cloud mit 40 Megabit.
Moment, machst du ein Time Machine Backup über Internet? Nee, weil ich hatte nämlich auch schon mal wieder das Problem, dass das mal wieder nicht funktioniert.
Nee, das funktioniert auch nicht.
Auf worauf?
Auf ein …Time Machine.
Genau. Du benutzt im pregnancy Mountain einen WLAN im High Volume-Modus.
Ein Neta-Talk halt.
Ich habe mir, nachdem es das zweite Mal jetzt gefailt ist, also das zweite Mal dieser Fehler auftritt, erstmal bei Amazon schnell noch eine 4-TB Festplatte gekauft und mach jetzt eine. Was war denn dein erster Fehler?
Aber was war denn dein erster Fehler? Du bist nur so, hallo, kleiner Tipp am Rande. Hast du ein Ethernet-Dongle für deinen Mac?
Oder hat der noch eine richtige Ethernet-Shitstelle?
Dann häng den damit mal in deine Time-Capsule und lass mal die WLAN-Nummer weg, dann geht das auch.
Ja, er steht in einem anderen Zimmer, deswegen hab ich jetzt die Dings gekauft.
Dann kaufst du ein längeres Kabel.
Nee, ich hab mir jetzt einfach eine Festplatte gekauft.
Hörst du auch zu den Leuten, die in Wohnungen einziehen und nicht als erstes eine Kat-6-Verkabelung einziehen?
Eine was? Kat-6-A bitte, du möchtest ja schon noch TG abhaben.
Kat-6-A verkabelung.
Jetzt so langsam ausfällt.
Wo ist denn der große Knopf, der hier, der, äh, wie konnte ich überhaupt auf die Idee kommen, dass irgendein sinnvoller Vorschlag hier war?
Du willst nicht auf uns hören, du sitzt hier mit einem Raum voll Hacker und fragst uns, ob du eine Plastikkiste kaufen sollst.
Was willst du denn? Das Ding hier heißt Freak Show, not Computer Wizards Give You Useful Advice Podcast.
Mit Amazonas Pay.
Ich wollte sagen, bei mir zu Hause funktioniert das wunderbar. Huckel meint auch das.
Ich bin mal her, Remote. Also ich lad meinen Chisel ins Internet auf meinen Server.
Das machen wir zu langsam. Ich muss auch sagen, ich hab meinen Backup noch nie gebraucht, zum Glück. Also das Lokale hab ich ab und zu mal gebraucht, dieses Local Time Machine. Das funktioniert auch super, wenn der Ausweis jemand eine Datei löscht. Meine SSH, irgendwelche Keys hab ich auch immer weggekloppt. Den musste ich mal ganz schnell wiederholen. Aber sonst hab ich es noch nicht benötigt, glaube ich. Aber dieses Netatalk unter FreeBSD als Time-Machine-Ersatz läuft wirklich 1A spitzenmäßig. Aber ich glaube, Time-Machine wird sich sowieso demnächst ändern wegen APFS. Also ich hab bei Mojave jetzt noch nichts gesehen, aber es müsste eigentlich mal irgendwas passieren da, oder?
Okay, also ich nehme mit, ihr könnt mir in dem Sinne überhaupt keine Empfehlungen geben, aber vielleicht...
Doch, doch, dir gefallen die nur nicht. Kauf dir kein Obo und keine Synology Standardmaschine, waren wir alle der Meinung.
Ja, ich habe aber noch kein gutes Argument gehört.
The Promise Toys hat den Vorteil, es gibt dir die rohen Bits. Das ist einfach roter Blog-Storage. Dann machst du dein ZFS vor OSX drauf, dann hast du nämlich eine schöne, schöne, so Zeit und Backup für die Parallel-Nation.
Ich will einfach eine Lösung.
Das ist eine Lösung.
Ginge Frickel.
Das ist auch Ginge Frickel.
Nein.
Du kannst deine Nuss um mir auch irgendwie im Monat.
Geld geben und wir machen dir das.
Wir basteln dir deine schöne Lösung. Musst dich um nichts kümmern, musst nur überweisen.
Das wird dann auch so was wie ein Dauerauftrag.
Also das weiß ich zu Hause. Schauen wir mal, ob es noch mal nachbaut. Das ist ja kein Problem.
Kriegt er auch eine richtige Rechnung für?
Absolut.
Hab Steuernummer alles am Start.
Das wollen wir doch hoffen. Na gut, Leute, ich glaube, wir fahren es jetzt mal runter hier.
Warst du doch in Schweden, Heimlich?
Aber ich habe ja...
Benutzen gerne als Wort. So im täglichen Sport.
Die Brücke auf Schwedisch geguckt mit Untertitel.
Präzis und Absolut.
Leute, Schluss jetzt hier. Vier Stunden sind noch.
Alle sind original mit Untertitel. Außer Deutsch.
War schön mit euch. Wir sagen jetzt hier mal Tschüss. Nächste Sendung, wahrscheinlich erst in drei Wochen. Guck einfach mal den Plan. Wieso was? Ja, so ist das.
Mach mal in drei Wochen.
In drei Wochen kann ich nicht glauben. Thank you for coming.
Was auch immer es ist, ist nicht richtig auf dem Teleprompter. Ich kann es nicht lesen, es gibt keine Wörter auf dem Text.
Sting wird es machen, es ist ein Video, Sting-Video.
Ich kann es nicht machen.
Ich bin Bill O'Reilly.
Wir lassen dich mit Sting und einem Cut-Off sein neues Album.